Hallo Wolfgang!
Hallo Stefan!
Sag mal, du siehst aus, als wärst du Shoppen gewesen.
Ich war Shoppen, allerdings Online-Shopping.
Ganz neu, ich bin gespannt. Ist das ungewöhnlich für dich? Bist du ansonsten so ein haptischer Shopper?
So, wenn er auf Studien aus China verweist, heißt das ja schon mal, also diese Studie muss jetzt im über ein Jahr alt sein, weil in China gibt es ja schon seit über einem Jahr kein Corona mehr. Das ist also wirklich altes abgestandenes Wissen und das wurde dann entsprechend validiert. Jetzt kann man sich ja überlegen vor dem geistigen Auge, Innenräume sind das Problem. Wenn Innenräume das Problem sind, klammern wir mal private, also eigene Innenräume aus. Und jetzt überlegen wir, wenn jemand, der auch so einfach Homeoffice machen kann, der typischer Büroangestellter, gutes Gehalt und so weiter, wenn der zur Arbeit fährt, der verlässt seine Wohnung und steht sofort auf der Straße. Der geht nicht erst noch durch ein Treppenhaus. Dann steigt er in sein Auto und fährt bis zu seinem Stellplatz. Und dann geht er kurz durch den Flur und ist in seinem Büro. Und jetzt kann man ja die Alternative dazu. Also jemand, der im 13. Stock wohnt, kleine Wohnung und so weiter, der geht natürlich erst mal in so einen 2 m³ Fahrstuhl, ist dann da 2 Minuten drin, muss dann noch durchs Treppenhaus und so weiter.
Hat dort wahrscheinlich keine Maske an, weil man immer noch glaubt, man sei im privaten Raum. Das ist ja ein großes Problem, Treppenhäuser wird oft übersehen, dass das ganz entscheidend ist.
Genau, dann ist er am öffentlichen Nahverkehr, hat dann wahrscheinlich an der Arbeitsstelle nicht sein eigenes Büro mit 100 m³ Luft für sich alleine, sondern und so weiter. Also diese ganze Thematisierung. Und wie das mit den Aerosolen und welche Rolle sie spielen, das war, also Lanz hat ihn so eingeladen und dann können sie einfach mal erzählen. Und er hat sich dann auch wirklich diese 10 Minuten genommen. Wir gucken von diesen 10 Minuten mal so zusammengeschnurzelt fast 5 Minuten, weil es wirklich super interessant ist. Also ich habe viel gelernt, schon allein, dass der Begriff Aerosol völlig falsch benutzt bisher.
Ein Aerosol ist immer ein Gemisch aus Luft und Teilchen. Das heißt, wenn Herr von Schirach eine Zigarette raucht, dann ist dieser Rauch das Aerosol, nicht das Aerosolteilchen per se. Ja, das muss man erst mal vorweg sagen. Immer wenn irgendetwas in dem Raum schwebt, ist das ein Aerosolteilchen, aber nicht das Aerosol selbst. Wir leben in einem Aerosol. Um uns herum sind immer irgendwelche Teilchen in der Luft. Sie verteilen sich sehr schnell. Sie können das selbst mal ausprobieren. Wenn Sie ein Streichholz in einer Ecke Ihres Wohnzimmers anzünden, dann fragen Sie mal Ihre Frau, wie lange es dauert, bis Sie an der gegenüberliegenden Seite der Wand diesen Rauch riechen. Das geht relativ schnell, das dauert keine Minute. Dann ist der Rauch im gesamten Raum verteilt. Und diese Sachen passieren eben in Innenräumen. In Innenräumen kann sich diese Aerosol-Wolke, die kann ja nicht weg. Wir atmen in den Raum, diese Aerosol-Wolke dauert. Die konzentriert sich auf. Ich habe das Fenster zu, habe keine Lüftung. Wir zeigen mal kurz das Klassenzimmer, während Sie sprechen. Genau, Klassenzimmer, ja, da sieht man auch wieder, auch dann die Aerosole konzentrieren sich auf. So, und je länger...
Jetzt hat er selber den Fehler gemacht, dann konzentrieren sich die Aerosole auf, die Aerosol-Teilchen konzentrieren sich im Aerosol. Er macht den Fehler gleich noch mal, den er uns dann immer vorwirft, aber es stimmt. Also, das Aerosol ist die Wolke an sich, abgegrenzt durch Wände, Fenster und so weiter, aber die Wolke, wie sie als Luftmasse einfach da ist, wo wir eben sind. Jetzt wissen wir, draußen gibt es das nicht, ja, draußen ist alles gleich. Also, da schwebt es einfach davon und üblicherweise weht noch ein bisschen Wind und damit ist es sofort weg. Das hat ja auch Kachelmann noch mal, wir hatten ja damals im Aufwarn-Podcast thematisiert, dass zu Silvester sieben Wochen lang Straßenverkehr-Feinstaub wird in einer Silvesternacht durchgepeitscht. Das ist giftig, wenn man im Moment, wo es Feuerzeug brennt, drin steht. Aber wie Kachelmann darauf hinwies, nach fünf Minuten ist das verflogen. Also, das löst sich einfach auf. Das ist, wir reden ja nicht von CO2 und Klimagasen, sondern das ist der Feinstaub, der ist giftig. Aber sobald man einen Meter davon zurück tritt und der Wind in die richtige Richtung, kriegt man davon nichts von mir. Das löst sich sofort auf. Und jetzt, in Innenräumen ist es natürlich ganz anders. Und hier kommt auf die Klassenräume zu sprechen.
Ja, ich mich in dem Raum befinde. Umso höher ist die Konzentration dieser Viren, die ich jetzt ausatme, in dem Raum. Übrigens, und das ist sehr wichtig, das ist eine Erkenntnis, die ist noch nicht sehr alt. Wir atmen die Aerosole aus.
Die Aerosolteilchen, Gerhard, hast du uns doch ganz selbst erklärt.
Wir brauchen nicht zu sprechen. Wir brauchen nicht zu singen. Wir brauchen nicht zu husten und nicht zu niesen. Beim normalen Atmen entstehen diese Aerosole. Und diese Aerosolteilchen sind sehr, sehr klein, die beim Atmen entstehen. Die sind nur ein Zehntel Mikrometer groß und die schweben eben unendlich lange in der Raumluft. Die fallen nicht nach unten, die steigen zwar am Anfang nach oben, dann verteilen sie sich in dem ganzen Raum und dann bleibt diese Wolke, die wappert hier in dem Raum rum.
Wie lange, in so einem Klassenraum zum Beispiel?
Tage. Wenn sie den nicht lüften. Es gibt eine Studie aus den USA, die hat also gezeigt, dass am nächsten Tag, wenn ein Infizierter in einem Raum war, noch RNA, also Virus-RNA in der Luft nachgewiesen werden konnte. Tage. Am nächsten Tag.
So, und das muss man sich jetzt wirklich mal, wenn das so stimmt, heißt das, Innenraum ist einfach gefährlich und da ist Abstand egal in dem Falle, da ist alles egal. Wenn man rausgeht aus dem Raum, man schließt ihn ab, man kommt am nächsten Morgen wieder rein, hat man den gleichen Zustand wie vorher. Das Aerosol steht da. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich dieses Virus nochmal genau angucken. Fiel da durchs Fenster UV-Strahlung draus oder sonst irgendwas. Es ist ausgetrocknet, aber es ist erst mal noch da und es schwebt doch in der Luft. Und wenn es auch nach Tagen noch, also nach einem Tag noch eine Infektion sogar gab, die nachgewiesen wurde, weiß man, naja, eine Schulpause, eine Viertelstunde, die Kinder gehen mal kurz raus und wieder rein oder Hausflure und so weiter. Da weiß man, das ist die Falle sozusagen, das ist die Corona-Fall.
So, man weiß also, dass diese kleinen Aerosol-Teilchen sich sehr lange darin halten können. Ob die Viren dann noch aktiv sind oder nicht, das kann ich nicht sagen. Ich bin kein Virologe. Ich weiß nur, dass wir RNA nachweisen konnten. Was kann ich jetzt dagegen tun? Jetzt muss ich mir doch überlegen, was kann ich dagegen tun? Da gibt es eben sechs Maßnahmen, die man gegen solche Aerosol-Wolken tun kann. Das eine haben sie eben schon genannt. Das ist Lüften. Das ist eine Maßnahme. Aber es gibt eine viel effektivere Maßnahme. Die effektivste Maßnahme, die man tun kann, ist, mit möglichst wenigen Leuten in diesem Raum zu sein.
Das ist doch interessant, oder? Wichtiger noch als Lüften ist die Dichte in dem Raum. Da kann man überlegen, welche Rolle spielt es jetzt? Wie viele Leute wohnen in einem Raum? Wie viele Kinder teilen sich ein Kinderzimmer und so weiter und so fort? Wie viele Menschen teilen sich ein Wohnhaus, Treppenhaus, ein Großraumbüro und so weiter?
Ein ganz großes Problem ist das Mittagessen in den Betrieben.
Zum Beispiel.
Denn man hat dann zwar eine Maskenpflicht, aber wenn man in die Kantine oder es gibt ja einfache Aufenthaltsräume für Leute, die sich was mitgebracht haben, da erlebt man es ja dann häufig dann doch, dass man sagt, na gut, wir machen gerade das Fenster auf, aber jetzt haben wir ja alle die Masken auf, essen, reden auch miteinander und schon ist es da. Und das betrifft selbstverständlich auch wieder Leute, die nicht Vorstandsvorsitzende sind, die sich nicht in irgendeiner Leitfunktion in ihrem Büro was kommen lassen können und gar nicht in so einen Raum gehen müssen.
Kontakt haben Sie völlig recht, aber in Innenräumen. Die Anzahl der Personen in einem Raum geht quadratisch in das Infektionsgeschehen ein. Das heißt, wenn Sie die doppelte Zahl von Leuten in dem Raum haben, haben Sie vierfaches Risiko. Als die erste Pandemiewelle auf uns losging, war die erste Maßnahme, die die Regierung völlig richtig gemacht hat. Veranstaltungen über 1000 Personen verbieten, 100 Personen durften sich dann noch treffen, dann zehn, dann nur noch zwei. Das war perfekt. Sie haben quadratisch gearbeitet. Der R-Wert rauschte auf eins von drei. Alle anderen Maßnahmen brachten dann ein bisschen Wabbern in dem R-Wert. Aber das war die entscheidende Maßnahme. Das lag daran, dass sich dann plötzlich nicht mehr so viele Leute treffen konnten. Zweiter wichtiger Punkt, der wird immer wieder vergessen. Das ist die Zeit. Je länger ich mich mit einem Infizierten in einem Raum aufhalte, umso höher ist die Ansteckungsgefahr. Auch die Zeit geht quadratisch ein. Doppelte Zeit, vierfaches Ansteckungsrisiko. Deswegen habe ich und andere Forscher schon Mitte letzten Jahres empfohlen, Schulstunden zu verkürzen. Bitte überlegt euch doch mal, ob wir nicht die Schulstunden von 90 Minuten auf 45 Minuten, dann haben wir schon mal ein Faktor 4 gewonnen. Oder vielleicht sogar auf 30 Minuten verkürzen können. Dann haben wir ein Faktor 9 gewonnen. Faktor 9, nicht nur 9%. Also Zeit. Dann kommt ihr Lüften ins Spiel. Die Zeit kann ich natürlich jetzt strecken, indem ich oft lüfte. Je öfter ich das Fenster aufmache, umso länger kann ich mich in dem Raum aufhalten. Also, erster Punkt Anzahl der Personen, zweiter Punkt Zeit, ganz wichtig, dritter Punkt Lüften, vierter Punkt die Größe des Raumes. Hier in diesem Raum passiert uns nichts. Wir haben so viel Volumen um uns herum. Die Aerosolwolke wird so stark verdünnt, dass der Herr Lanz von meinen Aerosolwolken, von meinen Aerosolteilchen nicht mehr viel abbekommt.
So, wenn man das alles jetzt ernst nimmt und runterdampft und da braucht man jetzt auch keine große Expertise, sich sozialpolitische Maßnahmen überlegt, die der Corona-Eindämmung dienlich sind, dann weiß man doch eigentlich, wo man ansetzen muss, oder? Dass man es auch sehr spezifisch geht, dass man jetzt nicht flächendeckend, keine Ahnung, Helgoland, ja war ja gestern so ein bisschen Thema, Helgoland fällt in den Landkreis Pinneberg, da gibt es gar keine Infektion, das ist auch kilometerweit weg vom Land, aber da gilt jetzt auch Corona-Regeln. Warum eigentlich? Da wird ja auch Wind, da sind nicht viele und da ist auch ein bisschen Frühling jetzt, da ist man auch draußen. Warum gelten da eigentlich Corona-Maßnahmen? Warum gelten sie überhaupt so flächendeckend? Wir kommen ja nachher auf so Zahlen zu sprechen, wo man sich fragt, also flächendeckend ist hier kein guter Ansatz. Flächendeckend war nur ein guter Ansatz, um zu sagen, niemand darf mehr zu Tausenden in einen Raum gehen. Das ist eine gute pauschale Maßnahme. Danach wird es ein bisschen kritisch, also da muss man sich wirklich überlegen, was bedeutet das?
Und bringen wir doch nochmal das Beispiel Innenstädte. Wir haben in den Innenstädten Gott sei Dank ja immer noch viele kleine einzelne Geschäfte. Dort, wo ich zum Beispiel meine Schuhe kaufe, bin ich in der Regel, wenn keine Pandemie ist, ohnehin nur zu dritt oder zu viert in diesem Laden. Da sind zwei die bedienen und da sind vielleicht zwei Kunden und vielleicht haben die zwei Kunden auch noch Partner mit dabei, aber eigentlich ist da nichts. Nun könnte man mit der Corona-Regel das ja so machen, dass nur ein einziger Mensch in diesen Laden darf und nur auf einen einzigen Verkäufer trifft und außerdem gibt es Lüftungsmöglichkeiten und der Raum ist entsprechend groß und wir haben Masken an. Ich würde sagen, da ist das Infektionsrisiko gleich Null. Also da muss schon alles wirklich schief gehen und das geht eigentlich dann nur, indem jemand seine Maske nicht richtig trägt, der andere an der Seite vorbeibläst und so kann es irgendwie zu Aerosolaufkommen kommen. Es ist aber so, dass diese ganzen Geschäfte jetzt fast alle zu haben, höchstens noch klick-collect dürfen oder dass man jetzt sagt, naja, die müssen jetzt mit einem Schnelltest dort rein und müssen aber einen aktuellen Schnelltest haben, wo man genau weiß, naja, hier in den kleineren Städten werden jetzt nicht 60-jährige einen Schnelltest machen gehen, um sich Schuhe zu kaufen, um irgendwelche Deko-Artikel oder so zu kaufen. Das heißt, die kaufen es nicht, gehen dann online, vielleicht kaufen es dort oder machen Konsumaufschub und das führt dazu, dass, wie du eben das schon skizziert hast, die Innenstädte ganz anders aussehen, nämlich sehr tot in den nächsten Monaten und dass man da so fatal vorgeht. Das wäre übrigens jetzt auch ein schöner Angriffspunkt, mal wenn man solche Videos drehen will, wie Jan Josef Liefers, wo man genau solche Sachen mal herausheben kann, da sieht man einfach, wie diese flächendeckende Corona-Politik eigentlich eine Vernichtungspolitik von Selbstständigen, kleinen Selbstständigen ist, während die anderen es ja weiterhin nach oben transferiert bekommen und auch nicht diese Auflagen bekommen. Also es ist doch interessant, dass man immer noch keine Testpflichtunternehmer jetzt einmal in die Gesetze reingeschrieben hat, sondern nur eine Testangebotspflicht, während aber die Inhaber von Geschäften keine Kunden mehr empfangen dürfen, entweder, oder sie dürfen sie nur empfangen, ab einer gewissen Inzidenz, wenn diese Kunden dann einen aktuellen Test vorweisen. Also da gibt es in gewisser Weise eine Testpflicht, die dann der Kunde erbringen muss, und wenn der Kunde sie nicht erbringt, dann hat eben der Unternehmer das Nachsehen. Das ist ein solcher Skandal, dass man eine Umverteilung von unten nach oben macht und zugleich auch noch diese Selbstständigen in dieser Weise ausblendet, einfach aus der Wirtschaft. Und das finde ich auch so interessant, dass das auch gerade linke Strömungen überhaupt nicht richtig aufgreifen. Denn gerade für ganz viele Migranten, und zwar noch die Gastarbeitergeneration, aber auch die folgenden Generationen, oder die jetzt kommen, ist die Selbstständigkeit etwas ganz Existenzielles, um anzukommen, um integriert zu sein. Warum? Weil wir ja, darüber haben wir im vergangenen Jahr ja viel diskutiert, es immer wieder in Betrieben auch mit strukturellem Rassismus zu tun haben. Weil es doch für Leute, die einen Migrationshintergrund hat, oft schwierig ist, in der Gesellschaft ganz anzukommen. Deswegen ist gerade die Selbstständigkeit die Möglichkeit, sich zu verwirklichen und sich ein bisschen durch diese Selbstständigkeit zu schützen vor einem strukturellen Rassismus. Und gerade solche Existenzen werden jetzt kaputt gemacht.
Ja, aber das ist ja ein flächendeckendes Phänomen, das kennen wir ja in Deutschland auch schon vorher. Dieses Buch von Sarrazin, das dann aufgegriffen wurde als Grundlagenwerk für die AfD gilt, die immer als, wir sind die Unternehmer-Partei, wir kümmern uns um das große Ganze und da hat man völlig übersehen, dass natürlich jeder Obststand von einer Ich-Age, von einem Einzelunternehmer gemacht wurde, sondern, nee, den wollte man nicht. Die Großen, die Eten-Champions, das sind bei uns die Unternehmen, aber doch nicht diejenigen, die die kleinen Dienstleistungen machen, die wir natürlich alle brauchen. Du hast es angesprochen, ich finde das auch, ich will das nochmal betonen, anhand eines Beispiels, das er jetzt auch im April die Runde machte, Amazon verbietet seinen Mitarbeitern die FFP2-Maske, weil das zu mehr arbeitsrechtlich auch vorgesehenen, arbeitsschutzrechtlich vorgesehenen Pausen führt. Das bedeutet aber ganz konkret, in den Innenstädten darfst du nicht alleine im Laden, nicht mit einer FFP2-Maske, nicht mal mit einem negativen Test einkaufen gehen, denn der Laden ist einfach richtig zu. Also es ist richtige Vernichtungspolitik, die diesem Ladenbesitzer zuteil wurde. Er darf gerade nicht arbeiten und ob er danach mal wieder rauskommt, ist egal. Im Sinne von, daran wird jetzt nicht gedacht, denn der Shift findet ja statt, Leute gehen jetzt online kaufen. Es wird also die gleiche Ware verkauft, nur eben nicht in der deutschen Innenstadt unter coronasicheren Gesichtspunkten, sondern bei Amazon verpackt. Die Menschen, die dort arbeiten, werden nicht ordentlich geschützt und infizieren sich auch reinweise und das wird aber ausgeblendet und auch nicht miteinander aufgewogen, obwohl das genau die Rechnung ist. Die Ware kommt am Ende an beim Kunden, der sie will, nur wir haben zum einen den selbstständigen Ladenbesitzer den Laden zugemacht und gleichzeitig Amazon so ein Return-on-Infektions-Geschäftsmodell durchgehen lassen, weil die einfach ganz klar sagen, wenn uns so und so viele Leute durch den Ausbruch ausfallen, kalkulieren wir das auf, da kommt dann so eine Corona-Bilanz mit, die machen aber so und so viele Pausen, das wird ja bei Amazon genau kontrolliert, wer da wie in welchem Rhythmus arbeitet und die dürfen das einfach so durchkalkulieren und das passt einfach nicht zusammen, denn, und jetzt kommt der Punkt, wer arbeitet denn bei Amazon? Wer geht denn einkaufen im Inladen und wer arbeitet denn plötzlich bei Amazon, weil man nicht mehr im Laden selber kaufen kann? Also wer packt es für einen von einer Stange in die Kiste und bringt es dann nach Hause? Und da hören wir den dritten Clip von Gerhard Scheuch, der auch mal so ein bisschen zusammenbindet, was er uns gerade erklärt hat und da mal so einen sozialpolitischen Hinweis draus macht.
Lass uns wieder einen Aspekt anführen und den vergessen wir sehr oft. Es gibt Mitbürger, die in sehr beengten Wohnräumen leben. Und wenn man sich die Zahlen auf den Intensivstationen anguckt, dann fragen Sie mal die Intensivmediziner, wer dort hauptsächlich liegt. Es sind Leute aus wirtschaftlich sehr schwierigen Verhältnissen. Die haben sich nicht im Freien angesteckt. Die haben sich in ihren Wohnungen angesteckt, in ihren Wohnsilos, dort, wo sie wirklich eng zusammen wohnen müssen. Dort finden Ansteckungen statt. Und das übersehen wir einfach. Da gucken wir auf den Biergarten. Da gucken wir auf einen Jocker, der mit der Maske nicht rumläuft.
So, und jetzt ist die Frage, wir wurden jetzt im April darüber informiert, in Deutschland, flächendeckend. Vorher gab es das so als Thema nicht. Was weiß die Bundesregierung eigentlich? Oder was sollte sie wissen? Sie hat ja Wissensapparate, die ihr da zur Verfügung stehen, vor allem nicht das Robert-Koch-Institut. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, im Juli 2020 wurde ein Text eingereicht, im Journal of Health Monitoring, der im Oktober dann publiziert wurde, wissen wir, na der wurde so Mai, Juni erarbeitet. Es geht hier um Socio-Economic Inequalities and Covid-19. Also hier bindet man so richtig thematisch mal die sozioökonomischen Unterschiede, Ungleichheiten und Covid-19 zusammen. Und zwar anhand der Current International Literature, also immer auch eine große Literatur-Auswertung. Das sind also drei Leute vom RKI, die sich dann noch mal Uni Düsseldorffilfe geholt haben, vom Institute of Medical Sociology, also da kennt man sich aus. Man hat 5.248 Artikel von Preprint-Servern genommen und nochmal ergänzt durch 22.306 Artikel aus der Lit-Covid-Datenbank, wo also alles publiziert wurde, was irgendwie mit Corona zu tun hat. Hat sich dann für 10 fertige peer-reviewed-Texte entschieden, 30 nicht-peer-reviewed-Texte und nochmal 6 frei verfügbare, denn sehr viele Regierungen publizieren ja auch so einfach Daten zum wer ist da eigentlich wie betroffen und so weiter und so fort. 28 der Texte kamen aus Amerika, 16 aus England, da sieht man schon mal, ok, da wurde solche Forschung anscheinend ein bisschen intensiver betrieben. Eine aus Italien, eine aus Deutschland nur. Und die Ergebnisse sind Most Studies, nämlich 44 der 46, reportieren sozioökonomische Unterschiede hinsichtlich, dass diejenigen mit niedrigem sozioökonomischen Status mehr effektet sind, also mehr von Corona betroffen sind. Sieben Studien kommen allerdings auch darauf zu sprechen, dass höher sozioökonomisch stehende härter getroffen waren. Es gibt einen Unterschied, aber er schlägt in beide Richtungen aus. Die einzige deutsche Studie, die hier drin war, war der einzige Text, der sich damit befasst, nicht nur einen Snapshot zu machen, wir gucken jetzt mal, wer ist hier infiziert, sondern wir gucken uns auch mal den Verlauf an, also den Shift, der dokumentiert wurde. Das bedeutet, und das ist jetzt Juli 2020, der Wissensstand des RKI, Juli 2020, in Germany's southern regions, also Bayern und Baden-Württemberg, war am Anfang bis Mitte April die höheren sozioökonomischen Status Menschen, also Menschen, die sich einen Tourismus-Ausflug ins Skigebiet leisten können, die internationale Freundschaften pflegen und so weiter. Die waren zuerst härter betroffen und dieser Socio-Economic Gradient, also der Anstieg, wenn man sich das als Graf, wer der Graf, der am einen Spektrum niedrig ist, sozioökonomisches Status zu hoch, der hat sich im Mitte April gedreht, was im Grunde bedeutet, die Reichen haben Corona mitgebracht und dann ist es bei den Armen hängen geblieben. Die Reichen konnten sich dann schützen. Die haben gesehen, oh, hier ist ein Problem, wir reagieren. Die Armen wollten auch reagieren und haben es dann aber nicht geschafft. Das ist die Erfahrung aus der ersten Welle. Also im Februar geht das so los, man hört die Berichte im März. Leute kommen aus Tirol zurück und sehen dann die Bergamo-Bilder und wissen, jetzt müssen wir alle mal reagieren. Und die Reichen schaffen es und die Armen schaffen es nicht. Und für die Armen wurde aber Corona mitgebracht. Die haben es nicht eingeschleppt, denn die waren ja nirgendwo. Also da hat das RKI das hier mal dokumentiert, dass am Anfang die höheren Stati, oder wie auch immer der Blue-Hat ist, infiziert waren, das mitbrachten und dass es sich dann in den niedrigen Status austobte.
Nun frage ich dich, warum erfahren wir das jetzt erst im April? Warum ist das jetzt erst im April Thema? Beziehungsweise, warum geht das RKI nicht damit direkt an die Front und macht das bei diesen ganzen Pressekonferenzen statt, die ganze Zeit immer nur noch mal R-Wert erklären, noch mal Inzidenzen, und wir glauben, dass wenn es so und so, dann wird es in drei Wochen. Das wären doch mal wirkliche Meldungen, die dann auch die Politik herausfordert, dass sie etwas tut. Aber offenbar hat man ja den Eindruck, als hätte es da einen Deckel draufgegeben, dass man sagte, naja gut, aber das wollen wir jetzt mal nicht so hoch spielen. Macht ja nichts, wenn die da unten das bekommen.
Du erinnerst dich ja an die Stimmung damals. Hendrik Streeck macht eine Studie, die dann irgendwie politisch ausgeschlachtet wird. Plötzlich dreht sich das so alles. Und jede Idee, die plötzlich aus dieser Richtung kommt, wird negiert und gesagt, die ist schlecht. Wie zum Beispiel, wir machen mal ein Ampelsystem. Bei Inzidenz 100 gilt etwas, das nicht erst politisch entschieden werden muss, wenn dann Inzidenz bei 100 ist. Das war ja Hendrik Streecks Vorschlag von vor einem Jahr. Das ist genau das, was wir jetzt gerade machen. Nur jetzt ist es irgendwie quatschig. Damals hätte es echt super Sinn gemacht. Also dieses Ampelsystem. Dann Risikogruppen schützen. Nee, das geht nicht. Die Inzidenz muss insgesamt runter. Es macht keinen Sinn, Risikogruppen einzeln zu schützen. Damals waren die Risikogruppen die Alten, weil die Krankheit die Alten trifft. Nur was das Infektionsgeschehen angeht, wissen wir, die Risikogruppen sind auch die Armen. Und wir wissen, dass die Bundesregierung keinen Bock hat auf sozialpolitische Maßnahmen. Man will sich mit den Armen nicht beschäftigen. Also macht mal lieber so ein allgemeines Theater und erzählt irgendwie das Märchen von, wir müssen die Gesamtinzidenz im Blick behalten. Bis hin zu, dass ja dann auch im Herbst diskutiert wurde mit Daniel Günther. Warum muss Daniel Günther für Schleswig-Holstein irgendwelche Entscheidungen treffen? Weil in Bayern, in Tirschenreuth die Inzidenz hoch ist. Ergibt ja heute noch keinen Sinn, wird aber immer noch so geregelt. Naja, die Frage allerdings völlig berechtigt, warum hat man sich dafür nicht interessiert? Warum es jetzt plötzlich aufpockt im April 2020? Sagen wir mal so, man kam nicht mehr ganz drumrum. Jan Böhmermann hat ja jetzt diesen Tweet gemacht, Zitat, die Inzidenz in Köln nach Stadtteilen. Beachten Sie den Unterschied in der Inzidenz zwischen beiden sozialen Brennpunkten. Hannwald, Willenviertel, Inzidenz 0, 0 und Korweiler, Hochhaussiedlung, Inzidenz 520, 1. Also irgendwann ist das Problem so krass aufgetreten, dass man nicht mehr drum rumkommt. Und das, was hier für Köln, wir haben es letztes Mal schon gesagt, das was in Scheffelt gilt, gilt für alle Großstädte Nordrhein-Westfalen. Das sehen wir jetzt hier. Es gilt in Köln, es gilt natürlich auch in Essen, in Dortmund, überall. Das gilt in Frankfurt, es gilt in Hamburg und in Berlin. Diese Inzidenzen werden je nach sozialen Brennpunkt krass unterschiedlich verteilt.
Man hätte ja auch die Priorisierungsdebatte vollkommen anders aufgrund dieser Datenlage führen können. Man hätte dann nämlich dann sagen können, die, die an der Front sind, die an den Kassen sitzen, die in den Werken tätig sind, die das bei Amazon packen, damit ich nicht raus muss, die müssen zuerst geimpft werden. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt nicht dafür, dass wir wieder alles umstellen oder so. Jetzt ist es auch zu spät. Aber es ist jetzt ganz interessant, dass man das nicht machte, sondern hier ganz im Modus Rentenrepublik hat man immer nur geguckt, ja, wer ist denn wie sterblich dann, dann und dann, und dann ist man da durchgegangen, wo man ja auch zugleich sagen kann, nein, über 70-Jähriger kann sich auch besten schützen, weil er zum Beispiel nicht mehr zur Arbeit muss, wenn er vermögend ist und genügend Räumlichkeiten hat, um sich auch dann abzukapseln von jemand, der es hat. Wenn dann natürlich die Großfamilie zusammen in einer Wohnung lebt, ist es wieder schwieriger. Aber das ist eine Priorisierung, die man gar nicht vorgenommen hat. Auch interessant, dass da der Ethikrat natürlich solche ökonomischen Dinge gar nicht im Blick hat.
So, ich nenne euch jetzt mal die beiden Texte, die ich eben referiert habe. Also es ist zum einen diese Literaturstudie DOI 10.25646 slash 7059. Ich werde es auch im Text schreiben. Und dann diese spezifisch deutsche Studie des RKI, wo man nochmal diesen Shift dokumentiert hat. Auch aus der gleichen Journal of Health Monitoring 2020.5, also im Oktober publiziert, aber im Juli geschrieben und im Mai, Juni arbeitet. Das ist DOI 10.25646 slash 7057. Kann man selber nachschauen. Und jetzt springen wir ein bisschen nach vorne. Das RKI hat es dann jetzt im Januar im Ärzteblatt nochmal für alle, also Januar 2021. Da haben wir natürlich schon Erfahrung mit der zweiten Welle. Da waren wir ja mittendrin. Und jetzt, das kann ich zum Glück auf Deutsch lesen, das ist ein ganz interessantes Zitat. Also das RKI im Januar im Ärzteblatt. Wie bereits in der ersten Welle der SARS-CoV-2-Epidemie in Deutschland sind auch zu Beginn der zweiten Welle zunächst höhere Inzidenzraten in sozioökonomisch besser gestellten Regionen festzustellen. Mit Voranschreiten der zweiten Welle kehrte sich dieses Muster jedoch um, sodass Menschen in sozioökonomisch stark deprivierten Regionen schließlich am häufigsten betroffen waren. Diese Befunde weisen darauf hin, dass sozioökonomisch besser gestellte Bevölkerungsgruppen für die anfängliche Dynamik einer SARS-CoV-2-Welle eine bedeutende Rolle spielen, möglicherweise aufgrund einer höheren Mobilität durch überregionale Geschäftsbeziehungen und Urlaubsreisen oder stärkere Pendlerverflechtung zwischen sozioökonomisch besser gestellten Regionen im dann folgenden Infektionsgeschehen, also während der anhaltenden Hochinzidenzphase der zweiten Welle, verlagerte sich das Infektionsgeschehen zunehmend auf Menschen der sozioökonomisch benachteiligten Regionen. Jetzt füge ich an, die dann dem auch nicht entrinnen konnten durch all die Sachen, die der Scheuch hier gerannt hat und dass man da niemals drüber nachdachte.
Und das ist ja schön, dass das wieder so gekommen ist. Und man hat das ja gesehen, dann im Herbst ist nochmal alles schnell ins Flugzeug gestiegen, ist nochmal irgendwo hingeflogen. Ich erinnere da auch an so eine Twitter-Sache von einer SPD-Influencerin, die wohl auf Dubai mal unterwegs war noch rasch, als wir hier schon in den Lockdown gingen, ja, so Sachen. Das ist schon ganz großartig zu sehen.
Und jetzt wissen wir ja, im Dezember starben 21.626 Leute und im Januar 2021 dann 21.374. Also über 43.000 Menschen von insgesamt 80.000. Also die ganzen Corona-Toten in Deutschland fallen ja zur Hälfte auf Dezember und Januar. Und das korreliert – und jetzt lese ich nochmal aus dem Erzeblatttext vom Januar 2021 – ab Meldewoche 49, 30.11. bis 6.12.2020, lag die Inzidenz bei beiden Geschlechtern in stark deprivierten Regionen am höchsten. Also wir hatten die Corona-Welle, also die zweite Corona-Welle, die Weihnachtswelle, wo wir jetzt von der Charité diese Dokumentation haben, wie es auf den Zinssivstationen zuging, als da wirklich 40 Leute starben, die da alle in 50 Betten lagen. Dieser Gipfelpunkt der Corona-Pandemie bisher in Deutschland, in diesem Moment, als dieser Gipfel erreicht wurde, war Corona, was die sozioökonomische Grundlage angeht, am größten ausgeprägt. Also das war der Gipfelpunkt in beiden Dimensionen. Allgemein Corona-Infektionsgeschehen und in der sozialen Differenzierung, wo Corona zuschlägt. Also wenn man Corona bekämpfen will, würde ich sagen, weiß man eigentlich schon seit ziemlich lange in Berlin, wo man da ansetzen könnte, müsste.
Ja, aber man möchte noch nicht mal kostenlose FFP2-Masken zur Verfügung stellen, noch nicht mal kostenlose Schnelltests. Also das ist schon fast wie bei Malte. Als hätte man da Malthus gelesen. Also das ist schon skandalös. Das ist wirklich skandalös. Und noch ebenso skandalös ist das dann auch, dass so wenig von der Opposition aufgegriffen wird. Also von den Grünen hört man ja so gut wie gar nicht zum Beispiel davon. Das wäre auch wieder mal ein Thema gewesen.
Genau und jetzt gibt es einen Nachtrag, den hängen wir kurz an. Denn es ist ja die Frage, wie wird das jetzt diskutiert? Und wir wissen, wie das im Bundestag diskutiert wird. Wir hören hier mal kurz rein. Gottfried Kurio von der AfD.
Das erinnert an die Superspreader-Events arabisch, türkischer Großhochzeiten und Beerdigungen, Hotspots bei Fastenbrechen, bei Türkei Reiserückkehrern. Warum wird diese Gruppe der Regelverweigerer nicht gezielt adressiert? Warum nicht mit Maßnahmen gegengesteuert? Ist die Erzählung vom Multikulti-Erfolgsmodell wichtiger als die Bekämpfung des Virus?
So hört sich das an, wenn solche Sachen, wie wir sie eben besprachen, nicht diskutiert werden, weil dann nämlich die Korrelation greift, arme Menschen haben häufiger Migrationshintergrund als reiche Menschen in Deutschland. Es ist dieser strukturelle Rassismus, dass natürlich Migrationshintergrund, also Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund werden gewisse Arbeitsverträge, Mietverträge verweigert und so weiter, deswegen kommt ihre Biografie nicht so richtig in Fahrt. Sie müssen dann in den Wohnen großen Häusern leben, bei Amazon arbeiten und in Großraumbüros. Der ganze Rattenschwanz der Sozialpolitik hängt da natürlich dran. Und jetzt wurde das ja ein bisschen thematisiert, beispielsweise hier gestern bei Christian Sievers im Heuterschanal. Er moderiert es wie folgt.
Dabei fällt überdeutlich auf, in Hamburg, Bremen, Köln, überall dort, wo die Menschen ärmer sind, wo sie enger zusammenleben, in einfachen Jobs arbeiten, dort wütet Corona ganz besonders.
So, er macht also das Armutsargument und er fügt sogar noch mal an, dass es wenig belastbares Wissen gibt.
Sind Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund stärker von Corona betroffen als andere? Schon im letzten Sommer hatten Ärzte so etwas berichtet aus eigenem Erleben. Wirklich belastbare Statistiken oder Studien dazu gibt es aber bis heute nicht.
Das hindert ihn aber gar nicht dran, das Gespräch, das er dann zum Thema mit Nellis Pärtin führt, in skandalöser Art und Weise zu führen. Wir hören ja mal drei Fragen von ihm. Die drei Fragen. Es ist beispielhaft für das ganze Gespräch. Ich glaube, es sind sogar nur die drei Fragen, die überhaupt drin vorkommen.
Güller ist Staatssekretärin für Integration in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Und jetzt bei uns. Schönen guten Abend, Frau Güller. Ja, Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund, stark betroffen von Corona, möglicherweise überproportional stark. Warum ist das in der Öffentlichkeit so wenig Thema?
So, und dann gibt es hier eine gute Antwort.
Also man suggeriert jetzt hier natürlich schon mal, wie die AfD. Darf man ja nichts sagen. Wir dürfen ja nichts mehr gegen Migranten sagen und deswegen wird das dethematisiert. Also das ist ja, das ist ja die eigentliche Tonlage dieser Frage.
Genau, und beim Thema, warum wissen wir so wenig darüber, obwohl er eben selber noch gesagt hat, also dass es jetzt Migrat in uns in der Grund ist, wahrscheinlich ist es einfach Armut, dass Ausschleit eben ist, nur dass es da hoch korreliert. Das klingt dann bei ihm im Frageverlauf so.
Gibt es darüber hinaus aus Ihrer Ansicht, aus Ihrer Einsicht möglicherweise bei manchen Migrantinnen und Migranten auch das Problem, dass sie sich einfach nicht genug als Teil dieses Staates fühlen und demnach auch nicht genug verpflichtet, dessen Corona-Regeln umzusetzen?
Also, wenn das keine sukzessive Frage ist, das ist skandalös und die...
Aber das, ich meine, Wieler hatte ja auch schon so Äußerungen mal in der Bildzeitung getätigt und Spahn hat ja jetzt auch nochmal gesagt, ja, wir wissen gar nicht, ob wir da mit den Impfungen bei den Migranten, da wird noch, das wird ein hartes Stück Arbeit, die zu überreden. Und wo ich sage, du hast zunächst mal mit deiner Impfpolitik dafür gesorgt, dass wir ganz, ganz viele Corona-Tote mehr haben. Also jetzt nimm dich mal zurück und frag jetzt nicht, wer sich da jetzt gerade noch nicht impfen lassen kann. Die meisten Leute wollen und können nicht.
Ja, genau. Und bei Sachen Überzeugungsarbeit, also die scheint ja wohl mehr bei den Querdenkern gescheitert zu sein. Und da sehe ich aber keine Migranten, die da irgendwie rumlaufen. Also das wirklich, und Christian Siebers hier, noch so eine Frage.
Jetzt scheinen auch viele Zweifel, viele Ängste geradezu im Umlauf zu sein. Falsche Gerüchte, der Impfstoff sei unrein, im Ramadan dürfe man nicht geimpft werden. Wie kommt man denn gegen sowas an?
Ja, also ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass wir muslimische verblendete Menschen haben, sondern das sind dann doch eher andere. Das sind zum Beispiel diese ganzen alten Rentner, die sich hier in Hessen einfach nicht impfen lassen wollen. Die lassen diese Impftermine einfach verstreichen. Wir hören das von, also zu einem Viertel gehen die Impfberechtigten in Hessen nicht hin, weil es AstraZeneca ist wahrscheinlich, ist die Vermutung, die natürlich noch mal genährt wird davon, dass wir wissen, Horst Seehofer stolz darauf zu verkünden, dass er mit BioNTech geimpft wurde, während gleichzeitig Christian Drosten in seinem Podcast sagt, also wer sich heute in Seehofers Alter, er hat nicht Seehofer gesagt, aber wer sich in Seehofers Alter heute nicht mit AstraZeneca, sondern mit BioNTech impfen lässt, nimmt im Juni einem jüngeren Menschen die BioNTech-Impfung weg. Aber das wird völlig, ach das ist doch kein Skandal, dass der Seehofer da in der Bundespressekonferenz damit prahlt, natürlich mit BioNTech geimpft worden zu sein. Das ist wirklich gruselig. Manchmal bei der FDP, Christian Lindner kommuniziert ja jetzt immer sehr staatstragend, er will ja wieder eine Rolle spielen, aber auch er hat dann noch mal diese Hinweise, die natürlich, wenn man sie nicht richtig einordnet, immer in die falsche Richtung führen.
Weil wir eine sehr starke Diskussion führen müssten darüber, ob wir eigentlich alle Teile der Bevölkerung erreichen. Ja, wir sind da immer sehr vorsichtig mit dieser Argumentation, aber hier geht es ja um den Schutz und da gibt es eben doch Evidenz, dass Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund nicht über die gesundheitlichen Risiken in gleicher Weise aufgeklärt sind. Auch so eine Art von Sofortmassenarbeit, die man es einleiten müsste.
Ja, also es ist der sozioökonomische Status, der peripher natürlich mit Migrationshintergrund korreliert und klare Zusammenhänge aufweist, aber es ist der sozioökonomische Status, der ja ausschlaggebend ist und nicht erreichen wir die nicht, kriegen wir das nicht übersetzt.
Naja, also das ist wir und da möchte ich jetzt mal, weil eben das über die Presse und diese Sache, die sagen alle dasselbe, aber man kann hier tatsächlich mal von der Mainstream Presse reden. Die Mainstream Presse macht eine Politik, die so gestaltet ist, dass man immer versucht, das sozioökonomische auszublenden und es stattdessen auf die Migranten abzuschieben. Das ist Mainstream Presse. Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber das ist Mainstream Presse und die Politiker machen das auch von der Opposition, wie wir es hier sehen und natürlich die wirklich asozial regierende Bundesregierung macht das auch und das ist eine wirklich skandalöse Vorgehensweise. Und da müsste eigentlich jetzt die große Presse Kritik kommen, weil das, was du da jetzt eben mit den drei Fragen davor geführt hast, das ist ja wirklich reinste Demagogie, nichts anderes.
Weiß uns doch mal das fröhliche Klima-Thema.
Was das Klima so bringt. Also erst einmal kann man da Fröhliches verkünden. So sieht es zumindest Jütte Gute Land, das EU-Klimagesetz. Sie erzählt jetzt mal, dass das ein großer Erfolg ist. Das hat man jetzt vor wenigen Tagen ja auf den Weg gebracht.
Das ist nun wirklich ein historischer Augenblick. Das soll nun wirklich das bedeutsame Klimagesetz werden, das wir immer angestrebt haben.
Wir haben dafür gesorgt, dass wir auch ein Budget für die Treibhausgase bekommen.
Viele hatten das ja vor den Verhandlungen schon gesagt.
Ihr schafft das nicht.
Doch, ich bin sehr stolz, dass es uns gelungen ist, hier hinzukommen.
Was für eine Veranstaltung war das? Die EU stellt es vor?
Ja, die EU stellt es vor. Kleine Pressekonferenzen, nichts großes. Aber man hat dann gleich noch bei der ARD Michael Bloß mal zugeschaltet. Grüner aus dem EU-Parlament. Und der ist nicht so euphorisch. Der hat da die ganze Nacht mit denen debattiert.
Ja, wir hatten wirklich 15 Stunden Verhandlungen. Und dann ist da sehr wenig bei rausgekommen. Das Parlament ist eigentlich in all seinen Forderungen eingeknickt. Und ist dann dem Rat, also den Mitgliedsstaaten, gefolgt. Gerade, was das Klimaziel angeht, also wie viel CO2 wir in den nächsten zehn Jahren reduzieren wollen. Da sind wir mit 60 Prozent gestartet als europäisches Parlament und haben uns am Ende nur auf 52, 8 Prozent geeinigt. Und die Bundesregierung, die hat da auch wirklich im Rat… Na, die 55, die werden jetzt immer gesagt, aber es ist ein Nettoziel. Und von dem Nettoziel, da müssen sie die Senken, also die Wälder, die jetzt neu mit eingerechnet werden, die müssen sie davon abziehen, das sind 225 Megatonnen. Wenn sie das tun, dann kommen sie bei den 52, 8 Prozent an und das ist zu wenig. Und ja, an wem lag es? Es lag an den Mitgliedstaaten, aber eben auch an der Bundesregierung, die keine Ambitionserhöhung zugelassen hat.
Ich frage mich immer, wie die EU das so kalkuliert. Also was ist jetzt die Auswirkung für Deutschland, dass wir dann irgendwann hier Verbote bekommen, weil die in der EU beschlossen wurden oder wie hängt das zusammen?
Ja, zumindest gibt es jetzt auch so eine Geschichte, dass alles, was die EU genehmigt nochmal so geprüft werden muss von einem Expertenrat, ob das so ist und wie das dann mit Deutschland ist, also da gibt es jetzt eigentlich den großen Kampf, der wird im nächsten Monatjahr stattfinden. Franz Zimmermann hat das ja jetzt angekündigt, dass man wohl schon sehr weit ist bei dieser Idee, wie weit man so eine Ausgleichsbremse macht bzw. wie weit es auch mit reingerechnet werden darf. Wenn Unternehmen Deutsche jetzt im Ausland produzieren, ist das dann einfach, damit haben wir nichts zu tun, das ist ja irgendwo anders, das ist ja nicht in der EU und jetzt gibt es aber da verschiedene problematische Konstellationen. Zum einen hat natürlich die Industrie ein großes Interesse, dieses Outsourcing machen zu können, ohne dass das irgendwie mitten in die Bilanz geht. Zum anderen gibt es aber auch den Vorwurf aus dem Ausland, ja ihr macht jetzt Protektionismus, dann dürfen die bald nicht mehr im Ausland arbeiten, sondern machen das dann einfach bei euch, weil das für sie ja keinen Vorteil mehr bringt, dass sie dort irgendwo die Umwelt verpesten. Das ist protektionistisch. Das sieht Amerika so, das sieht auch China so und da muss man also mal schauen, was man dort konstruiert. Ich bin da auch ein bisschen skeptisch, ob das tatsächlich dann zu einem Erfolg führt, wie er eigentlich sein muss, damit man da tatsächlich mal was Großes macht. Also ob Gute Land da Recht hat, dass das jetzt hier der große Schritt ist, naja, seien wir mal zögerlich. Blicken wir aber mal jetzt mit dem, was wir da jetzt erfahren haben, also die EU tut was, nach Amerika blicken wir zu der Klimakonferenz, die Biden veranstaltet hat. Biden war dann auch da. Übrigens waren dann immer alle zugeschaltet. Man hat die dann auch auf verschiedenen Monitoren gesehen. Also sie waren schon anwesend, wenn auch nur in digitaler Form. Es war also nicht so gewesen, dass da einfach jeder ein Video hingeschickt hat, sondern man hat schon miteinander in irgendeiner Weise konferiert, so gut das ging. Und natürlich waren erst einmal die Staatschefs dran und auf diese konzentrieren wir uns jetzt auch. Und jetzt kommt erstmal Biden, der dieses Klima-Thema ganz Arbeitsplatz-politisch angeht.
The signs are unmistakable, the science is undeniable, but the cost of inaction keeps mounting. The United States isn't waiting, we are resolving to take action. Not only our federal government, but our cities and our states, all across our country. Small businesses, large businesses, large corporations, American workers in every field. I see an opportunity to create millions of good-paying middle-class union jobs. I see line workers laying thousands of miles of transmission lines for a clean, modern, resilient grid. I see workers capping hundreds of thousands of abandoned oil and gas wells that need to be cleaned up and abandoned coal mines that need to be reclaimed, putting a stop to the methane leaks and protecting the health of our communities.
Das ist allerdings dieses Muster, dass die Grünen sich noch nicht so richtig zutrauen, aber das haben wir ja von allein letztes Jahr schon gehört. Diese grüne Wende ist die Wachstumsstrategie, die man nicht nur macht, weil Grün ist gut, sondern weil man auch sonst keine hat. Man hat ja keine weitere Wachstumsstrategie. Das ist die einzige, die übrig blieb. Also macht man jetzt hier so Win-Win eigentlich draus.
Und er zählt das dann noch weiter auf, wo er überall Arbeiter sieht. Und er hat da noch mal wirklich den amerikanischen Typus des Arbeiters irgendwie vor Augen oder er imaginiert ihn zumindest dort in der Rede und sagt genau das, was du jetzt gerade gemeint hast. Wir haben es da mit einem Buben zu tun.
Ich hoffe, dass die Grünen sich gut beraten lassen und den Mut noch finden. Annalena Baerbock hat das ja die letzten Jahre eigentlich schon immer gemacht. Diesen Hinweis, wer den deutschen Wohlstand erhalten will, muss jetzt diesen Shift machen. Da reicht das konservative Denken nicht weiter. Und sie hat ja mit Laschet eigentlich genau den Counterpart. Das ist ja genau wie auch Söder erstichelt ja als immer mal wieder. Und Laschet so in diese Kohle- und Stahl-Ecke und genau das ist es.
Und jetzt hat er ja auch noch März mit im Boot. Laschet, da sieht man, dass er überhaupt nicht in der Gegenwart ankommen möchte. Und das ist auch dann aber zu erleben. Ich habe das jetzt nicht noch mal in Auszügen hier, weil ich uns das allen ersparen will, wie Merkel dann bei dieser Klimakonferenz darüber redet. Sie hat überhaupt nicht eine solche Vision. Also sie sagt dann, ja, wir tun jetzt das eine oder andere und haben jetzt auch mit der EU das so und so durchgebrannt. Aber das sieht es mal signalisiert und man merkt auch hier einfach bei Biden, da hat sich jetzt jemand hingesetzt und hat eine Rede dem geschrieben. Eine richtig gute Rede. Bei Biden ist das nochmal durchgegangen, gesagt, ich möchte ganz klar so Working Class auch mit drin haben. Ich will sagen, da sind Small Business, die entstehen. Nicht nur für die großen Konzerne wird das wichtig sein. Und da ist es jetzt eine sieben- achtminütige Rede, die richtig amerikanisch ist, aber die gut ist. Und die glaube ich auch ganz viele noch erreichen kann, die man zumindest irgendwie erreichen kann. Man kann jetzt irgendwelche Verschwörungstheoretiker oder sowas sicherlich nicht. Aber wenn man dann sieht, wie Merkel sich dort präsentiert, sie hat dann so drei, vier Zettel, von denen sie ihre Stichpunkte abliest, und dann ist das einfach nur so ein bisschen, ja, wir sind auch alle dafür, dass wir was fürs Klima machen. Also dass man sich dann gar nicht mehr die Mühe gibt, zu sagen, ich versuche jetzt noch mal ein bisschen was hier mitzureißen oder versuche auch mal einen solchen Ton zu treffen wie Biden, ist schon interessant. Das Einzige, was sie dann sagt, ist, ja, wir müssen jetzt auch mal auf die Entwicklungsländer blicken. Da verspricht sie Folgendes.
Wir brauchen vor allen Dingen Solidarität mit den Entwicklungsländern. Als Industrieländer haben wir uns verpflichtet, bis 2020 jährlich 100 Milliarden für die Klimafinanzierung aufzubringen. Das soll bis 2025 mindestens fortgeschrieben werden. Wir haben in Deutschland unsere Klimafinanzierung bis 2020 verdoppelt in diesem Zusammenhang auf 4 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr und werden auch in den kommenden Jahren unseren fairen Beitrag leisten.
Man hört es so richtig raus, dann zweigen wir so ein bisschen aus unseren Produktionserlösen ab und geben das noch den armen Ländern und dem Klima, dass es hier aber um den Umbau des erlösbringenden Wirtschaftens geht. Das schlägt sich da überhaupt nicht nieder. Das ist wirklich ganz traurig zu hören.
Ja, ich kann dem nichts hinzufügen, möchte jetzt aber mit was noch Schlimmeren kommen, denn es geht natürlich noch viel, viel krasser. Wir blicken kurz mal nach Brasilien, Bolsonaro, der rechtsradikale Präsident war auch zugeschaltet. Und erstmal klingt alles ganz toll. Wir hören uns jetzt mal den ersten Clip an.
Ich erinnere dich an unsere Gründer, die nicht nur von unseren Erschöpfungen so far, sondern auch von den Erschöpfungen, die wir bereit sind, vor den nächsten Generationen zu gehen.
Ja, erstmal denkt man, achja, das ist ja toll, das ist hier das Powerhouse und das ist ja auch unsere grüne Lunge und die Regenwälder, die sahen wir aber komischerweise doch die ganze Zeit brennen und die Indigenen, die werden da regelrecht ausgerottet und Biodiversität überhaupt nicht, sondern man versucht eigentlich immer wieder neue Märkte zu erschließen, indem man Natur kurz und klein schlägt und sagt, hier kann man auch noch wunderbar Ressourcen abbauen und sie ins Ausland verkaufen.
Das klingt auch, als würde er in sein Propagandahandy an seinem Küchentisch widersprechen.
So, aber er stimmt dann jetzt nochmal mit Biden hier ganz zu.
Mr. President, we could not agree more with your call for establishing ambitious commitments on the climate agenda. Accordingly, I have determined that our climate neutrality in Brazil be achieved by 2050. Therefore, bringing forward by 10 years the previously announced commitment levels. Among the measures that are required to that end, may I highlight here our commitment to eliminate illegal deforestation in Brazil by 2030.
Auf den Clip wollte ich auch via Deutschlandfunk kurz hingewiesen. Die haben das auch mal gemessiert, dass er ja nur die illegale Abholzung dort jetzt behandelt hat.
Ich vermute, da sind dann wirklich irgendwelche Indigenen betroffen, die man Raum gefällt haben. Die werden jetzt unter dem Vorwand, wir machen ja Klimapolitik, daran gehindert. Und tatsächlich ist dann für Großkonzerne dort Platz. Ja, wir hören das und dann gibt es aber dann immerhin noch so das Versprechen. Ja, aber 2050 werden wir so und so vorgehen. Und eigentlich sind wir uns da ganz einig und wir schreiten jetzt Seite an Seite mit Amerika voran. Einen Tag später macht Bolsonaro das hier, ein Clip aus Nachrichten. Ich glaube, das ist Vion.
Brazil hat entschieden, die Umgebung auf die Umwelt zu kürzen, einen Tag nach dem Pläger des US-Klima-Summits. Diese Entscheidung kommt, obwohl die zaubernde Verwundung in den Ländern der Amazon-Rainforest und der zerstörten Waldfeuerung stattfindet. Das Präsidenten von Brasilien, Jair Bolsonaro, hat eine Umgebung von 24% zu dem Umweltbudget von letztes Jahr erhoben. Bolsonaro hat eine Liste um Umweltbudget-Vertrag von 43, 8 Millionen Dollar, zum einen Umgebung für die Umweltversorgung, verabschiedet.
Na wie ist es ehrlich? Ja, 24 Prozent gekürzt. Also alles nur leere Worte, die er da einen Tag vorher verkündet hat. Es ist unglaublich. Wir blicken jetzt mal ganz kurz nach Indien, auch Modi war zugeschaltet, aber erst mal ganz kurz um das zu thematisieren. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt hier einen Impf-Fortschritt zu verkünden, das ist erfreulich. In Indien impft man auch, und gar nicht so schlecht im Übrigen. Also man hatte dann ja auch schon 10 Prozent etwa geimpft, aber durch diese Mutante, die sich dort gebildet hat und durch diese unglaubliche Situation, die soziale Situation, natürlich auch die Gesundheitsvorsorge, sieht das jetzt ganz anders aus. Wir hören jetzt hier mal vom BR, den Korrespondenten Oliver Mayer. Der ist jetzt zurückbeordert, der ist jetzt wieder in seinem Homeoffice in Frankfurt und nicht mehr in Indien.
Wir erreichen dich jetzt nicht in Neudeli, wo du eigentlich wärst, sondern im Homeoffice in Frankfurt. Kannst du uns vielleicht kurz erzählen, was ist da passiert?
Naja, es war einfach jetzt so in den letzten Tagen, dass die Entwicklung so rasant war und für uns nicht mehr gewährleistet werden konnte, dass wir intensivmedizinisch versorgt werden könnten, im Notfall, wenn was passieren würde und es wurde dann eine Risikoablegung getroffen und unser Sender hat sich dann dazu entschieden, mich dann nach Hause zu holen und lieber nach Hause zu fliegen, weil...
Hm, also die New York Times hat ja ihre Leute noch da, ne? Und der Bericht aktuell gestern ging so los. Sickness and death are everywhere. One of my colleagues is sick, one of my son's teachers is sick, the neighbor two doors down to the right of us, sick, two doors to the left, sick, alle, alle einfach krank. Also in diesen Großstädten, da sieht man mal, was R ist gleich drei oder höher wirklich bedeutet. Und auch, was an Corona-Erfolg in der westlichen Welt eigentlich geleistet wurde, indem man gesagt hat, okay, Großveranstaltung, das machen wir alles mal weg, wir senken es von drei auf eins und 1, 2 ist dann schon katastrophal viel und dann machen wir auch wirklich was, das ist in Indien ja wirklich anders.
Ja, Oliver Mayer berichtet nochmal, wie das eigentlich so sich entwickelt hat.
Es war so, ich kam hier im Februar an in Indien und da war es nur nach dem Motto, naja, Corona ist so ein Stück weit vorbei in Indien, wir leben eigentlich unser Leben wie vorher, Partys haben stattgefunden, man konnte sich mit Freunden treffen, man konnte Sport machen, man konnte in Restaurants gehen und die Lage ist jetzt erst so richtig im April wirklich eskaliert, wo die Zahlen explosionsartig gestiegen sind und das hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, weil man hier recht sorglos gelebt hat. Bis zuletzt haben hier religiöse Großveranstaltungen stattgefunden, wie das Kumpen Mähler, wo hunderttausende im Gange sich von ihren Sünden reinwaschen und ohne Abstandsregelung das Ganze vonstattenging, politische Wahlkampfveranstaltungen haben stattgefunden, teilweise ohne Maske auch, die Bauernproteste haben ohne Maske stattgefunden und die Politik hat da zu spät eben die Notbremse gezogen und in Kombination mit dieser neuen Mutation, mit dieser B1617, mit der Doppelmutation hat das laut vielen Experten dazu geführt, dass die Infektionszahlen so rapide jetzt angestiegen sind.
Na ja, natürlich nicht. Also Modi sagt, ist da ja auch nicht viel anders als Bolsonaro und sitzt da auch, dass sie da mit Biden ganz fest zusammenarbeiten und sich freuen, dass auch Amerika zurück ist. Also immer wird das Beglückwünscht, dass Amerika zurück ist. Indien hat ja dann auch ein geopolitisches Interesse, mit den USA eng an zusammenzuarbeiten, weil man sich ja, wir erinnern uns, mit China ja immer mehr im Clinch befindet, dass man sich da auch nicht angeschlossen hat an dieses neue Abkommen, das man dort getroffen hat. Und deswegen ist das natürlich für Modi jetzt eine Möglichkeit, hier nochmal zu signalisieren, dass man eigentlich ganz eng mit Biden zusammenarbeiten will. Aber wenn man sich dann anhört, was er da so von sich gibt und wenn man noch einmal jetzt sich vergegenwärtigt, dass da tausende Menschen gerade sterben und auch natürlich Arme besonders sterben, weil sie gar keinen Zugang daran haben zur medizinischen Versorgung, dann ist das schon verrückt, wenn er jetzt hier etwas von dem Lebensstil und dem natürlichen Leben in Indien erzählt.
President Biden und ich sind die India-US-Klima- und Klinikenergie-Agentur 2030 mit einer Partnerschaft ausgebildet. Die India-Karbon-Footprint ist 60% höher als die globalen Veränderungen. Heute möchte ich die Wichtigkeit des Lebens in der Klimaaktion und der Fortsetzung einer nachdenklichen Philosophie zurück zu Grunde, eine wichtige Forderung sein.
Das ist natürlich vollkommener Unsinn. Warum ist der Fußabdruck eines Menschen in Indien oder von Indien viel kleiner als zum Beispiel der von Deutschland oder den USA? Weil wir ein hochmodernes Industrieland sind. Und dort passiert noch sehr viel auch in agrargesellschaftlichen Themen. Deswegen gibt es diese Bauernproteste. Und das ist vollkommener Unsinn, da zu sagen, weil wir noch so schön nah an der Natur leben. Nein, das ist einfach, weil man die Industrie noch nicht so weit entwickelt hat. Und man würde das jederzeit machen, wenn man dann die Möglichkeit hätte und auch die Politik dazu ausreichen würde, dass man so etwas umsetzt.
Die Rechnung wäre natürlich interessant, wenn er hier sagt, wir haben einen 60 Prozent kleineren Fußabdruck, der allerdings dann auf 85 Prozent mehr, also geringerem Wohlstand, oder 90 oder sind es 93 Prozent, also das ist natürlich, hier vom Lifestyle zu sprechen, das ist natürlich hart.
Da sterben Hunderttausende und der redet vom Lifestyle und das sei alles noch so schön mit der Natur verwurzelt. Es ist ein Skandal, aber das ist auch etwas, was wir dann wieder finden können. Bei Präsident Xi, auch der ist zugeschaltet und auch er bringt uns jetzt hier ein bisschen Naturphilosophie nahe. Ja, schönes Bild ist aber auch vollkommener Unsinn. Ja, also wir sollen die Natur schützen, wie unsere eigenen Augen. Wir haben ja im Salon über Shenzhen gesprochen und was in diesen Modellstätten passiert. Und naja, die werden irgendwann dann auch wieder grün gemacht. Aber das ist natürlich nicht ein Naturempfinden, bei dem man sagt, ja, wir bleiben jetzt hier in der Landschaft und bleiben rural, bleiben agrarisch, sondern man macht dann irgendwann, wenn die Technik so weit ist, auch wieder Grünflächen. Also das ist auch ganz idiotisch, dass das so gemacht wird. Also was hier jetzt erzählt wird, ist so idiotisch, weil ja China auch ein Land ist, das ganz stark schon experimentiert mit Geo-Engineering und da gibt es nichts mit Harmonie und Mutter Natur.
Genau und dieses Geo-Engineering, also bei Shenzhen war ja Ausschlag geben, dass sie halt gesagt haben, wir machen hier keine eklige Industrie, sondern wir wollen nur das Hipster-Zeug haben und dann holen wir uns auch die Welt hierher. Die das ein bisschen mitentwickelt. Die Industrie findet dann irgendwo anders statt. Da werden dann die Kühlschränke und die Sachen so gebaut, die man sonst so braucht. Und bis heute ist ja immer noch 80 Prozent Kohle, was da so an Strom produziert wird. Also jedenfalls eine sehr erschreckend hohe Zahl. Ich weiß nicht, ob es 80 Prozent waren, aber es waren immer noch erschreckende Werte. Und es wird ja auch immer noch viel Kohlekraftwerk da gebaut jetzt.
Auch wenn da jetzt viele leere Worte zu hören waren und ich könnte jetzt noch weiter damit gehen, also jeder Staatschef hat sich dort geäußert und hat im Prinzip gesagt, ja Klimawandel ist uns ganz wichtig und dann kommen die entsprechenden Zahlen. Bis 2030 werden wir das, bis 2050 werden wir das. China ist ja ein bisschen später dran. 2060 wollen die dann klimaneutral sein, vielleicht auch bisschen früher. Man wird das sehen. Aber was man vielleicht dann doch als positives Resümee ziehen kann, ist, dass zumindest nicht mehr Leute dort sitzen, die behaupten, es ist alles gar nicht so wild und lass uns mal, sondern zumindest die Lippenbekenntnisse, die sind schon mal einheitlich. Die Politik sieht, glaube ich, ganz anders aus. Aber was man sich auf jeden Fall verkneifen sollte, ist dieses merkwürdige Mutter-Natur-Denken. Und das verblendet vollkommen erst einmal das Politische, das jetzt zu tun ist. Es verkennt die ökonomische Dimension, die, glaube ich, Biden am allerbesten momentan anzusprechen weiß. Und was dabei auch ausgeklammert wird, ist, dass Mutter Natur, wie Slavoj Zizek einmal sagte, eine crazy bitch ist. Und deswegen habe ich hier nochmal einen kleinen Ausschnitt von Zizek, was der zu Mutter Natur uns zu sagen hat.
Die Natur ist in sich selbst eine Serie von Megakatastrophen. Die Natur ist verrückt. Dinge gehen immer falsch in der Natur. Können wir sogar vorstellen, was für eine gigantische ökologische Katastrophe vor Millionen Jahren passiert hätte, damit wir Öl haben? Wir sollten unsere ganze Allianz von Natur akzeptieren. Das Problem ist nicht die Wissenschaft und die Technologie. Sie können ein Teil des Problems sein, wenn sie Probleme haben. Aber sie sind die einzige Lösung. Wir sind bereits in der Technologie. Wir sollten uns immer noch...
Naja, also du bist doch auch niemand, der mehr mit der Natur groß verbunden ist. Also wenn du komplett verstöpselt bist, deine Podcasts hörst und deine Funktionssachen anhasst und dann joggst du noch durch den Wald, dann sagst du noch Natur ist schön. Aber eigentlich ist die Entfremdung zur Natur, seien wir doch ganz ehrlich, im höchsten Maße da.
Aber die Natur als die eigentliche Katastrophe, gegen die wir uns schützen, klar, wodurch wir sie dann wieder zerstören, es sind wie immer schöne Bilder.
Aber denk doch mal an ein Virus. Wir haben schon, also der Natur da draußen ist Chaos in gewisser Weise. Wir sind doch das Virus. Bleiben wir mal bei diesem Ökonomischen und gehen wir erstmal ein bisschen von dem Klimawandel und diesem Thema weg und schauen erstmal nochmal auf dieses Investitionsprogramm. Du hast hier einen Artikel im Freitag veröffentlicht, ganz wunderbar. Eine ganze Seite Fuß von der Bremse heißt dieser Artikel und der ist großartig, weil er noch einmal sehr schön zeigt, was Biden da gerade macht und vor allem zeigt er noch viel deutlicher, was wir in Deutschland gerade nicht machen oder worüber wir uns noch Gedanken machen. Und erzähl doch mal, wie das zustande gekommen ist, dass du jetzt im Freitag hier eine ganze Seite uns voll schreibst.
Ja, das ist ganz witzig, denn jetzt machen wir auch ein bisschen Medienkritik. Das letzte Mal, also in der Märzausgabe, haben wir als allerletztes Thema, ich will nicht immer Modern Monetary Theory sagen, sondern Joe Bidens Wirtschaftspolitik und die beruht auf ein paar neuen Fundamenten, beispielsweise Modern Monetary Theory. Und daraufhin haben wir ja einen Clips gehört hier von Stephanie Kelton, die war bei David McWilliams im Podcast, hat das mal beschrieben, wie Biden sich das jetzt denkt mit diesen ganzen Staatsschulden. Staatsanleihen sind Geldscheine, hat sie uns dann gesagt. Und daraufhin bekam ich eine Mail von der Zeit. Man hat ja dort ein Streitressort und wünscht sich nochmal das, was wir besprochen haben, so als Text für die Leser. Also habe ich gedacht, okay, das Streitressort, da muss also eine ordentliche These rein. Also habe ich zugesagt, keine weiteren Fragen gestellt, weil man will sich das ja dann thematisch offenhalten. Und dann habe ich einen Text geschrieben, der jetzt im Freitag erschienen ist, mit dem Tenor, egal wie man es nennt, Modern Monetary Theory, Neue Volkswirtschaft, Bidens Plan, keine Ahnung. Die Grundlösung für das Grundproblem, warum das in Amerika geht und hier nicht ist, man lässt den Staat das Geld einfach ausgeben. Und wenn man glaubt, der Staat bräuchte aber Geld, um es ausgeben zu können, dann kann man ja später immer noch mal über die Einnahmen nachdenken. Wir machen also nicht diesen Refinanzierungs-Voodoo und deswegen auch diese Einstiegsszene mit den Grünen. Baerbock und Habeck stellen ihr Parteiprogramm vor und die allererste Frage aus dem Kreis der Journalisten ist, wieso machen sie nicht mehr und wie wollen sie das refinanzieren? Und da verschwenden sich ja beiden kein Gedanken daran, sondern die 5 Billionen werden einfach rausgeballert, während sich Habeck da plötzlich für 50 Milliarden rechtfertigen soll. Also habe ich den Text so geschrieben, habe ihn an die Zeit geschickt und dann bekam ich einen Tag später eine Mail von dem Redakteur. Ja, man hätte sich doch lieber einen Text mit einer starken These gewünscht, wie zum Beispiel, Schuldscheine sind Geldscheine, wo ich mir dachte, Schuldscheine sind Geldscheine ist keine starke These, eine richtig starke These und deswegen steht die auch im Text, ist wir können ja erstmal sagen, der Staat soll erstmal Geld ausgeben, danach überlegen, wie man es einnehmen soll und für eine Staatsausgabe, die man ja einfach erstmal machen kann, war mein Beispiel ein Erbe für alle in Höhe von 80.000 Euro.
Ja, ich würde das mal hier gerade vorlesen. Bleibt Geld liegen, ist es nur so viel wert, wie das Papier, auf dem es bilanziert wird. Der haushaltspolitische Sprecher der CDU-CSU-Fraktion im Bundestag, Eckhard Rehberg, sagte im März, ich glaube als Bundesfinanzminister, sollte man auch ein bisschen auf der Ausgabenbremse stehen. Damit stellt er sich auf die Einnahmenbremse aller Bürger und Unternehmen. Drehen wir es mal um und diskutieren darüber, warum wir nicht allen zum 18. Geburtstag 80.000 Euro Startkapital verschaffen. Die einen erben es wie heute schon, die anderen bekommen es vom Staat. Ja, und das wäre bei 700.000 Anwärtern pro Jahr würden das 56 Milliarden kosten.
Genau, und das habe ich dann mal verglichen mit, das ist ja ungefähr so viel, wie wir an CO2 Subventionen bezahlen, Dienstwagen, Privileg und der ganze Kram. Oder es ist auch so viel, dass man so locker...
Das ist so 50, haben wir das mit Militärbudget, 50.
Genau, oder man nimmt einfach eine ordentliche Erbschaftssteuer, sodass man von den 400 Milliarden, die vererbt werden, diese 50 Milliarden nimmt und die eben umverteilt, nicht nach Familienzugehörigkeit, sondern einfach mal nach Staatsangehörigkeit. Aber jetzt können wir natürlich alle überlegen, warum wollte die Zeit das nicht drucken? Erbe für alle 80.000 Euro, ich halte es weiterhin für eine starke These. Und du hast ja dann die Idee gehabt, den Text kann man ja auch am Freitag anbieten. Also ich habe Wolfgang Michael geschrieben, der hat ihn gleich weitergeleitet. Das war dann alles ein kurzer Prozess und dann erschien er im Freitag, wofür ich sehr dankbar bin. Sonst hätte ich den sonst irgendwie bei Sozialtheoristen oder so veröffentlicht. So ist er in einem Zeitungspublikum zugeführt worden. Und noch mal eine schöne Seite. Ich habe auch lange keine Zeitungsseite mehr geschrieben. Aber liebe Zeit, wenn ihr ein Streitresort habt, wieso dann nicht mal streiten? Der Text hat gestern eine schöne Twitterrunde gemacht, fand ich. Da wurde danach auch noch mal von Sydecum und Trugha und so weiter entsprechend gefaffwürdigt.
Wir bleiben aber jetzt mal beim Thema und wir können jetzt weiter streiten darum, also inwieweit das denn stimmt, dass der Biden so mutig ist. Gucken wir erst einmal, was sich jetzt gerade so in den USA tut wirtschaftlich. Da hören wir jetzt Adam Toos, es gibt ja diesen Podcasts Das Virus und die Wirtschaft, den ich sehr empfehlen kann. Fratscher und Toos dort immer abwechselnd sprechen über global ökonomische Themen und jetzt hier USA und was tut sich da und was bedeutet das für uns Deutsche?
Die Prognosen für 2021 einen besseren Wirtschaftsstand als das, was man 2019 für dieses Jahr erwartet hat. Also nicht nur Erholung, sondern über den Vorkrisenerwartungen hinaus schießende Wirtschaftsentwicklung.
Gerade mit Blick auf diese vielversprechenden Prognosen könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, bedeutet das auch positive Impulse für die Weltwirtschaft, gerade auch für einen Handelspartner wie z.B. Deutschland. Wie sehen Sie das?
Absolut. Ich denke, das OECD hat diesen Effekt für Deutschland auf ein halbes Prozent des Bruttosozialprodukts berechnet, was nicht wenig ist. Also wenn man das vergleicht zum Beispiel mit dem Effekt des Next-Gen-EU-Packades für Deutschland, dann sind wir in ähnlichen Grüßenordnungen.
Ja, das ist jetzt erst das, was von den USA ausgeht. Und was bedeutet das dann jetzt für Europa oder ist USA jetzt die Lokomotive?
Also das ist ein Moment, in dem die Amerikaner eine Lokomotivfunktion erfüllen für die Weltwirtschaft. Und man würde hoffen, dass ein ähnlicher Impuls auch für Europa ausgehen könnte. Aber da sieht es mit der Konjunkturpolitik vor allem auf EU-Ebene nicht sehr dynamisch aus. Das heißt, man wickelt jetzt hoffentlich das Next-Gen-EU-Paket ab, aber wir werden nicht diesen gleichen Effekt sehen.
Ja, auf das kommen wir gleich mal zu sprechen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich ja jetzt auch entschieden. Diese Gemengelage ist wirklich, wirklich interessant. Das begann ja schon im Wahlkampf in Amerika, dass Elizabeth Warren auf der Bühne stand und meinte, wir müssen in diese Klimasachen investieren und zwar richtig all-in, auch in der Frage, wie kriegen wir CO2 aus der Luft und so weiter. Also so richtig, dass man sich fragt, daran will man so vermeiden, aber das wirklich rauszuholen aus der Luft. Und die haben dort Angst, nochmal von China in die Tasche gesteckt zu werden. China hatte jetzt diesen Plan mit den 15 Schlüsseltechnologien oder so bis 2025 und die sind da voll auf Track und jetzt hat Amerika wirklich Angst, das nochmal zu verlieren und deswegen machen die das jetzt da so. Da ist es auch völlig egal, wer der Präsident ist, jetzt ist Biden natürlich Präsident und muss Trump beerben und deswegen darf man nie vergessen, glaube ich oder nie übersehen, primär es geht es hier um Wirtschaftspolitik, Leute sollen ein Gehaltscheck kriegen, Lebenszufriedenheit soll wieder da sein, irgendwie, also das ganze amerikanische Volk muss ein bisschen aufgepäppelt werden, da geht es primär um Wirtschaft, aber es läuft eben programmatisch über dieses Klimathema.
1400 Euro gibt es aber, 1400 Dollar gibt es ja für jeden Amerikaner, da wird schonmal was ausgegeben, aber Tuusp sagt hier auch deutlich, Europa macht da eigentlich zu wenig, um jetzt die Wirtschaft wieder richtig in Gang zu setzen und da sehen wir schon, das ist, was auf EU-Ebene gilt, nochmal verstärkt dann in Deutschland zu sehen, dass da alle sagen, oh Gott, Hilfe, da müssen wir doch mal irgendwo eine Bremse jetzt schonmal betätigen, ehe irgendetwas angelaufen ist. Und jetzt kommt aber Tuus zu diesem Infrastrukturprogramm, also zu dieser Frage, was machen wir jetzt für das Klima? Es geht jetzt also nicht um diese Corona-Hilfen, die jetzt nochmal alle geleistet werden, die jetzt auch in die Bürger direkt gehen oder für Schulen und so weiter, sondern es geht jetzt wirklich um dieses Infrastrukturprogramm, dieses grüne Programm, diesen Green New Deal, obwohl es das jetzt noch bei Biden nicht ist. Und da ist dann Tuus doch sehr kritisch.
Der Nachteil davon ist, dass das Paket in seiner Größe beschränkt ist. Und wenn das jetzt das große Klimapaket sein soll der Biden-Administration, und so würde es ja angekündigt, und wenn das das große gesellschaftliche Transformationsprogramm sein soll, das auch angekündigt worden ist, dann muss man sagen, dass es in seinen Größenordnungen nicht reicht. Das ist auch nicht annähernd groß genug, um wirklich die Energiewende in Amerika mit der nötigen Energie voran zu treiben. Es ist in dieser Hinsicht, muss man sagen, eher enttäuschend in seinen Größenordnungen. Und wenn man das runterbricht auf einzelne Teile davon, sagen wir mal beim Bahnprogramm, beim Schienenprogramm, dann belaufen sich die Versprechungen hier auf nicht mehr als 8 Milliarden Dollar im Jahr. Und dafür können sie nicht mal die nötigen Reparaturen auf der Strecke New York, Washington, BC und in den Hauptstrecken in Kalifornien bezahlen.
Da ist er mal vehement, aber er hat es auch schon gehört, da ist er immer zu wenig zurückgekommen.
Ja, wir haben ja schon gesagt, 2-3 Billionen, wie verrückt. Du sagst, nur 10 Billionen wären eigentlich vernünftig.
Die Sunrise, Green New Deal Leute machen immer noch, wollen immer noch auf 10 Billionen kommen, was angesichts der Größenordnung der amerikanischen Wirtschaft und die Langfristigkeit des Programms gar nicht unvernünftig wäre. Das würde dann, sagen wir mal, 5 Prozent des Bodo-Sozialprodukts entsprechen, was für die Energiewende so die richtige Größenordnung ist.
Also da wäre man mal so in der richtigen Größenordnung, überlegt mal, was das für Gedanken sind, wo wir noch hier irgendwo rumkrebsen und sagen, naja, können wir da überhaupt jetzt schon was machen?
Also Bernie Sanders, ich wurde auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen nach unserer letzten Folge. Bernie Sanders hat tatsächlich zwischendurch so Texte in Zeitungen, dass er da so einen Plan hat, der ausgearbeitet ist, so Konzeptionsebene und so, mit zehn Billionen. Also wirklich jedes Jahr ordentlich, also zehn Jahre lang dann richtig reingebuttert wird, jedes Jahr eine Billion.
Ja, du hast dich ja mit deinem Text auch in das MMT-Gefilde begeben und das ist ja auch kein einfaches Gefilde, denn da gibt es ja auch Grabenkämpfe und da gibt es Orthodoxien und so weiter. Ich glaube, man muss die MMT erstmal als eine Strategie begreifen, mit der man den Kurs verändern kann und mit der man über Geldpolitik, über Ausgaben, über all das Neue nachdenkt und wie Orthodox das jetzt von welchem Politiker eingehalten wird, ist vielleicht gar nicht so wichtig. Ich würde sagen, dass Biden sehr gut beraten ist, sich von MMT-Land beraten zu lassen, ohne jetzt zum MMT-Verfechter zu werden, denn das könnte dann sehr nach hinten losgehen und das wird auch sehr schwer, das einer breiten Bevölkerung zu vermitteln. Dennoch, glaube ich, ist die MMT richtig gut, um anders nachzudenken über Wirtschaftspolitik und das tut hier in Deutschland Maurice Höfken auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob du ihn kennst. Das ist ein Ökonom, der auch einen YouTube-Kanal hat, Geld für die Welt, hat ein sehr, sehr gutes Buch geschrieben über MMT, das kann ich empfehlen als perfekte Einführung.
Ist ja nicht im Büro von Demasi und so gewesen?
Genau, genau. Und der geht jetzt auch auf Beidens Infrastrukturprogramm ein und dröselt jetzt erstmal auf, was Biden da vorhat.
Konkreter besteht Beidens Infrastrukturprogramm aus folgenden Komponenten. 620 Billionen für Verkehrsinfrastruktur, 650 Billionen für Wasser, Strom und Breitband, 580 Billionen für Subventionen und Forschung und 400 Billionen für Bildung und Pflegeinfrastruktur. Macht in Summe etwas mehr als 2, 2 Billionen US-Dollar, die über einen Zeitraum von acht Jahren investiert werden sollen. Aus progressiver Sicht ist so ein Infrastrukturprogramm grundsätzlich begrüßenswert und geht in die absolut richtige Richtung. Allerdings ist der Plan bei weitem nicht ausreichend und ambitioniert genug, wenn man den großen Investitionsbedarf, den die USA hat, dagegen hält.
Also das war nochmal Billionen, Millionen, das geht ein bisschen durcheinander, durch Billions und Trillions und so weiter, aber wir wissen, was gemeint ist. Das ist von seinem YouTube-Kanal Geld für die Welt und jetzt sagt er, was dann vielleicht an Bidens Politik gar nicht so klug ist, nämlich dieser Protektionismus.
Bidens Plan ist explizit protektionistisch. Er kündigte an, dass keine öffentlichen Aufträge rausgehen sollen, die nicht bei amerikanischen Firmen mit amerikanischen Lieferketten und amerikanischen Arbeitern landen sollen. Allerdings hat dieser protektionistische Fokus das Risiko, dass er Druck auf die begrenzten inländischen Ressourcen macht und diese unter Umständen überfordert. Grundsätzlich gilt ja, je mehr reale Ressourcen verfügbar sind, desto größer und schneller kann ein großes Ausgaben- oder Investitionsprogramm umgesetzt werden. Im Gegensatz zu diesem Made-in-America-Protektionismus, der zwar für strategische Güter sinnvoll und legitim sein kann, hätten hier handelspolitische Maßnahmen, die zum Beispiel Importe günstiger machen, mehr Sinn gemacht.
Das kann sein, da muss man aber sich anschauen, was jetzt mit Ressourcen gemeint ist. Denn die sind ja hier so technologische Fragestellungen. Da macht auch, hat die EU zum Beispiel große Sorgen, dass in Spanien nicht genug Menschen ausgebildet sind. Wenn du so Länder hast, wie viel Tourismus, wo die Leute so raus stolpern aus Biografien, die sowieso schon wackelig sind durch und so weiter, zu wenig Geld, dann wird nicht richtig studiert und dann sind irgendwie so 40 Prozent ungelernt. Das ist aber in Amerika vielleicht nicht ganz so, also Amerika ist zum einen riesengroß, sowohl was Ressourcen als auch wirklich was so Wissensgrundlagen und so weiter angeht. Der Bildungsstand ist dann nicht ganz so schlecht, wie man immer hört, wenn man so amerikanische Schulen und so weiter optimisiert. Also da würde ich erstmal sagen, Biden, es ist nicht verkehrt, dieser America First, du würdest schon sagen, dass da Kapazität genug da ist, dass da nicht mehr Verknappungen entstehen muss, weil man gar nicht genügend hat, die es machen. Diese urbanen Zentren und so, das ist, also Amerika ist immer wieder größer, als man so glaubt, weil Amerika einfach unglaublich groß ist. Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, auch bei dem, was so kulturell in Amerika stattfindet. Wir hören auch jetzt am Ende, wenn wir dann Zeit haben, nochmal so ein wahnsinniges Projekt aus Amerika, bei dem man sofort versteht, das wäre in Europa nie möglich, weil hier einfach gewisse Grundlagen gar nicht erst da sind, um irgendwas zu ermöglichen. Aber in Amerika ist es doch immer wieder überraschend, was da so passiert. Also in deren Sicht, würde ich sagen.
Wir hören nochmal Maurice Höfgen jetzt zu Bidens Plänen zur Steuererhöhung.
Wenn die Steuererhöhungen vor allem Wohlhabende treffen sollen, wie Joe Biden ja sagt, dann sind sie nicht dazu geeignet, um Inflation zu vermeiden. Denn Wohlhabende haben eine hohe Sparquote und wenn man denen mehr Geld wegnimmt, dann nimmt man denen Geld weg, was ohnehin gespart worden wäre und nicht ausgegeben worden wäre. Das heißt, damit werden keine Ressourcen geschont und freigesetzt und genau das bräuchte es aber für große Programme, etwa wenn AOC und Co. sich durchsetzen und der Investitionsplan letztlich größer wird oder schneller von der Rampe geschoben wird, als bisher angedacht.
Die MMTler sagen ja da sehr gerne, naja, diese Steuererhöhungen jetzt, darüber können wir irgendwann mal nachdenken. Das ist ja eine Frage der Steuerung, aber das ist vielleicht auch so ein Knackpunkt bei der MMT, dass man natürlich dann nicht unbedingt die Umverteilung mit in der DNA drin hat, ja, sondern das ist erstmal was dann irgendwann kommen kann. Aber das ist eine Frage, die sich stellt. Und da ist es vielleicht auch hin und wieder schwierig bei der MMT, denke ich, wenn sie nicht so stark macht, dass es auch um Umverteilung gehen muss. Wenn sie halt sagt, naja, wir brauchen ja die Steuern in dem Sinne gar nicht. Also gerade jetzt, wenn wir das von Reichen wegnehmen, dann ändert sich volkswirtschaftlich nichts insofern, als die Inflationsrate sich nicht verändert, wie denn auch, weil die das jetzt gespart haben. Sogar kann man eine Vermögenspreisinflation stoppen. Dann weiß ich aber nicht, ob nicht diese Orthodoxie eigentlich auch sehr viele Wege, die wichtig wären, verhindert, wie zum Beispiel eine Umverteilung, die ja so erstmal langsam in Gang kommt mit beiden. Das ist ja jetzt noch nicht Sozialismus, was er da macht.
Genau, aber da muss man immer genau hinschauen. Das habe ich ja für meinen Text auch nochmal sozusagen darüber nachgedacht. Dieses Argument, was weiß ich, von Elizabeth Warren oder so, ab 50 Millionen schöpfen wir irgendwie Vermögenswerte ab. Da muss man wirklich genau gucken, was schöpft man dann am Ende ab? Ist das Geld, das ansonsten verkonsumiert worden wäre, also wo auch wirklich ein Inflationseffekt da ist oder einfach nur Buchwerte, die halt so, wo es dann egal ist, wie auf der anderen Seite die Schulden bei der Zentralbank. Und wir haben ja bei In Working Class von Julia Friedrichs auch mal aufgezeigt bekommen, wie dieses Geld arbeitet von den Superreichen. Das sind also diese Family Offices, die sich dann alle möglichen Investitionsgüter suchen. Und diese Investitionsgüter sind aber sehr häufig selbst wieder richtig drin in produktiven Prozessen, wie beispielsweise der Wald. Also Superreiche Familien in Deutschland investieren in Wald, denkt man erst mal gar nicht dran, überall auf der Welt. Nur in diesem Wald dann wird ja wirklich dann gearbeitet. Also das sind ja dann große mannstarke Unternehmen, in denen da wirklich Bäume gefällt und Möbel hergestellt und so weiter und so fort und so. Und da, also man kann durch Abschöpfung dort tatsächlich einiges bewegen, weil die müssen dann anders, also entweder sie haben gar nicht mehr genug die Möglichkeiten, da zu investieren, dann fällt das an jemand anderen. Vielleicht sogar wirklich zurück wieder an Mitarbeiter oder so. Also jetzt mal ganz fantastisch gesprochen, dass es eben aus der Hand der Reichen rausfällt und wieder zurückgegeben wird bei denjenigen, die auch wirklich damit arbeiten. Aber da ist, also dieses Abschöpfen macht immer viel Sinn, außer man hat halt wirklich so mit Elon Musk oder so, weil der hat dann einfach nur seinen Buchwert. Tesla ist halt so und so viel wert, deswegen ist er 100 Milliarden. Wenn du dem dann 10 Milliarden nimmst, dann ändert das wirklich, glaube ich, gar nichts. Das ist nicht mal an Vermögenswerten, würde ich da irgendwas ändern, weil das ist einfach ganz ruhendes Geld, so ganz stilles Geld, das in der Börse einfach hin und her geschoben wird.
Und sonst sagen die Reichen, dass sie das Geld für sich arbeiten lassen, was natürlich nicht stimmt. Sie nehmen das Geld, damit sie andere für sich arbeiten lassen können, aber nicht, dass Geld arbeitet. Und es wird gearbeitet und wieder gearbeitet wird es entscheidend und selbstverständlich wird dort wertgelegt auf eine Profitmaximierung, die wiederum nicht so daran interessiert ist, dass es diesen Arbeitern gut geht oder der Umwelt auch noch, was damit Zuträgliches geleistet wird. Und insofern glaube ich, dass diese Abschöpfung erst einmal immer zu Befürworten ist, ganz egal wie jetzt der volkswirtschaftliche Effekt direkt ist. Man kann auf jeden Fall immer sehen bei diesen großen Kapitalkonzentrationen, dass dieses Kapital irgendwo wieder was anrichtet. Und das kommt dann vielleicht auch erst ein paar Jahren zu uns wieder zurück, weil man sagte, ja, da hat man ja durch diese Steueroase dort schon das und das geschaffen gehabt. Und das hat zum Effekt, dass das jetzt so und so ist. Also ich glaube auch, da muss man das nochmal anders sehen. Was ich aber sehr gut finde, ist, wie Maurice hier die Diskussion in den USA nochmal zusammenfasst um dieses Investitionsprogramm.
Dass das Paket von Joe Biden viel mutiger ist, sieht man auch daran, dass ordoliberale Ökonomen bis hin zu Larry Summers sich in den Kopf machen, ob das Programm zu einer Überhitzung der Wirtschaft und zu aufkommender Inflation führen kann.
Also wenn Larry Summers in Amerika vor Inflationswahn oder Friedrich Merz hier vor der Liquiditätsfalle warnt, dann ist das immer ein gutes Zeichen.
Ich halte die Sorge für absolut unbegründet. Die USA ist noch weit von Vollbeschäftigung entfernt. Es gibt immer noch hohe Arbeitslosigkeit und vor allem einkommensschwache Personen oder Familien werden jetzt das Geld, das sie durch das Hilfsprogramm bekommen, auch zu einem Großteil einfach nutzen, um ihre Schulden zu bezahlen. Die sind nämlich teilweise hoch verschuldet, konnten Rechnungen nicht bezahlen und werden das jetzt einfach nutzen, um das schnell zu begleichen. Aber positiv ist, dass das eine wirklich konstruktive Diskussion ist. Es geht nämlich um die konkreten Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft, sprich, ob das Programm so groß ist, dass die Wirtschaft überhitzt. Und es geht nicht um die schwachsinnige Finanzierungsfrage.
Richtig, die schwachsinnige Finanzierungsfrage.
Sehr gut. Und deswegen gibt er uns noch eine Faustregel mit auf dem Weg und die können wir ja mal hier überprüfen, ob wir das schon haben und da würde ich sagen, nein, so ist es noch nicht.
Was wir uns noch als Faustregel merken sollten, ist, dass ein Konjunkturprogramm dann groß genug ist, wenn ordoliberale Ökonomen graue Haare bekommen, die Zeitungen vollschreiben und ständig Interviews am laufenden Band geben, wo sie sich Sorgen machen, dass es zu einer Überhitzung der Wirtschaft und zu Inflation kommt. Wenn das der Fall ist, dann ist das Konjunkturprogramm groß genug, wenn nicht, dann hat man nicht genug Gas gegeben.
Also ich bin gespannt auf den Wahlkampf, Eckhard Rehberg, Friedrich Merz, wir haben sie alle jetzt auf dem Schirm. Mal gucken, wie die Zitate so ausfallen. In jedem Fall eine sehr gute Faustregel, Mois.
Wer kein Gas geben will, ist Kretschmann. Und zwar habe ich jetzt hier was, 48 Stunden alt Video auf dem YouTube-Kanal der Grünen Baden-Württemberg hochgeladen. Er sagt, wir kommen voran mit den Koalitionsverhandlungen. Man koaliert ja mit der CDU wieder, aber kein Geld, ist kein Geld da?
Na ja, ich habe es, ich kenne seinen Original-Zitat nicht, aber ich habe es nur gelesen, ich bin gespannt.
Und was natürlich ein bisschen misslich ist, wir schwimmen jetzt nicht im Geld wie die letzten zehn Jahre. Erstmal wird es jetzt sehr mager werden und wir müssen dann Dinge machen, die kein Geld kosten, wie zum Beispiel eine Wahlrechtsreform oder die Grundlagen für die Photovoltaik in der Fläche ändern, dass man die schneller macht. Da geht es ja gar nicht um Geld. Aber erstmal, was Geld kostet, das muss erstmal geschoben werden. Aber wir können davon ausgehen, wenn die Pandemie rum ist, dass es dann auch wieder gut anläuft und wir dann auch an die Umsetzung der Projekte gehen können. Die Geldkosten, also niemand muss jetzt da gleich in Panik geraten, weil wir die Dinge nicht sofort machen können, denn, wie das Sprichwort sagt, aufgeschoben ist nicht aufgehoben.
Ja, das ist diese erschreckend alte Denke, bevor wir hier Geld ausgeben können, also was kaufen können, muss erstmal die Wirtschaft wieder in Schwung kommen, wo man sich fragt, naja, wer das nicht, die braucht Käufer. Die braucht Konsumenten. Und du als Staat, der du eine echte Idee hast, wie zum Beispiel Solar und so weiter, dann geht es auch als Käufer ins Geschehen, ne?
Ne, man wartet jetzt erstmal ein bisschen, bis man langsam wieder anläuft, bis man mal wieder ein bisschen Gewerbesteuer einnehmen kann, zumindest von den Geschäften, die noch da sind nach der Krise. Und wenn man dann da wieder genügend Geld hat, dann können wir auch mal gucken, ob wir das für sinnvolle Projekte ausgeben. Es ist ein einziges Trauerspiel. Ich finde das auch skandalös, dass die Grünen das nicht in einer Weise thematisieren, die wirklich jetzt mal auf Angriff gegen Kretschmann geht. Sondern, dass man da wirklich so ein Kadaver gehorsam offenbar geschworen hat. Und das lässt ja auch tief blicken dann auf das, was auf Bundesebene sein könnte. Also wenn das auch in dem Modus dann sich verhält, dann gute Nacht.
Ganz genau. Wir haben ja, ich hänge noch zwei Clips dran ans Thema. Wir haben das letzte Mal darüber gesprochen, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht in einer Eile Entscheidung dem Bundespräsidenten untersagt hat, das Gesetz zu unterzeichnen, dass Deutschland im Bundestag ratifiziert, dass ich die EU-Kommission jetzt verschulden darf mit Next Generation EU, also die 750 Milliarden-Pandemie-Abhilfeprogramm, von dem beispielsweise Spanien 120 Milliarden bekommt, Italien 60 Milliarden, die bezahlen damit je kurzerweise Geld und so weiter und so fort. Und das kriegen wir ja alles gar nicht mit, wie sehr jetzt, wie viel davon abhängt, sondern wir haben ja in Deutschland einfach, dass der Bundestag so das macht und dann das Bundesverfassungsgericht, weil der Lucke, der damals die AfD gegründet hat, jetzt dagegen klagt und darf dann der Bundespräsident nicht unterschreiben. Dieses Urteil ist jetzt im April allerdings gekommen und ich will es ganz, also das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sein kleines Schwänzchen dann doch ganz schön tief wieder eingezogen, sagen wir mal so. Denn es sah ja erst so aus, als wäre das jetzt hier irgendwie oh nein und wir müssen alle Angst haben, stellt sich raus, nee. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht wollte nur noch mal kurz auf den Putz hauen und hat ansonsten alles durchgewunken. Wir hören das hier am Beispiel des FAZ Einspruch Podcasts. Also wir hören jetzt zwei Juristen, die zum Thema sagen, wie jetzt dieses Gesetz zu verstehen ist und da zum einen dieser Hinweis.
Wenn jetzt tatsächlich der EU wieder Aufbaufonds nicht aufgenommen werden kann, wenn das Geld nicht fließen kann, das ja explizit zur Pandemiebekämpfung da sein soll, dann fürchten die Verfassungsrichter erhebliche Schäden und wollen das ehrlich gesagt die Verantwortung natürlich auch nicht auf sich nehmen. Das kann man ja auch verstehen.
Sie haben Schweißausbruch bekommen, 750 Milliarden, aber man ist wirklich verbieten. Nee, komm, es gibt nur Ärger und es hätte auch Ärger gegeben. Sie haben sich nicht getraut. Die Zahl war zu groß, es steht zu viel auf dem Spiel und das hätte Spanien und Italien Deutschland nie verziehen. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, aber es ist doch immer noch der Bundestag, der ein Budgetrecht, das hohe Recht des Hauses, die Hoheit des Hauses, das Budgetrecht, wird das jetzt nicht ausgehebelt. Ab wann, ab welchen Summen, mit denen sich die EU verschuldet und damit sozusagen Gläubiger Pflichten auch der Bundesregierung aufbürdet, denn wenn irgendwas nicht hinhaut, das hatten wir ja bei Gauweiler, wenn irgendwann mal was nicht hinhaut, das muss ja alles zurückgezahlt werden. Christine Lagarde wird ja dann kommen mit der Polizei, mit der Frankfurter Polizei und wird das Geld eintreiben, die Knochen brechen. Dann muss natürlich die Bundesregierung dann zahlen und jetzt hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht noch aus sich auch noch mal zum Thema geäußert in diesem Urteil. Ab wann, ab welchen Dimensionen, ist denn jetzt wirklich Gefahr im Vollzug? Wann darf denn der Bundestag da noch mal einschreiten und die Grenze ist sehr weit weg?
Diese Grenze, die legt das Bundesverfassungsgericht echt hoch an jetzt in dem Beschluss. Das sagt im Grunde, die es erst erreicht, wenn zumindest für einen längeren Zeitraum das Budgetrecht nicht nur eingeschränkt, sondern praktisch völlig ausgehöhlt wäre. Also wenn es wirklich so käme, dass Deutschland so viel zahlen müsste, dass wir hier eben, wie ich gerade sagte, mehr oder weniger unser ganzes Steueraufkommen darauf verwenden müssten. Und das ist natürlich, wie gesagt, das ist halt recht fernliegend. Und deshalb bewerten sie auch das Risiko als nicht so groß.
Also wir haben ja eben von Adam Two's gehört, das sind zwar viele Billionen, aber es ist ja immer noch ein, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Prozent des BIPs und so weiter. Und das Steueraufkommen liegt auf dem ganzen BIP. Also das sind ja in Deutschland allein eine Billion Steuereinnahmen oder so pro Jahr, die dann durch Bund, Länder und Kommunen einmal durchgereicht werden. Und da sind jetzt 750 Milliarden auf EU-Ebene, von denen dann irgendwie 35 Prozent auf Deutschland entfallen oder so. Keine Hürde, um zu sagen, das dürfen sie nicht, sondern hier ist jetzt wirklich der Freifahrtsschein ausgesetzt. Es gab ja wieder große Debatten. Olaf Scholz hat ja im Bundestag dann gesagt, damit ist der Einstieg in die Fiskalunion Europas gelungen. Und dann kam Eckhardt Rehberg und meinte, nein, das ist eine einmalige Angelegenheit. Nur wegen der Pandemie hat die EU jetzt Schulden gemacht. Das wird nicht wieder vorkommen. Und wir wissen, wenn die CDU erstmal abgewählt ist, macht die EU-Kommission das jedes Jahr und das ist auch genau richtig. Dann retten wir doch mal das Klima jetzt. Aber richtig, da wo man es retten muss, wenn man es da retten kann, nämlich in der Stadt. Frank Eckhardt ist ein, glaube Stadtzuzulo oder so, keine Ahnung. Fabian, Hörer Fabian hat mich darauf hingewiesen. Es war wohl mal sein Professor. Ich höre es hier noch leise piepen. Ich mache mal mein Fenster noch zu. Wir haben hier auch Baufahrzeuge gefahren, rückwärts die Straße entlang. Also Frank Eckhardt möchte auch, dass mehr gebaut wird. Und er hat in einem kleinen Podcastgespräch im MDR ein Plädoyer für neue Innenstädte aufgesprochen. Er war in einem Interview verwickelt und hat über die Stadtforschung, sein Metier gesprochen und über seinen Wunsch für andere Innenstädte.
Den öffentlichen Raum so zu gestalten, dass man sich da gerne und lange und auch vielfältig aufhält, das haben wir irgendwie verlernt. Und da glaube ich, wenn wir jetzt gucken, wie die Leute diesen öffentlichen Raum, die Parks, okkupieren, wie sie ihn nutzen wollen nach ihrem Gusto, dann sehen wir, ja, die Leute wollen diesen Raum. Sie brauchen ihn, aber sie wollen ihn anders, als er jetzt ist.
Also für ihn ist das Corona, sagen wir so, ein großes Experiment. Was wäre, wenn wir die Leute fragen, was willst du eigentlich von deiner Stadt? Mal abseits von dem, was wir von dir wollen, nämlich dein Geld, also Konsum mal ausgeklammert, es ist ja alles zu, es ist ja Pandemie. Wie möchtest du die Stadt nutzen? Und dann stellt sich raus, die Leute wollen vor allem in der Natur liegen. Die Leute nutzen die Stadt, um draußen zu sein. Und draußen meint hier in der Natur. Nur in den Städten ist ja gar keine Natur. Stattdessen ein interessantes Paradox. Natur gibt es nur dort, wo man sie, um hinzukommen, zerstört.
Wir produzieren, um für bestimmte Situationen, also mit dem Auto in die Natur fahren zu können, produzieren wir große Strecken an Luftverschmutzung. Das ist ein Paradox. Also wir fahren mit dem Auto irgendwo hin, um dort in der Natur spazieren zu gehen. Aber der Weg dahin ist sozusagen betoniert und voll mit Stickoxiden.
So und jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder wir gehen alle raus in die Natur, machen sie dadurch kaputt, oder wir holen uns die Natur so weit möglich in die Stadt hinein, um sie lebenswerter zu machen, um von der Stadt das zu bekommen und ihr auch das abzuverlangen, was wir von ihr wollen, nämlich ein lebenswertes Leben, trotz Urbaner und wir kennen alle die Vorteile einer Stadt. Kurze Wege, Synergieeffekte, viele Menschen auf wenig Platz, statt wenige Menschen auf endlos langen Landstraßen, die dann irgendwo in irgendwelche Dörfer führen, die man dann entlangfährt. Und da gab es auch in der Kulturzeit Gernot Wagner zu hören. Gernot Wagner ist ein Klimaforscher. Er hat in Stanford und Harvard studiert, hat danach sich durch Mitarbeit beim Emissionshandelshandbuch der Weltbank verdient gemacht, hat dann mit Klimaschock einen eigenen Bestseller geschrieben und ist jetzt gerade mit Stadt, Land, Klima in den Bücherlisten vertreten. Und er äußert sich hier zum Thema Wohnen, aber wie? Und er sagt, es geht überhaupt nur noch in der Stadt.
In der Stadt zu leben, das heißt inzwischen Selbstmord aufraten.
Also Kulturzeit hier ganz klassisch. Guckt man nochmal in die alten Fernsehberichte von früher rein. Genau, als alles noch anders war.
Er sieht es anders. Gernot Wagner. Österreicher, Klimaökonom, Stadtliebhaber, der in New York lebt. So eine urbane, dicht besiedelte Stadt ist für ihn die Rettung unserer Welt.
Die urbane Stadt, das Lebenszentrum für viele, ist für ihn die Rettung der Welt. Denn dann lässt man endlich die Natur in Ruhe. Und was wir aus den letzten 30 Jahren sagen können, das ist der Megatrend. Urbanisierung ist die Migrationsbewegung auf der Welt. In allen Ländern dieser Welt. In Mexiko, hier in Deutschland, in Amerika.
In allen deutschsprachigen Ländern, in Österreich, in der Schweiz. Deswegen gibt es ja diese unendlich vielen Dokumentationen auf YouTube darüber. Verödungen von Schweizer, Österreichischen oder deutschen Dörfern. Und dann gibt es irgendwelche lustigen Modelle, wie man das irgendwie wieder umkehren kann. Und dann gibt es aber auch immer mal wieder so einen Stadtforscher, der dann kommt und sagt, naja, das sind halt Entwicklungen. Und man kann das auch nachvollziehen, warum da Leute weggehen. Und dann ist das so.
Genau. Die Berichte, die du angesprochen hast, die überspringe ich alle. Denn ja, es sind diese kleinen Orte um Kreis Berlin und so weiter, wo aus 300 Bewerbern zwei ausgewählt werden. Denen wird dann ein Haus zugeteilt und ein kleines Budget gegeben. Und dann sollen sie mit der Dorfbevölkerung zusammen, um sich dort auch bekannt und beliebt zu machen, das Haus aufmöbeln und gleichzeitig das Dorf noch ein bisschen miterfrischen, mit ihrer Jugendlichkeit. Dafür gibt es dann irgendwelche Budgets, die dann so als Stipendium und so weiter. Und das ist ein Testprojekt und das dauert ein Jahr. Und der ganze Kram, um Leute aufs Dorf zu locken. Aber nein, wenn wir das Klima wirklich retten wollen, müssen die Dörfer entvölkert werden. Urbane Zentren ab 10.000 Einwohnern mit gewissen Dichten. Ab da lohnt es sich überhaupt, Stadt zu sein. Oder man nimmt sich gleich die große, große Metropole.
Aber wie sieht denn das denn aus? Also du würdest dann sagen, dass diese Dörfer sich selbst irgendwann überlassen werden, beziehungsweise die werden neu naturalisiert, renaturiert werden diese dann. Und dann ist das einfach so, dass dort ja auch eine gewisse Vielfalt wegfällt. Also das ist natürlich jetzt hier bei so einem Bericht. Wir sehen jetzt hier New York und wir sehen jetzt verrückte Gestalten auf der Straße rumlaufen. Das sehe ich jetzt so im Dorf nicht. Aber gleichzeitig bietet ja so ein Dorf auch eine Pluralität in einer anderen Weise.
Dann könnte man ja sagen, holt man das Dorf in die Stadt, sodass es nicht auffällt, dass man in der Stadt lebt. Du weißt ja, wie es bei uns hier so ein bisschen ist. Wir sind ja auch mitten in der Stadt in Frankfurt, aber es ist relativ grün. Man kommt hier so ein bisschen, man kann barfuß aus dem Haus gehen und ist sofort da. Und das ist die Perspektive, aber eben für die Stadt.
Und die bedeutet aber auch ein Wachsen in die Höhe. Also du kennst den Text von Alexander Mitscherlich, die Unwirklichkeit unserer Städte, was nicht meint, oh Gott, da gibt es ja nur noch Beton- und Glasfassaden, sondern Unwirklichkeit unserer Städte meint. Es geht immer mehr in die Breite. Die Menschen fahren lange in ihr Haus irgendwo. Und dadurch ist der Stadtkern kein Kern mehr und alles ist ausgefranst. Beziehungsweise die Wege in den Städten werden auch immer länger, dadurch dass man immer ins Flache denkt. Und er denkt ja nach oben, hat ja selbst auch da in Frankfurt Höchst im Hochhaus gelebt. Also das wäre ja dann auch etwas ganz Dringendes. Denn das ist ja vollkommen klar, dass jetzt nicht Eigenheim-Träume in der Großstadt verwirklicht werden können.
Genau, man kann dicht wohnen, man braucht nicht das eigene Haus, das ist alles Quatsch. Aber wir brauchen neue Konzepte für die Städte, die ein eigentlich dörfliches Leben in der Stadt ermöglichen und die die Natur davon entlasten, dass 15 Kilometer Landstraße gebaut werden müssen, damit drei Leute sich auf dem Dorf wohlfühlen. Weil diese 15 Kilometer Landstraße, die dann von LKWs befahren werden, damit das alles klappt, das ist das Schändliche, das Natur- und Umweltschändliche.
Um ganz offen zu sein, hier tut sich jetzt für mich ein privater Konflikt auf. Zum einen kann ich das absolut nachvollziehen, was du da gerade skizzierst. Zum anderen bin ich jemand, der einfach nicht gerne viele Menschen um sich herum hat. Und deswegen ist mein Wunsch eigentlich eher zu sagen, ich wohne in Koblenz, aber ich würde eigentlich gerne noch ein bisschen mehr aufs Land, also mit noch ein bisschen mehr Abstand zu allem. Und eigentlich nichts hören, nichts sehen, müssen von anderen Mitmenschen, sondern sehr für mich alleine leben. Das ist für mich eigentlich etwas sehr Erstrebenwertes. Ich finde auch einen amerikanischen Architekten besonders gut, Frank Lloyd White, der ja genau eine solche Fantasie immer hatte und dann diese immensen Bauwerke integriert hat in die Natur. Das finde ich ganz reizvoll. Und ich bin eher menschenscheu bzw. mag das nicht sehr viel, so um mich zu haben. Also nicht, nicht jetzt, wenn ich irgendwo vor Publikum auftrete, aber ich mag das nicht irgendwo, wo dich dann dicht, ich mag nicht Leute reden hören, wenn ich das Fenster aufmache und sowas.
Dann lasst ihr jetzt von der aufgeklärten Seite der Gesellschaft sagen, Wolfgang, du lebst auf fremder Kosten.
Die Freiheit, auf dem Weg zum Eigenheim draußen im Stau zu stehen und ungehemmt Ressourcen zu verbrauchen, ist ökologisch ein Desaster. Durch Versiegelung, Pendlerpauschale und Baukindergeld von allen mitbezahlt.
Wenn ich mir es leisten kann, natürlich, dann gibt es den Wintergarten und den zweiten Wintergarten und die Sauna neben dem Schwimmbad. Und das gehört alles mir persönlich. Wir als Gesellschaft, ob das hier in Amerika ist oder in Deutschland, Europa, wir subventionieren das Leben in Einfamilienhäusern sehr, sehr stark. Das heißt, es kommt kaum jemand für seine vollen CO2-Kosten persönlich auf.
So, Laura Schiritz heißt die junge Vize-FDPlerin, die zum Mietendeckel Bein wegschlagen des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes, schrieb auf Twitter Als Dorfkind ärgert mich die Debatte um den Mietendeckel auch deshalb, weil so getan wird, als sei nur das Leben in der Großstadt lebenswert. Ich füge kurz an, was es ist. Bei uns in der Lausitz stehen Wohnungen, 75 Quadratmeter, sanierter Altbau, drei Zimmer mit Balkon, 350 Euro kalt frei. You're welcome. Diese 350 Euro sind ein Fake-Preis. Wir subventionieren ihn mit. Der Straßenbau, die Infrastruktur, die dafür nötig ist, hat nicht Laura mit einkalkuliert und er steckt auch in diesem Mietpreis nicht drin, sondern das geht auf Kosten der Natur und auf Kosten der Gesellschaft. Wir brauchen einen Strukturwandel, der zur Urbanisierung führt. Oder anders ausgedrückt, wir dürfen ihn nicht länger künstlich ausbremsen. Auch der Strukturwandel für die Lausitz, da ist eigentlich Entvölkerung. Die Leute, die dort nachwachsen, junge Menschen verlassen ihre Eltern, ziehen in die nächste Großstadt. Und das wird gerade künstlich gebremst durch sinnlose Milliarden, die dann Strukturförderung heißen und via Kohleausstiegsgesetz zum Beispiel in diese Region gepumpt werden. Das muss aufhören.
Ich stimme allem zu, Dr. Pfeffern. Wir haben hier schon hin und wieder mal darüber geredet, dass es ja nicht mehr diese klassischen Sphären gibt zwischen der privaten Sphäre, die Trennung hin zur öffentlichen Sphäre, sondern was wir erleben, ist, dass eigentlich der öffentliche Raum privatisiert wird. Nicht nur von irgendwelchen Investoren, sondern er wird auch dadurch privatisiert, dass die Menschen sich immer weniger im Klaren sind, dass sie sich in einem öffentlichen Raum befinden. Und deswegen verhalten sie sich auch so, als seien sie eigentlich in ihren privaten Räumlichkeiten. Was für mich das schönste Beispiel da ist, ist diese komische neue Mentalität, dass man gerne mit solchen Musikboxen, mit den Tragwaren, wie heißen die nochmal, mit denen geht man gerne durch die Gegend und beschalte alle Menschen damit. Und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist für mich eine mittlerweile so unerträgliche Weise, sich durch den öffentlichen Raum zu bewegen, dass ich natürlich sage, um Gottes Willen, ich muss versuchen, möglichst weit weg von Menschen zu kommen, damit ich das nicht an der Backe habe. Also ich würde ja fast sagen, das ist ein guter Schritt und ich wäre dazu bereit, wenn wir in einer Gesellschaft leben würden, die noch eine Affektkontrolle kann. Nämlich Affektkontrolle ist ja etwas, was nicht mehr passiert, sondern man wird ja, egal ob man in der U-Bahn sitzt oder ob man sonst irgendwo sitzt, mit privaten Gesprächen, die am Handy geführt würden, wird man belästigt, man wird überall eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer wieder mit dem Privatleben von Leuten konfrontiert, die man überhaupt nicht kennt, auch mit einer immensen Lautstärke. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt für alle französischen Städte sagen kann, aber in französischen Städten, in denen ich das öfteren war, kann ich sagen, da wird sehr viel leiser gesprochen, das ist sehr viel angenehmer. Das ist für mich alles eine solche Zumutung, dass ich eher sagen würde, fliehen vor der Stadt. Ich würde man da fragen, wie das da in der Lausitz mit der Wohnung ist, ob die noch frei ist.
Bevor ich meine Polemik hier beende, quäle ich dich noch mit einem letzten Clip zu diesem Thema und sage dir, Wolfgang, hör auf mit deiner Klimazerstörung. Komm in die Stadt. Du musst dein Leben ändern.
Lieber die Cities verbessern, als die Speckgürtel vergrößern. Wer die Umwelt retten will, der bleibe in der Stadt.
So, Punkt ist nun folgender. Ich will niemanden aus dem Dorf raus zwingen und niemanden in die Stadt rein zwingen, denn das ist ein sozialer Wandel, wie schon gesagt, der sowieso von alleine passiert. Es wollen eigentlich genug junge Menschen in die Stadt ziehen, sodass wir sagen können, die Orchidee Wolfgang können wir auf dem Land lassen. Soll er doch dort an dem weiten Blick sich ergötzen, den er hat.
Ich hatte auch überlegt, schön wäre ja, wenn man einen Garten hätte, dann könnte man sich Zwergesel halten wie Arnold Schwarzenegg.
Zum Beispiel.
Das fand ich sehr putzig.
Die kommen dann auch schnell auf deinen Küchentisch gesprungen. Also wir haben einen ganz großen Vorteil beim Thema Klima-Rettung. Die Urbanisierung ist intrinsisch in die meisten Menschen einprogrammiert. Sie geschieht von alleine. Menschen wollen eigentlich in die große Stadt ziehen. Das ist jedenfalls das, was uns die Zahlen sagen. Städte wie Frankfurt, Berlin, Stadt Hamburg und so weiter.
Und das ist ja absolut verständlich. Ich lebe ja auch nur hier. Ich lebe ja auch nicht ländlich. Koblenz ist ja nicht ländlich. Aber ich lebe natürlich auch nur hier, weil ich relativ schnell in der Stadt bin. Weil ich schnell nach Köln und Frankfurt kann. Sowohl mit dem Zug als auch mit dem Auto. Das heißt, ich nutze natürlich die Möglichkeit, an einem urbanen Leben teilzunehmen. Meine ganze Sozialisierung ist ja durch das Theater und die Oper da. Und da war ein bisschen Koblenz auch dabei. Aber ganz viel ja alles in Hessen, in NRW, was man so anfahren kann. Insofern ist das absolut verständlich. Es ist auch verständlich natürlich für alle Leute, die nicht ganz so sind wie alle anderen, nämlich die irgendwie sich verwirklichen müssen, ob es beruflich ist, ob es in ihrer Sexualität ist, ob es auch Diskriminierungserfahrungen sind. All das sind immer Leute, die es in Städte treibt. Denn dort ist man geschützter selbstverständlich davor, weil man erstens in der Anonymität untergehen kann und zweitens genügend Leute findet, mit denen man sich in Communities zusammenschließen kann. Das ist ja auch dann nochmal in dem kulturellen Spektrum was ganz Besonderes, wie das in Städten stattfinden kann. Auch wenn dort vielleicht gar nicht die Kulturförderung so groß ist, aber doch treffen sich dann diese Leute dort. Und ich muss ja auch noch hinzufügen, dass wir jetzt über die Klimakonferenz zwar gesprochen haben, aber ich habe jetzt einen Panel rausgelassen, weil das ein bisschen zu spezialistisch wäre. Es war das von Bürgermeisterinnen aus aller Welt. Die wurden dort zusammengesetzt und die haben dort ihre Klimakonzepte beschrieben. Und das ist ja sowieso eine Lektion, die wir hier erfahren haben, auch mit der Corona-Politik. Oftmals haben wir richtig gute Bürgermeister, die vernünftige Sachen tun. Also auch in puncto Klima oder Corona-Politik. Und da kann das natürlich auch ganz, ganz attraktiv werden, in der Stadt zu ziehen, wenn man sieht, okay, da ist eine Regierung, die hat es verstanden, die weiß auch, wie sie eine vernünftige Wohnungspolitik macht und wie man auch so baut, dass Leute sich auch noch im zehnten Stock wohlfühlen. Denn da gibt es ja einfach ganz, ganz große Unterschiede, denn an sich ist ja Höhe nichts Schlechtes oder so. Nur das ist immer noch ganz stark mit einer Bauweise verbunden so, dass man denkt, na ja, aber das ist ja nicht so toll. Warum soll man eigentlich so hoch bauen? Dabei kann man ja gewisse Höhen erreichen, die ganz grandios sind, um dort vernünftig zu leben.
Genau, das ist der Spirit, den wir brauchen. Es ist in Städten alles möglich. Wer meint, ich will gar nicht in die Stadt aus Gründen. Diese Gründe können alle zur Disposition gestellt werden. Aber was hindert uns denn daran, dem größten klimafreundlichen, wie soll man sagen, sozialen Selbsttreiber? Warum gehen wir dem nicht einfach nach? Warum lassen wir nicht alle in die Städte? Städte sind zu teuer. Diese Pandemie, die wir gerade haben, hat dazu geführt, dass nachdem letztes Jahr vor der Pandemie noch 10.000 Menschen pro Jahr nach Frankfurt gezogen sind oder auch mehr, letztes Jahr nur noch 237 kamen. Die Pandemie hat schon mal viel für Einbruch gesorgt. In New York haben wir gesehen, dass Immobilienpreise bis zu 30 Prozent nach unten gingen. In Deutschland warten wir mal ab, welche Attraktivität die Innenstädte noch mitbringen, also die hochpreisigen Lagen nach der Pandemie. Weshalb wir jetzt einen Clip von vor der Pandemie gucken, 2019 Panorama.
Wir haben eine Studienauftrag gegeben, wie viel Prozent vom Haushaltseinkommen für eine 3-Zimmer-Neubauwohnung draufgehen. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt erschütternd. Alles, was über 27 Prozent des Einkommens geht, gilt nämlich als problematisch, weil da nur noch wenig Geld zum sonstigen Leben übrig bleibt. Wir haben alle verfügbaren Daten auf einer Karte zusammengefasst. Hier in Frankfurt etwa gehen 40, 7 Prozent des Durchschnittseinkommens für Miete drauf. Okay, Problem Großstadt, das kennt man. Aber auch in Kiel sind es 36, 4 Prozent. Oder in Magdeburg muss man für eine 3-Zimmer-Neubau-Wohnung 34, 1 Prozent rechnen. Zwar sind die Mieten hier im Verhältnis günstig, aber dafür sind die Einkommen auch nicht so hoch.
Also Panorama hat damals genau die richtigen Studienaufträge gegeben. Nicht die absoluten Preise sind entscheidend, sondern kann man sich es leisten. Und hier ist einfach klar, das kann man sich nicht leisten. Das ist einfach zu teuer. Nun haben wir ja einen Bauminister, Horst Seehofer, kürzlich. Deswegen gab es da auch einen Fernsehpodcast zu zum Bauen. Es gab eine große Bundespressekonferenz zum Thema Wohngipfel und so weiter. Da ist nichts bei rumgekommen, weshalb wir hier durchaus beim Sachstand 2019 bleiben können. Nochmal Panorama. Bauminister Seehofer äußert sich zum allerersten Mal überhaupt in seiner Funktion als Bauminister. Und es ist keine Veranstaltung, die irgendwas mit Bauen zu tun hat natürlich.
Das ist der zuständige Bauminister, Horst Seehofer. Viel getan hat das Bauministerium bisher nicht. Die Aufgaben immer nur weiter vertagt. Mit immer neuen Kommissionen. Aus der Baukostensenkungskommission entstand keine Änderung im Baugesetz, nur eine neue Arbeitsgruppe. Die Arbeitsgruppe standaz im Bauwesen. Ihr Ergebnis ein neuer Ausschuss. Der Sonderpresidialausschuss Bauen und Gebäude, kurz PBG. Und dessen Ergebnis war der Ständige Presidialausschuss Bauwerke. Viele Experten, viele Spesen, aber hinten raus kamen immer nur Papiere, die nicht umgesetzt wurden. Wir sprechen Bauminister Seehofer am Rande eines Termins an, als er den Hilfskräften im Schneekatastrophengebiet dankt. Wann reagiert er auf die Vorschläge der Baukostensenkungskommission? Mitglieder dieser Kommission werfen Ihnen jetzt vor, dass Sie die Vorschläge nicht umsetzen. Was sagen Sie zu dem Vorwurf?
Kommissionen neigen dazu zu glauben, wenn sie ihre Ergebnisse abgeschlossen haben, dann müsste am Abend des gleichen Tages schon die Umsetzung vollendet sein.
Die Baukostensenkungskommission hat 2015 die Vorschläge schon auf den Tisch gelegt. Das ist jetzt ja nicht gestern.
Ja, da war ich noch bayerischer Ministerpräsident.
Aber jetzt ist Ihr Bauminister.
Ja, aber wissen Sie, so wie Sie Ihr Leben auch nach Prioritäten abschichten müssen, wie jetzt die Hilfskräfte Prioritäten setzen müssen, was ist am wichtigsten, so muss ich das auch, muss es die Politik ja auch. Aber es ist auch nicht ganz einfach, Vorschläge zur Reduzierung des Bauaufwandes zu realisieren.
Der Minister hat andere Prioritäten.
Ach Gott, ich weiß nicht, ob du dein Buch Rentnerrepublik nennen sollst, das ist ja schon die senile Republik, das ist ja anders nicht. Meine Güte.
Also es ist nicht ganz einfach, dieses politische Feld, und er hat auch andere Prioritäten.
Muss ja auch Prioritäten setzen, ja.
So, das bedeutet aber, und diese Schlussfolgerung ist jetzt gar nicht polemisch von mir gemeint, wir haben es hier mit Verhinderungspolitik zu tun. Denn würde tatsächlich mehr gebaut, würden ja die Preise fallen. Und können wir uns vorstellen, dass jemand in Deutschland kein Interesse daran hat, dass die Preise fallen?
Ja, das ist das Amüsante. Das ist ja der, das ist auch was Altmaier oder was alle FDPler bei Twitter die ganze Zeit schreiben. Alle sagen, ja, jetzt durch diesen Mietendeckel war das ja so, dass es überhaupt keinen Anreiz mehr zum Bauen gibt. Aber man weiß ja, wenn man wieder dann bauen kann, weil es einen Anreiz gibt, dann sinken ja die Preise. Aber selbstverständlich ist es für die Immobilienkonzernen wie für jeden, der investiert in Immobilien, der sagt, ich will jetzt eine Wohnung hier mir kaufen, um die zu vermieten, geht es natürlich darum, nicht die Preise sinken zu lassen, sondern man hofft, dass die noch steigen. Also sonst hat das überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das ist so eine ganz komische betriebswirtschaftliche Denkweise, dass man meint, es gibt einfach dann ein ganz großes Angebot und vielleicht ist das Angebot dann sogar irgendwann größer als die Nachfrage. Und dann sinken ja die Preise. Aber genau das versucht man ja immer zu verhindern, dass das stattfindet. Deswegen ist das absolut gelogen, wenn so getan wird, als würden jetzt durch den Wegfall des Mietendeckels es wieder dazu kommen, dass die Leute bauen. Mag sein, dass jetzt ein bisschen mehr gebaut wird. Aber sicherlich werden die Preise natürlich nicht sinken bzw. ist das gar nicht intendierend. Man wäre ja verrückt, wenn man das machen würde als Investor.
Genau. In Berlin hält man sich eine politische Klasse. Die größten politischen Lobbyisten sind da die Bauunternehmer. Und selbst Chris Giffey, der für die SPD dort Bürgermeisterin werden will, hat gesagt, der Mietendeckel wird von mir abgeschafft. In Berlin sind 85 Prozent Mieter. Also nach Mehrheit wird es nicht entschieden, was die SPD mit was sie da anbaut.
Das ist jetzt schon mal ein Kotau und dann kann man sich denken, was da im Hintergrund schon gelaufen ist, damit man zu einer solchen Ausgabe kommt.
Andre Hollm wurde damals als Staatssekretär verhindert. Also die ganze Geschichte kann man da aufzeigen. Und im Großen und Ganzen haben wir es hier mit Verhinderungspolitik zu tun. Also die Mietpreisbremse des Bundes, an der ist es ja gescheitert, der Mietendeckel, da kommen wir gleich drauf, das ist natürlich ein Sabotagegesetz. Weil man dann einfach das Angebot gemacht hat, wird doch schon im Bund geregelt. Muss das Land nicht machen. Genau, das Baukindergeld. Das Baukindergeld ist auch ein Sabotagegesetz, denn es geht ja auch für bestehende Gebäude. Das reizt also gar nicht, neu zu bauen. Im Mietendeckel war das ja eingepreist. Da hat man gesagt, das Mietendeckel kann überhaupt nur für Häuser gelten, die bis 2014 fertiggestellt wurden. Also für Neubauten gibt es da gar keine Regelung. Der Mietendeckel hat das ganz unberührt gelassen, das Feld. Während bei das Baukindergeld diese 10 Milliarden gar nicht Fördermasse waren, um neu zu bauen, sondern damit hat man auch bestehende Gebäude. Also jemand, der eh schon ein Haus hatte, hat jetzt nochmal Käufer gehabt, bei denen der Staat nochmal was drauflegte. Also so Aufstockerei für Hausverkäufer sozusagen.
Ja, und ich habe das hier ganz schön gesehen von jungen Familien, die hier Häuser gekauft haben, um das jetzt noch schnell auszunutzen, solange es das Baukindergeld noch gab. Und dann sagten die, es war dann so, dass man einfach einen Hauspreis hatte, sagen wir 300.000. Und dann wussten aber ja die Verkäufer schon selbst, dass es ja noch diese 15.000, 30.000, je nachdem, wie viele Kinder es noch da gibt. Und dann haben die auch noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht, naja, das ist ja der Verhandlungspreis. Und Verhandlungspreis meint nicht, man geht nach unten, sondern man geht nach oben. Und dann gab es hier überall in der Region Überbietungswettbewerbe, wo man dann sagte, naja, ich bekomme jetzt eh vom Staat noch mal so 30.000. Dann schlage ich die mal noch dem Verkäufer vor. Und wenn der dann einsteigt, dann habe ich dann doch noch schnell das Haus bekommen. Also das ist ein großes Geschenk an die Immobilienbesitzer gewesen, die Verkäufer.
Der inserierte Preis ist eine Verhandlungsbasis. Mit Basis ist immer unten gemeint. Und dann, ach, mit drei Kindern wollen sie einziehen. 3 mal 30 Tonnen Euro. Legen wir die mal oben drauf. Also in der Ansicht haben wir es hier mit Politik zu tun, die Neubau verhindert, um den Markt knapp zu halten. Die den bestehenden Markt noch mal unterfüttert mit irgendwelchen Subventionen, die niemand braucht. Und hinzu kommt dann, und das ist sozusagen beispielhaft, dass wir dann, wenn mal eine Krisensituation ist, absoluten Protektionismus rund um die Mietzahlung gestaltet wird. Und das hat Fratscher an seinem Podcast hier nochmal aufgegriffen in Bezug auf die aktuelle Pandemie.
Der Staat zahlt viele, viele Milliarden Euro den Unternehmen für Überburgenshilfen, Neustarthilfen, die Bäckerei um die Ecke, die Gastronomie, den Einzelhandel, um ihre Kosten zu bedienen. Und was sind die Kosten für ein Café oder eine Bäckerei? Klar, die haben ihre Beschäftigten, die gehen auf Kurzarbeit, aber die Überbrückungshilfen und die anderen Hilfen werden zu einem großen Teil genutzt, damit diese ihre Mietkosten zahlen können. Also die Eigentümer von Wohnungen sind in dieser Pandemie fast komplett ungeschoren davongekommen.
Ja, und wenn es jetzt immer heißt, ach, die armen Künstler sollen sich mal nicht so anstellen, haben sich ja selber für den Job entschieden. Nee, das ist Vermieter-Schutzpolitik, dass die das Geld bekommen. Es geht jetzt nur um die Vermieter. Die Läden sind zu in der Innenstadt, die Vermieter sollen das Geld bekommen. Dafür hat der Staat diese Milliarden und Milliarden jetzt ausgegeben, damit die Vermieter fast ungeschoren, wie Fratia sagt, davon kommen. Die Mieter allerdings kriegen jetzt in dieser Pandemie, nachdem man ein Jahr lang Stress hat, noch dieses Mietendeckel-Urteil aus Karlsruhe in Berlin vor den Latz geknallt. Wo es heißt, nicht nur bist du weiterhin natürlich verpflichtet, deine Miete zu bezahlen, auch wenn du selber regeln musst, wie in dieser Pandemie, sondern sie wird jetzt auch nochmal erhöht. Also ohne jegliche soziale Sensibilität wurde hier einfach sehr viele Menschen nochmal die Existenz einfach weggeschlagen.
So ist Nachzahlungen, die auch kommen.
Genau, Nachzahlungen, die dann nochmal oben drauf kommen. Und jetzt kann man sich ja fragen, naja, aber der Staat irgendwann muss doch mal eine staatliche Institution so ein bisschen sensibel sein, oder die Sachlage erkennen und dann auch sagen, hm, okay, hier machen wir doch mal auch ein inhaltliches, stellt sich raus. Nee, gar nicht. Und interessanterweise, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hätte inhaltlich entscheiden können zum Thema Mietendeckel. Es gab genug Anträge, Klagen und so weiter. Man hätte sich da einfach mal was rauspicken können, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt machen wir mal eine Grundsatzentscheidung zum Mieten. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht so, ne, das machen wir nicht. Wir machen hier ein rein formales Urteil. Das hören wir uns kurz an, eingeschätzt von dem Juristen. Ja, wie heißt er denn eigentlich? Keine Ahnung, also der FAZ Einspruch-Podcast.
Beim ersten Senat waren es dann eben einzelne Vermieter, die Verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben haben, gesagt haben, das ist der Sache nach verfassungswidrig, weil es uns in unserem Grundrecht auf Eigentum verletzt. Und jetzt hat der zweite Senat eben zuerst entschieden. Und damit sind aber die Verfassungsbeschwerden, die beim ersten Senat liegen, der Sache nach auch gegenstandslos. Die dürften sich erledigt haben, ja.
So, es liegen ganz viele Klagen. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht nimmt sich genau die raus, wo sie mit Absicht nicht inhaltlich entscheiden müssen, die nämlich alle beim zweiten Senat liegen, und sagt, nee, hier ist einfach der Bund zuständig für das Thema. Und damit ist das alles erledigt.
Ich scheue mich nicht davor zu sagen, das ist schon Klassenjustiz, wenn man auf diese Weise vorgeht.
So, die Alternative. Wo kommt dieser Mietendeckel eigentlich her? Und wie kommt man jetzt darauf, dass der Bund mit einer Mietpreisbremse irgendwie flächendeckend für das ganze Land ununterscheidbar zwischen irgendeinem Lausitzer Dorf und der Berliner Innenstadt, der da einfach entscheidet. So ist es jetzt. Der Berliner Mietendeckel kommt aus der Feder von Peter Weber, der diese Idee gehabt hat, der hat in Baden-Württemberg lange als Anwalt gearbeitet und ist dann in die Berliner Verwaltung eingerückt und hat in der Juristenzeitung 2018 über die Möglichkeit einer landesspezifischen Gesetzgebung geschrieben. Ortsübliche Mieten sind nämlich künstliche Preise. Da kann man also ruhig aus ein bisschen was machen. Eingriffe des Gesetzgebers sind hier nicht verboten, so wie auch überall sonst nicht. Und mit der Föderalismusreform 2006 bekam die Länder, schreibt er, die Kompetenz im Wohnungswesen. Nicht zu verwechseln mit den Mietangelegenheiten, die im BGB niedergeschrieben sind, auf die auch die Mietpreisbremse abzielt. Was ist das Wohnungswesen? Wir sind super aufgeklärt in Deutschland. In der WGP stehen genau zwei Sätze zum Wohnungswesen. Nämlich das Wohnungswesen umfasst die Gesamtheit der Institutionen, Aktivitäten und Regelungen zur Versorgung der Bevölkerung mit Wohnraum. Dazu gehören die Wohnungsbestände, die Wohnungswirtschaft, die staatliche und kommunale Wohnungspolitik, sowie die Haushalte als Bedarfsträger und Nachfrager. Wir können uns also ein bisschen vorstellen, das Wohnungswesen kam nach dem Krieg. Als man jetzt gesellschaftlich sagen muss, wir brauchen jetzt Wohnungen. Markt kann man dann immer noch machen. Dann kam aber irgendwann der Markt und dann hat es BGB übernommen, weil dann wurde alles nur noch zwischen Vermieter und Mieter geregelt. Nur, man könnte das ja auch wieder zurücktreten. Man könnte ja sagen, wir haben eigentlich hier eine kritische Situation. Gut, wir sind nicht nach dem Krieg, aber für viele fühlt es sich an, wie so ein kleiner Krieg, den sie hier führen, mit ihrer Biografie. Da könnte man ja immer wieder das Wohnungswesen aktivieren. Und das könnte jedes Bundesland machen. Und zwar im Rahmen einer preisrechtlichen Vorschrift, die Eigentumsrechte tatsächlich begrenzt. Denn das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat zwar schon entschieden, dass Eigentum natürlich im Grundgesetz geschützt ist, aber Renditen auf Eigentum nicht. Und Mietzahlungen sind Renditen auf Eigentum. Also wenn man an die Mietzahlungen rangeht, greift man nicht das Eigentum an, sondern nur die Rendite auf das Eigentum. Und da darf man durchaus eingreifen. Das kennen wir aus vielen Gebieten. Und er verwies dann in dem Text auch nochmal auf die historische Bedeutung solcher Gesetzgebung. Denn nach dem Krieg gab es tatsächlich eine Wohnungszwangswirtschaft in Deutschland. Da wurde einfach der Markt bei so richtig rausgenommen. Da hat man gesagt, so, jetzt machen wir das. Fazit, Höchstpreisfestsetzung auf Landesebene sind möglich. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat dem nicht widersprochen, sondern es hat nur gesagt, der Bundestag im Rahmen der konkurrierenden Gesetzgebung, also die Länder sind zuständig, bis es der Bund regelt. Das sieht man jetzt bei der Pandemie auch. Die Länder machen so lange, bis sich Merkel durchringt, dann doch mal ein Bundesgesetz zu machen. So lange ist Landesgesetz. Und da die Mietpreisbremse auf Bundesebene schon da ist, kann man auf dem Land, in den Ländern nicht nochmal eine konkurriere Gesetzgebung machen. Und das ist natürlich blöde. Denn jetzt haben wir die Situation, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht tatsächlich gar nichts inhaltlich dazu gesagt hat.
Er geht auf die ganzen inhaltlichen Fragen. Ist das jetzt sinnvoll? Ist das irgendwie vielleicht zu rabiat den Vermietern gegenüber? Ist das okay, dass man selbst bestehende Mietverhältnisse, die die Miete so deutlich absenkt und so weiter, darauf geht er überhaupt nicht ein. Darum geht es in der Entscheidung genau gar nicht. Sondern es geht ausschließlich um die Kompetenzfrage. Also durfte Berlin das? Und darauf hat der zweite Senat auch eine ziemlich klare Antwort. Nein, durfte es nicht.
So, also, wie viel Rendite darf man jetzt auf sein Eigentum abschöpfen? Und die Antwort ist weiterhin, so viel der Markt eben hergibt. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat erst mal nur gesagt, die Ebene ist falsch. Aber klar, wir könnten noch ganz vieles wieder in den Blick holen, wie zum Beispiel auch das Wohnungswesen. Wir müssen es jetzt gar nicht bei den Mietpreisen und bei den Mietverträgen und was das BGB dazu sagt. Also zwei private Vertragspartner regeln was und der Staat spielt da gar keine Rolle. Sondern wir können es auch zurückholen aufs Wohnungswesen, beispielsweise bei der Klimafrage, finde ich. Also wir könnten jetzt durchaus sagen, wir müssen den urbanen Zuzug fördern, um mit dem Anliegen das Klima zu schützen. Das hat nichts mit den Vertragspartnern zu tun, die dann später das in der Stadt regeln, sondern da muss der Staat eine Rolle spielen und sagen, wir müssen es fördern. Beispielsweise über Mietpreisbremsen, also Wohnkostendeckelungen oder wie auch immer. Und das ist der zweite Punkt, es geht sowieso das Wohnen in der Stadt weit über das private Mietverhältnis hinaus. Also zwei private Vertragspartner. Denn um was geht es eigentlich in den Städten und warum sind die Preise so hoch? Das hat Fratscher hier in seinem Podcast nochmal beschrieben.
Berlin lebt davon, kreative Leute anzulocken. Wir haben viele Start-up-Unternehmen in der Stadt, wir haben viele junge Unternehmen. Wir haben eine sehr aktive Kunst- und Kulturszene. Und deshalb sehe ich das mit großer Sorge, dass wir eine der Stärken Berlins, also diese Offenheit, die Attraktivität für junge Menschen, damit in gewissen Weise auch zunehmend verlieren. Und deshalb muss die Politik schleunigst schauen, dass es da Lösung findet.
Die Städte, in Frankfurt sehe ich es selbst, in Berlin ist es genauso, tun unglaublich viel, um attraktiv zu werden. Infrastrukturprojekte, Kinderbetreuung, Schulen, alles das sind Aufgaben, um die kümmert sich der Staat, um die Städte attraktiv zu machen. Und hier spielt das Wohnen einen Aspekt unter vielen. Und es wird aber komplett ausgeklammert. Da wird gesagt, wir kümmern uns ja um die Straßen, um die Einkaufsmöglichkeiten, um den Spielplatz, um die Kita, um die Schule, um den sicheren Weg zur Arbeit, um die Fahrradwege, um dass du noch Zuschuss kriegst für dein Fahrrad, um nicht mit dem Auto durchzufahren. Alles Sachen, um die Stadt attraktiv zu machen. Wohnen klammern wir komplett aus. Der Egon, der vor 30 Jahren das Haus gekauft hat, darf das jetzt verhökern. Für welchen Preis auch immer, er findet ja jemanden, der es mietet. Da wird dann gar nicht eingegriffen. Obwohl das nur ein Aspekt unter vielen ist in der Stadt. Und dann muss man genauso zugucken.
Ja, und diese Preise sind kontextabhängig. Das heißt, hätte es diese Entwicklung in der Stadt nicht gegeben, würde auch keiner da wohnen wollen, würden auch nicht mehr die Mieten so hoch sein. Das heißt, das ist immer damit direkt verbunden. Und was ja hier von Fratscher beschrieben wird, ist ja dieser übliche Gentrifizierungsprozess, dass die Künstler kommen, machen die Stadt attraktiv. Oder auch andere Leute, die kommen, die Queerszene, ein hoher migrantischer Anteil und alles. Die machen eine Erneuerung in der Innenstadt, weil ja auch die Konservativen so lange noch in ihren Dörfern leben und lieber hin und her pendeln. Dann ist irgendwann die Stadt so attraktiv, dass selbst die Konservativen sagen, ach ja, das ist eigentlich doch ganz schön inzwischen da geworden. Dann siedeln die sich dort an. Dann müssen als erstes Migranten aus nicht gut bezahlten Jobs müssen dann immer weiter ins Land hinausgehen, damit sie das normalen können. In Frankreich kannst du es ja in extremster Weise sehen, mit Paris 60 Minuten Anreise, um dann einen schlechten Job in der Innenstadt zu machen, ist ja überhaupt gar keine Seltenheit, sondern die Norm. Dann gehen irgendwann die queeren Clubs und so weiter zu, weil dann sich auch schon die Mieter beschweren, dass es so laut unten ist noch auf der Straße nach 22 Uhr. Und dann, die Künstler können es sich auch nicht mehr leisten. Da sind ja dann sehr viele auch zum Beispiel von Berlin abgewandert nach Leipzig. Leipzig wird auch entsprechend teuer. Ich weiß nicht, wo man dann als nächstes hingeht. Wahrscheinlich sind die dann irgendwann wieder auf dem Land. Und da hat man dann so eine schöne Dorfinitiative. Aber das kann ja auch nicht das Ziel des Künstlers sein, dann irgendwann nur auf dem Land noch in so einer kleinen Kommune zu produzieren. Aber das sind diese Entwicklungen. Und all diese Entwicklungen sorgen immer dafür, dass erst alles attraktiv gemacht wird. Und dann, wenn es attraktiv genug ist, kommen die, die ohnehin es sich leisten können. Und die Vermieter sind die ganze Zeit Profiteure, ohne dass sie irgendetwas dafür tun.
Genau, gar nichts. Sie schöpfen einfach nur diesen Gewinn ab. Alles, was du jetzt beschrieben hast...
Und wir haben es ja hier mit Konzernen zu tun, ne? Also das ist ja noch in Berlin ganz stark, wie da Deutsche Wohnen und Vonovia vertreten sind.
Und wir können uns auch beziffern, um welche Werte es da geht. Das machen wir auch gleich. Das, was du eben alles im großen Bogen umrannt, das läuft ja alles unter Gentrifizierung. Für diesen Begriff, weil den Andre Holm mal in einem Text benutzte, wurde er jahrelang überwacht von der Polizei. Also wirklich so mit Telefonüberwachung und so weiter. Weil das ja so ein linker Begriff ist. Und nach dieser Überwachungsgeschichte wurde er dann von der neuen rot-rot-grünen Regierung als Staatssekretär zum Thema Bauen in die Regierung geholt in Berlin und von der CDU rausgemobbt in einer wirklich schändlichen Art und Weise, für die die CDU auch als Partei verboten gehört, um es ganz klar zu sagen. Und zu diesen Kosten, die du eben nanntest, das sind Konzerne. Georg Kunz ist Sprecher der Grünen und wohnt aus den von dir eben beschriebenen Gründen in Berlin. Da hat er nämlich eine U-Bahn und auch eine U-Bahn, die wohin fährt, wohin will. Also eine attraktive Stadt, in der er auch mal ordentlich leben kann. Und er schrieb dann am 15. April zum Mietendeckel-Urteil. Ich wohne in einer Berliner Vonovia-Wohnung. Die haben letztes Jahr 851 Millionen Dividende ausgeschüttet. Das sind 2045 Euro pro Wohnung. Meine WG zahlt also jeden Monat 170 Euro nur für Aktionärinnen. Erklärt mir nochmal genauer, warum wir keinen bundesweiten Mietendeckel brauchen. Genau die Frage ist genau auf den Punkt. Er hat es runtergebrochen auf seine WG, die jeden Monat 170 Euro bezahlt. Weil Berlin attraktiv ist, zahlen sie diesen Preis. Nur dieser Preis bleibt nicht in Berlin, sondern da wird dann irgendwelche Aktionäre ausgeschüttet, die das weder in Berlin attraktiver machen mit dem Geld noch sonst irgendwas. Also das ist einfach Geld, das aus Berlin abfließt. Und entsprechend hat Claudia Kipping, ne Katja Kipping heißt sie Katja Kipping, auch völlig richtig auf Lanz provokante Frage geantwortet.
Wen würden sie enteignen als erstes?
Ich glaube Deutsche Wohnen und Co.
weil die praktizieren bereits Enteignung. Durch steigende Mieten werden Menschen mit mittleren Einkommen enteignet.
Die Wohnungskonzerne enteignen, das ist nichts anderes als enteignen. Sie enteignen nicht nur ihre Mieter, sondern auch die Stadt. Das ist Geld, das durch die Stadt attraktiv gemacht wird. Das wird dort gezahlt, weil sich die Stadt das attraktiv gemacht hat. Dort dieses Geld zu zahlen und dann wird es einfach abgezogen. So und jetzt wechseln wir allerdings von der linken Politik, die bei Lanz auch mal was sagen darf, zu den Tagesthemen. Der Tagesthemen-Kommentar, wir haben vorhin schon Skandalöses von Christian Sievers im heutigen All gehört. Aber das, was hier von Anna Kirillais kommentiert wird zum Thema Mietendeckel, ist unverschämt skandalös vorbei an jeder Realität. Der erste Clip, naja, der zweite Clip geht dann ins Eingemachte. Hören wir uns das mal an.
Die Politik kann mit Gesetzen in den Markt eingreifen. Sie kann aber nicht die Gesetze des Marktes außer Kraft setzen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat den Berliner Mietendeckel gekippt. Es hat aber nicht entschieden, dass Politik sich nicht für bezahlbare Mieten einsetzen darf. Das Ziel, Mieten bezahlbar zu halten, bleibt richtig. Mieten sind in vielen Großstädten in den letzten Jahren explodiert. Bezahlbare Mieten sind die soziale Frage der Gegenwart. Auch in Berlin bestimmen Angebot und Nachfrage die Mietentwicklung. Die Antwort auf steigende Mieten muss also lauten, massiv Wohnraum schaffen.
Soweit so gut. Jetzt fragen sich einige, wieso findet Stefan das so skandalös? Er hat doch erst mal nur gesagt, mehr bauen und so. Keine Ahnung, Stefan ist auch viel mehr bauen. Aber jetzt, Wahlkampf, ja. Und sie kommentiert es wie folgt.
Und für die, die das Thema Mietendecke in den Bundestagswahlkampf mitnehmen möchten, das Berliner Beispiel sollte abschreckend genug sein.
Ja, und es ist einfach falsch, weil sie das jetzt nochmal sagen mit Angebot und Nachfrage. Nein, das ist so nicht richtig. Es ist nicht eine Sache, dass die Preise dann immer weiter sinken. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass man, also das sind ja normale Stadtentwicklungen auch, dass es irgendwo sehr teuer ist zum Beispiel. Und das liegt aber jetzt nicht daran, dass man jetzt sagen kann, gut, da sind jetzt vier edel Italiener und da kostet die Pizza 25 Euro. Dann sagt man nicht, naja, wir brauchen jetzt einfach noch vier weitere Italiener da, weil dann kostet die Pizza wieder irgendwann 7, 50 Euro. Sondern so funktioniert kein Markt. Das ist dort darum geht, dass alle wieder daran interessiert sind, die Kosten zu senken. Nein, es geht sehr häufig darum, künstlich zu verknappen, um eine möglichst hohe Gewinnmarge zu haben. Und diese Profitmaximierung bestimmt einfach diese Städte und bestimmt die Immobilienkonzerne. Sonst könnten die ja einfach sehr viel mehr bauen. Das ist doch ein ganz gutes Beispiel, das du da eben von dem Grünen gebracht hast, der da sagte, der 170 Euro geben wir da aus von der WG. Die haben 2500 Euro pro Wohnung, an die 2045 Euro an die an die Aktionäre, pro Wohnung. Jetzt sage ich mal was, das ist ja gar nicht viel. Also jetzt mal, wenn du bedenkst, wie aufwändig das ist, also mit einer Wohnung, Mietvertrag, all diese ganzen Dinge. Das ist für die Immobilienkonzerne zwar jetzt gerade ein lukratives Geschäft in dem Sinne, aber man kann an den Märkten mit anderen Dingen viel mehr Geld, viel leichter verdienen. Das heißt, das ist gar nicht vielleicht so ein tolles Geschäft und bzw. zeigt sich hier nochmal deutlich, die brauchen ja schon sowas wie 2000 noch was, damit sich das auch für die lohnt diesen ganzen Aufwand zu betreiben, dass sie das ausschütten können, denn sonst ist es einfach zu wenig. Das heißt, würden die jetzt noch anfangen, selbst ganz tolle Bauprojekte so zu machen, dass es günstig ist, dass es also ein Sinknetmiete gibt, dann haben die ja weniger. Und das ist für die Aktionäre nicht interessant. Deswegen sollte man gerade sich ganz davon verabschieden, dass das überhaupt eine gute Idee sein kann, dass Aktienkonzerne über Wohnungen verfügen. Sondern das kann nur dazu führen, dass man eine Profitsteigerung mit Verknappungen herbeizieht. Denn sonst ist das kein wirklich gutes Geschäft.
Also die 2045 Euro pro Wohnung, pro Jahr an Dividende. Da kommt ja noch parallel dazu, das operative Ergebnis, das das Unternehmen selbst macht. Das sind ja nur zu sagen an die Miteigentümer ausgezahlt jenseits der eigenen BWL-Bilanz, die man noch für sich da rechnet. Diese Häuser, also diese Wohnungen, wurden ja irgendwann mal verkauft. Und zwar in so großen Packungen, dass runtergebrochen eine Wohnung weniger als 10.000 Euro gekostet hat. Ja, das ist nicht fair. Also man hat vierstellige Preise, sodass man hier in vier, fünf Jahren die Wohnung allein über Dividendenzahlungen wieder refinanzieren könnte. So und jetzt, ich will, dass wir nicht zu schnell über diesen Kommentar hinweggehen. Wir hören uns nochmal diese acht Sekunden finalen Kommentar von ihr an.
Und für die, die das Thema Mietendecke in den Bundestagswahlkampf mitnehmen möchten, das Berliner Beispiel sollte abschreckend genug sein.
Das Berliner Beispiel ist gerade nicht abschreckend, da das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, wenn ihr über Mieten diskutieren wollt, dürfen es nicht mehr die Länder, sondern dann kann es nur noch der Bund. Es sei denn der Bund sagt, wir geben es wieder ab, wir lösen das Gesetz auf, aber jetzt sind wieder die Länder zuständig. Aber das Mietthema wurde durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt überhaupt nur zum Bundesthema gemacht.
Das ist schon Fake News eigentlich.
Und dadurch ist es genau falsch.
Man fragt sich dann wirklich, warum das Journalisten freiwillig machen.
Ja, und vor allem, es ist ein Meinungsbeitrag, aber er darf nicht so inhaltlich daneben liegen, so täuschend sein. Das ist hier Täuschung, die hier drinsteckt. Und deswegen Michael Müller als Verantwortlicher, dem es auch wirklich nahe ging an dem Tag, dass ja jetzt seine Berliner da im Feuer stehen, der hat es dann nochmal andersrum gedreht.
Für alle deutschen Großstädte, glaube ich, bleibt das ein Thema. Hier muss nun der Bundesgesetzgeber auch sehen, ob er uns Möglichkeiten gibt, in Zukunft entsprechend handeln zu können oder selbst eine Mietregulierung formuliert.
Das sind die Alternativen. Entweder der Bund gibt das Thema wieder frei, dann machen es die Länder für sich. Das ist absolut zu präferieren, denn es macht keinen Sinn, wie nochmal bei einer Pandemie. Da rechnen wir dann in Jahre zu verschwenden, dass sich Horst Seehofer als Bauminister, oder wer auch immer ihm folgt, mit Winfried Kretschmann und Daniel Günther, also dem Ministerpräsidenten von Schleswig-Holstein und Baden-Württemberg, auf irgendwas einigen. Die müssen sich nicht einigen. Das können diese Bundesländer für sich machen. Oder wie in den Großen, das sind auch Vorteile. Bremen, Hamburg, Berlin, die können es dann wirklich einfach für sich machen. Also dass der Mietendeckel prinzipiell hier einfach den Ländern als gesetzgeberische Hoheit aus der Hand geschlagen wurde, ist ein ganz großer Sündenfall. Und zwar nicht nur in diesem, es ist der Mietendeckel und so weiter, sondern in diesem grundsätzlichen, wie gehen wir hier mit Eigentum um? Was dürfen Vermieter? Wer erwirtschaftet eigentlich die Rendite der Vermieter? Und diese Klimafragen, die da halt auch dahinter stecken. Wir haben es bei der Klimafrage mit Problemlösungen zu tun, bei der eine Sache mal in die richtige Richtung geht. Und das ist Urbanisierung. Und genau das funktioniert nicht, weil irgendwelche Leute immer nochmal 170 Euro von so einem Studenten abkassieren wollen, der in Berlin in einer WG wohnt. Und das geht einfach nicht. Letzter Clip zum Thema. Wir schließen nochmal an, wo wir vorhin angefangen haben, bei Frank Eckhardt. Es ist jetzt Pandemie. Und ich habe gerade die Zahlen aus Frankfurt genannt. Statt 10.000 kommen nur noch 250 Leute in die Städte. Das wird die Städte verändern. Es sind Billionen Werte, die in deutsche Innenstädte investiert sind. Die Investoren sind irgendwelche Fonds, die für irgendwelche Alterssicherung sorgen und so weiter. Und das wird jetzt alles umgekrempelt. Wir haben Homeoffice und die Attraktivität von Homeoffice ist hoch. Wir haben eine Aversion gegen das Pendeln. Leute leben gerne in der Stadt und fahren nicht mehr in der Stadt gerne zur Arbeit, sondern reicht es nicht zweimal die Woche zur Arbeit zu fahren. Sonst bin ich zu Hause viel produktiver. Der ganze Kram. Und es wird sich als Allererstes, diese Veränderung ganz konkret in den Innenstädten, in den superattraktiven Lagen, nämlich in der Einkaufsstraße, im ersten Erdgeschoss unten, da wo man einfach reingeht und für Umsatz pro Quadratmeter sorgt, da wird sich das zuallererst niederschlagen. Und da hat die Bundesregierung jetzt eine große Aufgabe, und zwar den großen Ausverkauf zu verhindern.
Wir sind hier wirklich mit einer massiven Problematik konfrontiert. Es ist einfach zu befürchten, dass viele Geschäfte es nicht schaffen werden, trotz staatlicher Hilfe. Und wir werden 1a Lagen haben mit großen Leerständen. Da sind wir mit enormen Herausforderungen konfrontiert. Und da hilft es dann erst mal kurzfristig überhaupt nichts darüber nachzudenken, wie kann man denn da jetzt mit Onlinehandel das irgendwie auffangen. Das wird man so nicht auffangen können. Also da kann ich wirklich nur sagen, wir bräuchten sehr dringend nicht nur eine Taskforce für das Impfen, sondern auch eine Taskforce für die Innenstädte. Mit den kleinen Einzelhandlern kann jeder Stadtplaner gut reden. Mit denen kann man eine Interessensgemeinschaft machen. Kann man sagen, also hier, wie sieht es aus? Wir wollen machen was kundenfreundlicher, mit internationalen Immobilienhändlern das zu machen. Dann machen sie es selbst lächerlich. Es ist fast unmöglich. Und wenn jetzt die Politik schläft und da nicht eingreift, dann werden wir für Jahrzehnte die Innenstädte aufgegeben haben. Und genau das ist jetzt der Punkt. Und wenn wir jetzt dem Einzelhandel da nicht zur Seite stehen und da nicht eingreifen proaktiv, dann tun wir nicht nur dem Einzelhandel keinen Gefallen, sondern wir zerstören wirklich unsere Innenstädte.
Also wenn die Innenstädte jetzt über Landesgesetze oder Kommunale oder wie auch immer nicht die Möglichkeit bekommen, diese guten Innenstadtlagen, die alle umgekrempelt werden jetzt, die die Eigentümer wechseln, wenn die nicht die Möglichkeit bekommen, das nicht an die Höchstbietenden zu verkaufen, konzeptionsfrei, dann sind diese Innenstädte einfach verloren. Es ist jetzt schon schwierig, die Leute in die Innenstadt zu bekommen. Die Frankfurter Innenstadt hat ein echtes Problem. Die Goethe-Straße, das ist bei uns so, wo man seine Anzüge für vielstelliges Geld kauft und so weiter, hat ein Umsatzeinbruch von 80 Prozent erfahren letztes Jahr. Auch im Sommer, als Corona eigentlich rumschien und so weiter. Das sind alles Ladenflächen, wenn die nicht so und so viel 1000 Umsatz pro Quadratmeter pro Woche machen, dann machen die zu und dann werden die neu vergeben. Und wenn die alle zu höchst bieten an irgendwelche Konzerne für Jahrzehnte verkauft werden und dann nur noch Investitionsmasse sind und sich niemand konkret darum kümmert, was man da macht, ist die Innenstadt tot. Also dann haben wir amerikanische Verhältnisse, wo alle wirklich flüchten, weil das dann einfach verfällt in den Städten. Und das kann auch so Städte wie Frankfurt oder so weiter drohen. Das ist alles auf Kante genäht. Die Umsatzerwartungen waren so hoch, die Mietzahlungen sind so hoch, dass es dann einfach ganz schnell kippt, wenn diese Werte dann nicht mehr geschaffen werden. Und in deren Sicht sollten wir jetzt alle mal das Schlimmste befürchten für die Jahre bis 2000. Also wir sind ja hier, wir haben es jetzt spontan historisiert, dass jetzt die Aufgabe für 2030 irgendwie die Innenstädte attraktiv zu halten.
Ja, wir werden sehen, ob das gelingt. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen zurück auf die weltpolitische Bühne und schauen da mal, wie es mit Krieg und Frieden aussieht. Und zwar erst einmal steigen wir aber nochmal auf der Bundesebene ein. Annalena Baerbock war bei ProSieben, hat dort ihr erstes offizielles Interview als Kanzlerkandidatin gegeben, Kathrin Bauerfeind und Thilo Mischke haben sie interviewt. Es war, glaube ich, ziemlich grässlich, wie diese Veranstaltung dort ablief, vor allem was die Moderation anbelangt. Und ich hatte mir nur einen Bericht im Deutschlandradio angehört. Wir hören jetzt nur einen kleinen Clip. Es geht jetzt nicht darum, wie ProSieben das aufbereitet hat. Da werden wir, glaube ich, auch noch viel Schlimmes erleben in den nächsten Monaten. Denn was wir ja erleben, ist, dass die Privaten sich gerade die ganzen öffentlich-rechtlichen Stars unter den Nagel reißen. Also Jan Rufer ist jetzt bei RTL. Dann Linda Zervakis hat aufgehört bei der Tagesschau, geht jetzt auch zu den Privaten rüber. Die machen so eine Nachrichtenoffensive. Darum soll es aber jetzt nicht gehen. Sondern wir hören jetzt nur einen Clip aus diesem Radiobeitrag, um auf eine Frage zu kommen, die Thilo Mischke-Beerbock stellte.
Und dann fragte Mischke eben nach, klare Haltung irgendwie. Wie ist das denn mit dem Zitat von Joe Biden? Putin sei ein Mörder? Dann antwortet Beerbock und er fragt dann sogar noch mal nach und versucht, sie nicht entkommen zu lassen. Das klang dann so.
Und daher ist es aus meiner Sicht auch so wichtig, dass eine deutsche Bundesregierung da eine klare Sprache spricht. Herr Nawalny muss sofort behandelt werden. Und da sieht man jetzt auch wieder, wie komplex Außenpolitik ist, dass es nicht einfach nur eine Sprache braucht. Aus meiner Sicht kann man nicht von außen sagen, wer dafür jetzt einzeln verantwortlich ist.
Ja, schon mal sehr klug geantwortet. Denn es wäre natürlich dumm, jetzt als mögliche deutsche Bundeskanzlerin zu sagen, ja, der Putin ist ein Mörder. Sollte man nicht machen, hat man noch gar nichts mitgewonnen, weiß ich überhaupt nicht, was das soll. Also ich hätte das auch vielleicht nachgefragt. Aber das sollte man einfach nicht tun. Da finde ich, hat sie absolut richtig geantwortet. Cem Özdemir sieht das natürlich anders. Hat das bei Lanz nochmal bekräftigt, dass das absolut richtig wäre, dass Biden das so beantwortet hat. Und Özdemir ist ja eh so ein transatlantischer Hardliner, der irgendwie davon besessen ist, dass wir jetzt unsere Werte mit aller Gewalt durchsetzen müssen. Und hat sich dann dazu nochmal bei Illner geäußert. Und da kann einem ja dann doch Angst und Bange werden. Da ist mir dann doch die CDU als Friedenspartei fast sympathischer.
Wir sind die die Hard-Europeans, also die hinter Wolle gefärbten Europäer. Da gibt es einfach kein Vertun. In der Linkspartei wird da rumgeschwurbelt. Das geht nicht. Wir sind ein Land, auf das man schaut, mit einer besonderen Geschichte. Jetzt sage ich aber mal gerade, weil Frau Kade gerade das Problem haben wir Grüne mit alle. Wir sind glasklar bei Menschenrechten in Schließe aus, dass wir mit Parteien, die in der Frage, wie man mit Erdogan, wie man mit Putin umgeht, rumschwurbeln. Da kommen wir nicht zusammen. Das muss glasklar sein. Wir stehen, wenn Sie so wollen, in der Tradition von Adenauer, in der Frage. Da gibt es eine ganz klare Richtung in der deutschen Geschichte. Wir haben nun mal das Erbe von Auschwitz. Daraus ergibt es sich eine Verpflichtung. Daraus ergibt es eine Verpflichtung, dass wir kein Abenteurer-Tum machen dürfen als Deutschland.
Ja, wir hatten ja schon einmal, dass die Grünen mit dem Auschwitzverweis, wie auch Strafisch hat das damals gebracht, einen Krieg rechtfertigt haben. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie man jetzt da mit Russland umgehen möchte. Ich sage mal so, Baerbock hat ja zwei Kinder, die kann sie ja dann schon mal ausbilden. Aber ich glaube, bei jungen Leuten ist eher jetzt wenig Lust da, sich fürs Vaterland noch mal in Stalingrad zu engagieren. Also ich würde sagen, auf diese Weise bringt man eigentlich es tatsächlich zu einer Eskalation, die eigentlich für keine Seite wünschenswert ist. Und ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum man dort jetzt zu einem solchen Säbelrasseln übergeht, weil das extrem gefährlich ist. Das eine heißt ja, ob man irgendwelche wirtschaftspolitischen Zugeständnisse macht oder so. Und natürlich braucht man nicht jetzt solche schönen Färbereien zu machen, wie wir das gesehen haben, ja in den vergangenen Jahren immer wieder mit Autokraten. Aber ich würde doch sehr davon abraten, auf solche Eskalationsspiralen sich einzulassen. Zumal auch das Interessante ist, dass immer jetzt so stark auf die Linkspartei verwiesen wird, als sei die jetzt nicht regierungsfähig, weil die ja zu Putin schon mal eine andere Haltung hat. Na ja, also wir hatten jetzt die ganze Zeit eine CroCo, die überhaupt keine Probleme damit hatte, mit Erdogan einen Flüchtlingsdeal zu machen. Also das ist viel schmutziger, als was da hin und wieder mal aus irgendwelchen Teilen der Linkspartei zu hören ist.
Also das ist aus meiner Sicht purer Wahlkampf. Ich habe beides ausführlich geguckt, Baerbock und Özdemir da. Und das war die ganz klare Ansage an die Rentenrepublik, ihr könnt uns ruhig wählen. Also bei uns gibt es jetzt keine, deswegen auch diese klare Abgrenzung von den Linken. Das ist reiner Wahlkampf. Und so, wie beide gesprochen haben, also das Baerbock immer nur Nawalny, Nawalny und Özdemir dann dieses Die Linken, Die Linken. Das ist auch genau in diesem Rahmen kommuniziert, dass sie da in Moskau da sitzen und sagen, ja, das ist dieser Wahlkampf. Da fällt kein Satz, der irgendwie brenzlig wird oder der in einem Jahr dann nochmal rausgekramt wird oder so. Anders als bei beiden dann. Aber das sind einfach, das ist einfach, das ist wie nennt man dieses Signal, Virtue Signaling für die Rentenrepublik, für die alten Wähler. Und diese Art des Wahlkampfes, also dass wir bei Özdemir nicht so, also dass wir bei beiden, die jetzt verantwortlich sind. Und Özdemir, das wird immer unterschätzt, wenn man im amerikanischen Kongress nachfragt, zu wem habt ihr denn noch Kontakt im Bundestag, dann sagen die alle immer nur noch Özdemir, weil er ist irgendwie der einzige, der da noch so Transatlant durch.
Ja, ja, der ist ja da auch damals.
Genau, die Stange hält.
Auch so ein Jahr in den USA.
Ja, irgendwie so. Da gibt es so Verknüpfungen noch und Bekanntschaften. Und in deren Sicht ist diese Art des Wahlkampfes, die sie jetzt gehört haben, also diese ganz, also gerade bei Berbung, wie sie Nawalny ausspricht, diese Betonung auf Nawalny, Nawalny ist Schicksal-Nawalny, das ärgert die CDU maßlos, Röttgen und so. Die kotzen da im Strahl, weil da genau deren Futtertrog sozusagen genommen wird.
Wir hören mal, also ich bin, bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe nur ein bisschen Sorge, wenn das dann irgendwann auch mal in der Realpolitik übergeht und nun inzwischen auch die Grünen von der neuen Härte und deutscher Verantwortung reden und Aufrüstung und all das. Ich meine, erst mal kostet das alles Geld, das bringt auch dem Klima nichts. Da kann die Luisa Neubauer mit der NATO noch so viele Panels bei Instagram veranstalten. Und letztlich führen solche Aufrüstungsspektakel auch immer dazu, dass man dann vielleicht doch mal sagt, wir probieren es mal aus. Und da wäre ich doch sehr für das Thema abrosten, was ja zumindest früher mal, also ganz früher, das haben wir alle nicht mehr erlebt, bei den Grünen ein wichtiges Thema war. Aber genug der Polemik gegen die Grünen. Wir wollen uns mal anhören, was denn Biden da in diesem Interview gesagt hat. Ja, da wird er im Fernsehinterview darauf angeschaut. Ja, ich denke schon. Wie reagiert jetzt Putin darauf? Da könnte man ja jetzt überlegen, wie würde jemand hier in Deutschland zum Beispiel auf so einen Vorwurf reagieren, dass man ein Killer sei, man würde das zurückweisen, oder man würde einfach nur sagen, das sei ja unverschämt, so etwas zu sagen, oder würde sich vielleicht verteidigen und sagen, genau das bin ich nicht. Wie kommt man nur darauf? Putin reagiert wie folgt.
Wenn du andere Menschen beigetragen hast, oder auch wenn wir andere Staaten beigetragen, andere Menschen, wir schauen uns immer in den Miror ein.
Ja, schon fast philosophisch. Ja, finde ich irgendwie. Also bei aller Antipathie, die ich zu Putin habe, finde ich natürlich diese Aussage ganz interessant, weil sie was Schönes hat, was man irgendwie in Tragödien wiederfinden könnte, in großen, dass er also da erst mal sagt, also it takes one to know one.
Aber dass er es nicht zurückweist, ist doch schon.
Genau, und er weist es wirklich nicht zurück und sagt dann noch, ja wann immer wir einen anderen Menschen oder beziehungsweise ein anderes Land, einen anderen Staatsmann kritisieren, blicken wir in einen Spiegel. Das ist natürlich auch sehr interessant und bedeutet ein ganz anderes Verständnis von Präsident sein oder vielleicht gar nicht so anders. Jedenfalls hat mich das an ein Drama, erinnert ein Barock-Drama von Pierre Corneille, Sinner heißt dieses Drama. Es geht darum, dass Octave durch ein Verbrechen, nämlich er bringt Emilias Vater um, zum Kaiser wird. Und dieser politische Mord, den möchte jetzt die Tochter Emilia rechen und sagt, das geht nicht, der ist auf den Thron gekommen, weil der meinen Vater umgebracht hat. Und die Frau des Kaisers, die weist Emilia zurecht und sagt, sie habe da im Prinzip was nicht verstanden. Und weil du jetzt sagst, ja komisch, dass er das nicht zurückweist, ja, das ist ein anderes, sagen wir, Amtsverständnis. Und wie das aussieht, glaube ich, das können wir jetzt hören bei Corneilles Sinner. Ich habe da mal die Stelle eingelesen. Die Frau von Octave, der jetzt der Kaiser ist, die weist jetzt mal Emilia darauf hin, wie sich das eigentlich verhält. Genug, Emilia. Halt ein. Bedenke, dass er an dir die Wohltat deines Vaters nur allzu sehr vergolden hat. Sein Tod, der deine Wut entflammt, war ein Verbrechen Octaves. Doch war es das des Kaisers nicht. Die Staatsverbrechen, die der Krone gelten, verzeiht der Himmel, wenn sie uns gelingen. Und auf dem hohen Platz, den er uns gab, wird was geschah gerecht, was kommen wird erlaubt. Der, dem es gelingt, ist schuldlos stets, und unantastbar bleibt das, was er tat. Wir schulden alles ihm, Besitz und Leben. Doch uns fehlt Anrecht auf des Herrschers Leben. Ja, also Oktaf hat das gemacht, da war er aber noch kein Kaiser, und jetzt ist er aber Kaiser geworden. Damit kann der Kaiser nicht mehr belangt werden, und wenn der Kaiser etwas tut, dann ist das rechtens und dann darf man ihn nicht da in irgendeiner Weise in Verantwortung ziehen. Und auch da gibt es eine Parallele nach Amerika. Hier nochmal dieser ganz berühmte Satz aus dem Interview. Richard Nixon sitzt David Frost gegenüber, es geht um Watergate, und Nixon erklärt mal sein Amtsverständnis. Ja, wenn der Präsident es tut, dann ist das nicht illegal. Also hier haben wir mal dieses Thema bis hin zu Corneille nochmal. Aber was wir jetzt erleben können, ist natürlich, dass der Ton gegenüber Russland, aber auch gegenüber China sehr viel schärfer wird. Und das hängt sicherlich damit zusammen, dass man jetzt mal wieder als Allianz auftritt. Also dass die EU und USA sehen, okay, wir könnten mal als Verbündete mal wieder agieren und nicht so wie Trump das getan hat. Und dadurch vielleicht verändert sich auch was, zum Beispiel beim BDI, denn auch von Deutschland gibt es immer mehr Kritik ja jetzt an China. Und das BDI schließt sich hier an, einen Auszug hier aus dem Deutschlandradio.
Vor drei Jahren hätte ich Ihnen nicht ins Mikrofon gesagt, dass wir es in China mit einem autokratischen System zu tun haben. Heute tun wir das selbstverständlich und monieren Menschenrechtsverletzungen in China an und werden das auch weiter tun.
Fridolin Stragg spricht für den Bundesverband der deutschen Industrie, den wichtigsten Wirtschaftsverband.
Vor drei Jahren hätte er nicht gesagt, dass China ein autokratisches Regime ist. Das ist ja eigentlich noch eine Aussage, wo man dachte, ach, vor drei Jahren hat die ja wohl auch jeder schon getroffen, hätte das China nicht schon fast von sich selbst gesagt. Nee, das hätte man da nicht gemacht. Fratscher hat sich auch damit beschäftigt und sagt, na ja, schon komisch, dass das jetzt gerade kommt.
Und deshalb halte ich es schon ein bisschen für verlogen, dass man jetzt kommt mit diesem Argument, oh, was macht ihr mit den Urguren? Das sind aber böse Menschenrechtsverletzungen. So kann das nicht weitergehen. Ich halte nochmals, ich halte diese Klage für völlig richtig. Nur man muss sich die Frage stellen, wieso jetzt? Wieso nicht vor zwei oder vor fünf oder vor zehn Jahren? Und ich sehe einen direkten Zusammenhang, dass wir letztlich gerade durch diese Corona-Pandemie einen seismischen Shift sehen, eine Verlagerung der Wirtschaftskraft, auch der politischen Kraft damit, von dem Westen, also Europa und den USA, hin nach Asien und vor allem China im Mittelpunkt Asiens.
Ja, also diese Quartalsvergleiche. China ist im Corona-Quartal eins, 2020, und heute sind ja irgendwie plus 18 Prozent Wirtschaftsleistungszuwachs oder so, ne? Also das ist schon beträchtlich.
Und das macht Angst und fratschern noch mal hier über das Motiv.
Und das Motiv heißt für mich, es ist ein globaler Systemwettbewerb, zu dem die USA und Europa langsam auch aufwachen und es realisieren.
Ja, ich hab gestern oder so im Deutschlandfunk auch noch mal was Aktuelles gehört. Steinmeier war wohl irgendwann mal in China und hat dort auch noch mal gesprochen, was natürlich nicht groß reportiert wurde, weil und so, aber man guckt dann doch so ein bisschen interessiert. Und der hat dann noch mal diese europäische Vorstellung geäußert, Wandel durch Annäherung. Wenn wir unsere Maschine einlassen, werden die irgendwann sich uns annähern. Und jetzt sieht man, ne, diese Erwartung ging nicht auf. Also da ist man jetzt enttäuscht auch.
Ja, und das Traurige ist vielleicht dann auch, wenn man jetzt mal so sagen will, dass wir da ein bisschen mehr tonangeben sein sollten, dass das, was wir jetzt gerade machen gegen China, also mit Sanktionen drohen oder auch manche dann in Kraft setzen, dass das, sagt Fratscher, nicht viel bringen wird. Welche Auswirkungen haben die Sanktionen denn dann überhaupt auf die Weltwirtschaft?
Die Sanktionen, die die Amerikaner und zum Teil auch Europa bisher auf China aufgelegt haben, sind nicht wirklich greifend. Sie werden China nicht wirklich schwächen. Sie führen lediglich zu einer Verunsicherung, gerade auch bei europäischen, bei deutschen Unternehmen. Aber wir sehen das im Augenblick noch nicht. Das Ganze im Gegenteil. Gerade Deutschland profitiert in dieser Corona-Pandemie massivst von diesem starken Wachstum, das China im Augenblick hat. China ist ja deutlich besser durch die Pandemie gekommen. Ich befürchte, die Politik hat gar kein Interesse daran, China wirtschaftlich zu schaden, weil mittlerweile ist die Abhängigkeit von China und der chinesischen Wirtschaft so groß.
Im aktuellen Manager-Magazin ist ein Interview mit dem BMW-CEO und der sagt, ja momentan verkaufen wir so 2, 3 Millionen Autos pro Jahr und sie wollen aber bis 2030 eigentlich schon ein paar Jahre früher, wenn es alles gut geht, es schaffen, dass sie 3 Millionen Autos verkaufen. Und wo werden die die verkaufen? Natürlich nicht hier. Hier wird umgestellt auf Immobilität und so wie überall und Amerika ist jetzt auch kein Markt, der noch unendlich wächst, sondern das ist der asiatische Raum und das ist ganz stark China. Insofern haben wir dann die Abhängigkeit deutlich.
Ja, wenn man den DAX irgendwie aufsummiert, 15 Prozent der DAX-Erlöse werden in China erwatschachtet, das kann man sich überlegen, 15 Prozent klingt erstmal nicht viel, aber wenn man 15 Prozent so rausnimmt durch politische Verwicklung oder nur kleine Shifts zulässt, indem man sagt, hier fällt in Deutschland gerade eine Produktion aus, weil irgendwer Zero-Covid-Quatsch macht oder so und dann verlagern sich diese Ströme woanders hin. Also hier steht echt viel auf dem Spiel.
Ja, ja und ein Versprechen, ein Erwachstumsversprechen, also über die 15 Prozent hinaus, dass da noch ganz viel zu holen ist. Und Fratscher bringt es aber noch mal sehr schön auf den Punkt, wenn wir über eine globale Wirtschaft sprechen, was dann immer zu bedenken ist.
Globalisierung ist gefährlich. Globalisierung heißt erst einmal, dass man eine Arbeitsteilung hat, eine globale Arbeitsteilung, wie Produkte hergestellt werden. Es fehlt Europa, den USA, eine klare Strategie, denn man kann nicht glaubwürdig versuchen, China zu isolieren. Das hätte man vor 20 Jahren vielleicht noch machen können, aber nicht mehr heute.
Das hat man schnell zurück isoliert.
Man ist der Welthandelsorganisation beigetreten in China vor 20 Jahren und nun jetzt ist das so toll mit der Entwicklung, dass man das einfach nicht mehr machen kann. Aber, was Fratscher hier noch mal deutlich macht und das wäre dann doch etwas, was wir jetzt auch so im Auge behalten müssen für die Neuen Zwanziger. Wie wird das Bündnis geschmiedet sein zwischen USA und EU gegen China bzw. für ein anderes China? So sollte man es eher formulieren, weil es tatsächlich ja eine globale Wirtschaft ohne China nicht mehr geben kann.
Und die große Frage ist, wie können wir unsere Werte, unsere Standards, die uns in Europa wichtig sind, wie können wir die global verankern und setzen? Und die Antwort ist, dass werden wir nur gemeinsam mit den USA können. Also wenn Europa und USA gemeinsam sagen, wir teilen gewisse Werte, nicht nur was Menschenrechte betrifft, sondern auch eben Datenschutz, Umwelt, Klimaschutz, Grundrechte. Wir haben in Europa und den USA vielleicht noch ein Zeitfenster von fünf bis zehn Jahren.
Ich bin mir damit nicht so sicher. Es gibt verschiedene Science Fiction Szenen, die so mit der Idee spielen, dass zwischen Wirtschaftsräumen wirklich viel Raum liegt, nicht nur so eine Zugfahrt, sondern so die Expans oder so. Der Mars ist besiedelt. Und irgendwie kann ich mir das auch vorstellen. Also diese Art von Globalisierung, die wir jetzt mit China gemacht haben, die braucht man nicht zwingen. Es gibt in China nichts, was in Europa nicht gelbe und es gibt in Europa nichts, was es in China nicht gäbe. Sondern das sind rein auf sozialer Ebene, auf juristischer Ebene Konstrukte, mit denen man da nochmal Geld spart, da irgendwie ausnutzt, dass es da einfach keine Sozialpolitik gibt oder sonst irgendwas. Also dass man in China so viel produziert hat, hängt halt viel damit zusammen, dass da einfach keine Lohnnebenkosten gab. Da musste niemand in die Rentenkasse einsahen, also war das da billiger, die waren eh ärmer und so. Aber in dem Maße, wie Biden ja jetzt dann doch so ein Aufwachen zeigt, auf so einer Zeit, und ich meine, gestern war die große Rede im Parlament, die haben wir jetzt beide noch nicht gehört, aber die wird natürlich auch Thema sein. Spätestens im nächsten Neuen Zwanziger wird das nachwirken, auch wenn es dann schon wieder ein Monat her ist. Man kann das alles durchaus so gestalten, dass man America first oder Europeans first oder so auf konstruktive Weise in Anklang bringt in einer 1 zu 1-Kalkulation gegen Verbändelung mit China, ohne dass das gleich zu Weltkrieg und so weiterführt, weil Wirtschaftsverbindungen natürlich auch immer bewirken, dass es dann zu friedlichen Auseinandersetzungen gibt oder man sich irgendwie juristisch bei der Welthandelsorganisation oder sowas streitet, aber eben nicht mit Panzern. Aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man das entflechten kann, ohne dass gleich alle tot umfallen, weil irgendwelche Konzerne irgendwelche eingepreisten Renditen dann nicht mehr einfahren.
Für die Aktienmärkte ist das eher etwas, was die in Schrecken versetzt. Aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt für die Realwirtschaft durchaus was möglich wäre. Und da sollte man aber dann auch mal überlegen, ob man noch mal ein anderes Wort dafür findet. Protektionismus klingt halt immer sehr stark. Das ist Trump, der macht die Mauern hoch und so weiter. Es klingt sehr negativ. Man muss vielleicht noch mal da irgendwas finden, wie man das anders dann aufgreifen kann. Zumal ja dieser Protektionismus-Vorwurf ohnehin immer schwachsinnig ist, da natürlich jede Nation protektionistisch agiert. Also Freihandelsgesetze sind ja auch dazu da, damit dann jemand einen Vorteil daraus sieht. Und wir haben ja hier zu Genüge schon aufgezeigt, inwieweit Deutschland zwar ganz viel Handel überall hin betreibt, aber das hat nichts mit Handel auf Augenhöhe zu tun. Sondern das ist ganz klar protektionistisch oder der EU-Protektionismus, was Landwirtschaft anbelangt. Und du hast es ja auch hier sehr schön mit den Lobby-Organisationen aufgezeigt, die da im Parlament schalten und walten. Da ist es ja keineswegs so, dass man sagen kann, wir versuchen hier mit unseren Handelspartnern gemeinsam einen schönen Weg zu finden. Das ist ja vollkommener Unsinn. Die Frage ist, ob man das tatsächlich gegen die Macht der Finanzmärkte, die ein großes Interesse daran haben, dass die so global bleiben, wie sie sind bzw. noch globaler werden, dass man das da schaffen kann. Also möglich halte ich das auch, aber das geht nur mit immensem politischen Willen und da muss man sich mit richtig vielen Leuten anlegen. Und das würde auch für EU-Ebene vielleicht der eine oder andere schaffen. Bei den beiden traue ich das auch jetzt inzwischen zu, hier jetzt auf der Bundesebene erstmal schwierig. Die Sache ist natürlich noch, wie China so agiert. Also China ist natürlich weiterhin daran interessiert, zu expandieren wirtschaftlich und beäugt alles kritisch, was sich irgendwie verbündet gegen China. Also jetzt hier mal nur ganz beispielhaft eine Reaktion vom chinesischen Außenministerium. Die Sprecherin Hua äußert sich da dazu, dass Japan und Indonesien mal so ein bisschen jetzt miteinander sondieren, wie könnte man sich da verpartnern. Und Japan wird ja auch ein bisschen schärfer dann in der Abgrenzung zu China. Und so reagiert man dann im Außenministerium auf eine Pressekonferenz da.
Wir erzielen den japanischen Teil, die Diskoart zu verhören, die Basis von internationalen Beziehungen zu beherrschen, China zu verhören und konkrete Aktionen zu nehmen, um die overallen Interessen der China-Japan-Behörungen zu schützen.
Ist schon harter Tobak. Aber da sieht man ein bisschen, wie rau der Ton inzwischen ist. Viel Sonnenschein gab es aber dann beim Treffen zwischen Biden und dem japanischen Präsidenten Suga, der ist jetzt nach Washington gereist und war damit auch das erste Staatsoberhaupt, glaube ich, das Biden besucht hat. Und auch das ist ja was Entscheidendes, dass die USA sagt, ach, wir holen jetzt mal jemand von Japan hier hin, dass es uns mal wichtig als Bündnispartner zuerst anfangen.
Ich habe noch von keiner Aktion von Suga gehört bisher, das ist die erste.
Es ist ja auch Japan, das Land der aufgegriffenen Sonne.
Ja natürlich, er hat das nochmal alles wunderbar hier aufgegriffen und wenn die Sonne aufgeht, also wenn er das schafft, dann können wir auch alles miteinander tun. Suga ist ja ein bisschen angezählt, was Japan anbelangt, also da hat er ja auch mit Korruption und allem Möglichen zu kämpfen. Man ist sich gar nicht sicher, ob er da noch den Herbst überstehen wird oder ob dann jemand Neues kommt, obwohl er noch gar nicht lange im Amt ist. Aber außenpolitisch kann er sich da natürlich erst mal gut präsentieren. Biden macht jetzt nochmal erst einmal was Grundsätzliches deutlich. Es geht um internationale Normen und wer die setzt. Ja, das machen sie alles mit Japan jetzt zusammen. Worum es natürlich eigentlich geht, ist, man will eine gemeinsame Strategie haben, die vor allem militärischer Natur dann auch ist, dass man was für das südchinesische Meer hat. Denn da geht es ja um Handelswege, da geht es darum, dass es permanente Schamütze gibt, seit zwei Jahrzehnten jetzt oder seit den 90er Jahren. Aber das hat ja immer stärker zugenommen. Die Chinesen haben künstliche Inseln aufgeschüttet. Zum Teil ist das eine ganz große rechtliche Problematik. Wie kann man überhaupt da eingreifen? Also wem gehören die denn eigentlich? Wenn die die jetzt einfach aufschütten, dann sind die jetzt denen. Also da entsteht ein ganz merkwürdiges juristisches Konstrukt. Also man braucht da. Japan, Deutschland ist ja da auch schon unterwegs, will da auch patrouillieren. Und das wird jetzt hier auch nochmal von beiden benannt.
Wir sind engagiert, zusammenarbeiten, die Herausforderungen aus China zu nehmen und auf Themen wie das East China Sea, das Süd-China Sea und Nordkorea zu sorgen, um eine Zukunft eines freien und ökologischen Indo-Pacifischen zu ermöglichen. die Menschenrechte und die Regelung der法.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant, auf die Wortwahl zu achten, wann nennt er das Süd-Chinesisches Meer, wann Indo, Pazifik und so, das ist ja, da wird ja viel mit gespielt.
Und Suga ist hier sehr, sehr deutlich, denn er muss natürlich ein bisschen aufpassen. Japan und China verbindet ja sehr viel, vor allem wirtschaftlich, und die sind schon sehr stark voneinander abhängig, also da ist es wahrscheinlich mit dem Decoupling nicht so leicht wie mit EU und USA, wenn es da schon schwierig ist, aber bei Japan ist es richtig heikel, aber der nimmt hier eigentlich kein Blatt vor den Mund. Wenn der Status Quo da angetastet würde, was er ja wird, das ist auch schon eigentlich eine Tatsachenbeschreibung, dann wird man da nicht lange zögern und wird sich da engagieren, was immer das dann heißen mag. Da hat es schon öfters fast geknallt und das wird hier nochmal so ganz offiziell auch bekräftigt. Also dann in Washington, das ist ja nochmal eine andere Ansage, als wenn man das jetzt von Japan aus Richtung China signalisiert.
Ist eigentlich dieses japanisch-chinesische Verhältnis so ein bisschen mit Deutschland, Frankreich zu vergleichen, nur ohne dass es eine Versöhnung gab? Wahrscheinlich irgendwie, ne?
Also es ist ganz, ganz schwierig. Ich kann da, und das sind auch meine letzten beiden Clips zu dem Thema, auf ein Buch verweisen, das jetzt erschienen ist von Kai Vogelsang. Der hat schon eine sehr gute Geschichte über China geschrieben, die bei Reklam erschienen ist. Und jetzt hat er beim Kröner Verlag ein Buch veröffentlicht, China und Japan, zwei Reiche unter einem Himmel. Und das sagt er schon sehr deutlich, es sind zwei Reiche, aber irgendwie sind sie unter einem Himmel. Und sie verbindet natürlich diese beiden Länder eine lange Geschichte, aber die ist sehr wechselvoll. Und ich habe jetzt mal hier einen Ausschnitt, in dem Vogelsang ein bisschen auf das südchinesische Meer eingeht und um deine Frage nochmal aufzugreifen, es ist tatsächlich so, dass es eine starke kulturelle Annäherung in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren gegeben hat, das heißt zum Beispiel die japanische Manga-Kultur ist in der chinesischen Jugendkultur sehr stark vertreten und auch wieder anderes wird von japanischen Jugendlichen aufgegriffen. Das heißt, man hat da einen sehr starken Austausch und der geht auch dann über diese politischen Konfrontationen hinweg. Der Handel sowieso, aber es gibt halt diese schwelenden Konflikte und hier mal so ein kleiner Ausschnitt über das südchinesische Meer. Mit der Wirtschaftsleistung stieg auch Chinas Anspruch, eine politische Führungsrolle einzunehmen. Vom Wiederaufstieg war jetzt die Rede. China sollte, wie einst in der Kaiserzeit, wieder zum Reich der Mitte werden, das dem Rest der Welt seine Ordnung vorschrieb. Dieser Anspruch drückte sich auch in dem Streit um die Diaoyu-Senkaku-Inseln aus. Jenes winzige Archipel im ostchinesischen Meer, das halbwegs zwischen Taiwan und Okinawa rund 350 Kilometer vor der chinesischen Küste liegt. Japan hatte diese Inseln 1895 besetzt und kurz darauf an einen Privatunternehmer verkauft. 1945 waren sie unter amerikanische Militärverwaltung gekommen. Danach war ihr Status ungeklärt geblieben. Bei den Verhandlungen 1972 und 1978 hatte China das Thema noch explizit ausgeklammert. Doch Mitte der 1990er Jahre reklamierte auch China die Inseln für sich und damit begann ein handfester Streit. China berief sich auf alte Landkarten, auf denen die Inseln als Teil des Ming-Reichs eingezeichnet seien. Japan pochte darauf, dass sie noch Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts völlig unbewohnt gewesen seien, keine Seite vermochte, mit ihren Argumenten zu überzeugen. China hatte 1995 Erdölbohrungen in der Nähe des Archipels begonnen. 1996 errichteten japanische Nationalisten auf einer der Inseln einen Leuchtturm. In den folgenden Jahren kam es mehrmals zu Zusammenstößen zwischen chinesischen Fischkuttern und der japanischen Küstenwache. Der Streit eskalierte 2012, als Japan die Inseln von den Privatbesitzern zurückkaufte und verstaatlichte. In China kam es wieder zu wütenden Demonstrationen und vor den Inseln umkreisten zeitweise dutzende Schiffe, zivil und von der Küstenwache einander. Gerade so nah, dass sie einen gewaltsamen Zwischenfall eben noch vermieden.
Ja, wenn das Meer doch nur ein bisschen tiefer wäre dort, Mensch.
Ja, das wäre dann alles ein bisschen leichter. Aber es gibt auch einen Konflikt, den es skizziert Vogelsang auch dann in seinem Schlusskapitel, der sich daran festmachte, wie in den Schulbüchern über die gemeinsame Geschichte geschrieben wird. Nämlich gab es da zunächst in Japan eine Tendenz, die China nicht gefallen hat. Und dann gab es Boykott-Aufrufe in Bezug auf japanische Produkte, nur weil in einem Schulbuch das und das stand. Und solche Streitigkeiten, die ziehen sich eigentlich durch und haben zugenommen. Und Vogelsang schreibt dann Folgendes in seinem Fazit. Vielleicht haben sich beide Länder in den letzten Jahrzehnten gerade deshalb so leidenschaftlich entzweit, weil sie sich so ähnlich geworden sind. Nicht in ihren politischen Systemen, aber auf vielen anderen Ebenen. China hat mit denselben Mitteln wie Japan ein ähnliches Wirtschaftswunder geschafft, wie dieses eine Generation zuvor. Der Warenkorb des chinesischen Exports entspricht heute weitgehend dem Japans von vor 30 Jahren. Jenseits aller Streitigkeiten um Schulbücher sind die Erziehungssysteme beider Länder einander frappierend ähnlich. Und gerade der virulente Nationalismus, der beide gegeneinander aufbringt, deutet in der Analogie seiner Formen eher auf Gemeinsamkeiten, denn auf Unterschiede.
Ich habe dazu auch noch eine Spekulation. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du davon hältst. Du kennst doch das Argument, Demokratien führen keinen Krieg gegeneinander. Irgendwas ist mit Demokratien, man weiß noch nicht so genau, was, großes Rätsel. Aber Demokratien führen keinen Krieg miteinander. Das einzige Mal war, glaube ich, das um die Falkland-Inseln als Argentinien gegen England oder so. Aber das war ja auch nur so Schabützel. Und eine rentenapublikanische These ist, Demokratien sind einfach zu wohlhabend. Und zwar nicht nur kollektiv, sondern auch individuell. Das heißt, mit wohlhabend sein, also mit dem Wohlstand, kommt das Schrumpfen der Familiengröße. Das heißt, so in, nehmen wir mal Iran vor 50 Jahren oder so, eine Frau, sieben Kinder. Wenn da einer zum Militär ging, war das so, ja gut, er ist jetzt beim Militär, stirbt dann, man hat ja immer noch sechs andere Kinder. Also man geht da anders um mit Opfer, Trauer und so weiter. Jetzt haben wir in Japan die niedrigste Geburtenrate auf der ganzen Welt. Da werden Frühchen in einem Stadion noch versucht zu retten. Das ist selbst in Europa undenkbar, weil man dann noch nicht vom Leben sprechen würde. In China haben wir jetzt gerade eine niedrigere Geburtszifferzahlen, egal was, es werden gerade weniger Kinder geboren, als auf dem Höhepunkt der Ein-Kind-Politik. China ist jetzt wirtschaftlich im Aufstieg begriffen. Das heißt, Frauen kümmern sich erst mal um ihre Biografie, statt um irgendwelche Kinder zu bekommen. Jetzt haben wir mit China und Japan zwei Länder, die es sich emotional nicht leisten können, auch nur ein Opfer in irgendeinem sinnlosen Scharmützel zu beklagen und zu betrauern. Das scheint dem Ganzen ein bisschen entgegenzustehen. Das, was du jetzt eingelesen hast, die Länder nähern sich kulturell an. Was sowieso schon mal dazu führt, dass zwar im Iran die Regierung dort Amerika hasst, aber die jungen Leute Instagram nutzen und gar nichts dafür übrig haben, einen großen Hass auf Amerika zu fahren, was der iranischen Regierung dort nicht gerade sehr gut gelegen kommt. Und wenn es solche ähnlichen Tendenzen auch zwischen China und Japan gibt, dass man da so Kulturräume teilt und überhaupt, kann es zwar noch dem Befehl geben, ihr fahrt jetzt mit dem Schiff darüber und dann wird wirklich mal ein Flugzeug abgeschossen oder so, aber das hätte so viele Nachwirkungen als Fernsehnachricht, als alles Mögliche, dass eigentlich eine Eskalation undenkbar ist.
Das heißt, du glaubst, dieser alte berühmte Spruch, stell dir vor es ist Krieg und keiner geht hin, dass der sich in gewisser Weise bewahrheitet in den Rentner-Republiken, weil tatsächlich jemand sagt, ich bin noch nicht bescheuert, jetzt da hinzugehen. Und die Eltern sagen, du bleibst mal schön, du bist unser einziger Sohn oder unsere einzige Tochter, bleib hier, du machst das jetzt mal lieber nicht. Und das ist sehr, sehr gut möglich. Also das ist eine sehr interessante Idee, die man, glaube ich, noch mal weiterverfolgen muss. Denn das zeigt sich ja in all diesen asiatischen Ländern, dass es jetzt da langsam auch das Thema Überalterung gibt. Ich meine, Südkorea sowieso schon. Die haben auch schon einen ganz, ganz klaren Nachfrage-Mangel. Deswegen ist da das Influencer-Marketing immer noch wichtiger als hier. Und in China haben wir, wie jetzt Ökonomen wie Branko Milanović auch schreiben, es auch mit dem Problem zu tun. Die haben zwar jetzt gerade diese Wahnsinnswachstumszahlen, die du auch genannt hast, aber in ein paar Jahren, wenn diese Überalterung dann sich wirklich spürbar bemerkbar macht, dann sind wir auch an einem Punkt, wo dieses Wachstum einfach nicht mehr sein kann. Also dann können diese Konsumvorstellungen, die man sich zwar erfüllen kann, jetzt noch ein Auto mal sich zu leisten, eine Flugreise sich zu leisten, all das, die können zwar noch eine Zeit lang darüber hinwegtäuschen. Das ist eigentlich schon auf Stagnation hinauslauft. Doch irgendwann ist dieser Punkt erreicht und dann würde nur ein Kinderreichtum dafür sorgen. Aber von dem ist nicht zu spüren und mit dem ist auch nicht zu rechnen. Insofern könnte sich auch damit dieses große chinesische Wachstumsversprechen wieder ein bisschen, ja nicht in Luft auflösen, aber ein bisschen abschwächen. Oder vielleicht kann man damit auch ein bisschen stärker verstehen, warum China so sehr daran interessiert ist, in Osteuropa Fuß zu fassen, in Afrika Fuß zu fassen. Denn die könnten ja sagen, naja, wir sind so viele Menschen, wir haben eine so tolle Binnenwirtschaft. Was interessieren uns die anderen? Das war ja mal eine kurze Zeit die Haltung gewesen. Aber Sie sehen jetzt plötzlich, naja, wenn wir hier überaltern, dann brauchen wir auch das, was Deutschland schon lange macht, nämlich wir brauchen das Denken einer Exportnation.
Ja, in China erreicht jetzt die allererste Generation überhaupt sowas wie ein Renteneintrittsalter. Es gibt in China keine Rentenpolitik, sowas wie in Deutschland, dass man so ganz selbstverständlich vom Einkommen was abzweigt und das wird dann in so ein Umlageverfahren. Und selbst wir haben damit Probleme, volkswirtschaftlicher, weil die demografische Kalkulation nicht aufgeht. In China gibt es nicht mal so ein System, sondern da wachsen die Leute jetzt in so eine Lebensphase nach dem Arbeits- nach dem Erwerbsleben hinein. Und man weiß überhaupt nicht, wie soll man das bezahlen. Selbst in Südkorea, also ein unfassbar armes Land, man denkt immer, hä, aber da ist doch Samsung. Und Samsung hat sich doch bereit erklärt, 8 Milliarden Euro umgerechnet Erbschaftssteuer zu bezahlen. Aber mehr als 50 Prozent der südkoreanischen Rentner leben in Armut. Da wird die Wohnung vom Staat gestellt. Da ist gar kein Markt mehr, dass man sagt, okay, sondern der Staat baut das Haus und weist es dir zu. Dann kriegst du so eine Wohnung im siebten Stock von irgendeinem Hochhaus-Ding. Und da leben die Alten. Also das sind alles so Sachen, auf die muss sich China auch vorbereiten. Das ganz schreckliche Vorbild für sie ist Vietnam. Denn Vietnam ist alt geworden, bevor es reich wurde. Und China tut gerade alles dafür, noch schnell reich zu werden, bevor man alt wird. Aber die Zeit rennt.
Ich bin ein bisschen mit Südkorea jetzt verwirrt, dass es da so groß ist mit der Armut.
Sind alle immer mal wieder überrascht, wenn man denkt, das ist doch so ein mega cooles Land, in dem doch alles so ziemlich gut funktioniert. Aber irgendwann muss man halt, ich meine, Südkorea ist ein Land, da ist innerhalb von 25 Jahren oder so die Kinderzahl von 6 auf 1, 2 oder so gefallen. Und irgendwann gab es, also dieser Baby-Boomer-Bauch, wir haben in Deutschland auch einen kleinen Baby-Boomer-Bauch, Japan hat einen richtigen Baby-Boomer-Bauch. Da kommt gerade von unten gar niemand nach, der in irgendeinem Umlagesystem oder so irgendwas beisteuern kann. Die Leute arbeiten sich da tot, können sich von ihrem Einkommen nichts leisten, kein Vermögen aufbauen, schaffen es gerade noch so ein bisschen, die eigene Oma über Wasser zu halten, aber ein soziales Umverteilungssystem, das sich wirklich trägt, das funktioniert da einfach nicht.
Eine große frauenfeindliche Politik und Gesellschaft, da gibt es auch richtig, richtig große Probleme. Unser Buch erscheint in Südkorea.
Das habe ich gesehen.
Es wird übersetzt. Ich bin gespannt. Vielleicht lernt man dann ein bisschen was darüber, was dann sein wird.
Sehr gut. Da kann man sich zumindest mal das Schriftbild angucken und dann denken, das ist Sprache? So, wollen wir mal gegen Ende zwei kleine Clips, die Europa betreffen. Ich fand es ganz überraschend in diesem ganzen Theater. Wer wird es denn jetzt? Laschet oder Söder? Was ich immer noch nicht für entschieden halte, übrigens.
Wie?
Ich hoffe sehr auf Laschet, weil man gegen ihn spektakulär gut Wahlkampf machen kann. Aber so richtig, glaube ich noch nicht, dass die CDU nicht doch noch mal angesteckt ist.
Ich muss jetzt mal gerade nachhaken, weil mich das etwas verwirrt. Also wenn ich die Nachrichten doch richtig rezipiert habe, ist es so, dass jetzt der Kanzlerkandidat Laschet ist. Gut, das wird noch mal irgendwo abgesegnet, aber eigentlich ist das...
Ja, die Umfragewerte kommen. Morgen kommt wieder eine, dann kommt übermorgen wieder eine, dann kommt nicht so hoch wie wieder eine. Die Grünen drei Prozent vorne, vier Prozent vorne, zwei Prozent, drei Prozent.
Du könntest dir jetzt vorstellen, dass die sagen, im Juni hilft alles nix, Söder muss ran.
Wer weiß. Ich will immer nichts ausschließen, die CDU... sag uns mal so... Angela Merkel geht und wir wissen alle nicht, was das bedeutet. Und die CDU weiß es auch nicht. Und die Termine, die Wahltermine sind da. Und die CDU wird noch im Anfang Juni in Sachsen-Anhalt wählen. Also dann entscheiden müssen, wie sie mit der AfD umgeht. Und ich würde sagen, sie ist zerrissen. Also die Bundestagswahl ist noch eine Weile hin und da ist noch einiges möglich. Aber jedenfalls, was ich sagen wollte, in diesem Streit darum, wer es denn da nun wird, war, nachdem es zu dieser CDU-CSU-Fraktionssitzung gab, die Markus Lanz sich danach immer wieder als, das war doch ein Massaker, oder bestätigen ließ in seiner Sendung, hat die CDU Roland oder wie auch immer heißt, Kiesewetter nach vorne geschickt, um mal so ein bisschen die medialen Geschäfte zu führen, nämlich für Ruhe zu sorgen, zu argumentieren, hier ist noch gar nichts passiert, zwar nur eine Fraktionssitzung, ja es ging ein bisschen hoch her und so, aber jetzt mal alle mal ruhig bleiben. Und um abzulenken vom Thema, hat er zweimal, und dort deswegen greife ich es auf, weil es eben nicht aus Versehen, sondern er hat es zweimal gemacht, einmal bei Lanz und einmal im Heuter-Journal, Folgendes gesagt.
Hier geht es um klare Haltung, um Zukunftsorientierung, um das Zusammenhalten der Gesellschaft und was mir als Außen- und Europapolitiker sehr am Herzen liegt, ab Herbst wollen Macron und Draghi, zwei überzeugte Europäer, die Zukunft Europas gestalten. Da muss Armin Laschet auf europäischer Ebene mitwirken. Wir können hier nicht alleine aus der Sicht der CSU ausschließlich der kleineren Schwester arbeiten. Das geht nur gemeinsam. Das Entscheidende ist doch, wie geht es ab Oktober weiter? Da gibt es ein Draghi in Italien, früherer EZB-Präsident und Macron in Frankreich. Wir müssen doch alles tun, dass Europa gemeinsam und stark aus der Krise kommt. Armin Laschet bringt seine Zeit aus dem Europaparlament mit. Er war im Bundestag. Er ist erfolgreicher Ministerpräsident. Und er wird gemeinsam mit Weber, dem Fraktionsvorsitzenden der EVP, mithelfen, dass wir gemeinsam am Strang ziehen, die Europäische Union aus der Krise zu führen.
Ah, die CDU entdeckt Europa.
Draghi und Macron sind natürlich ein Power-Couple. Das ist klar. Draghi hat die letzten Jahre, das kann man bei David McWilliams gut nachhören, Italien in eine wirklich neue Position gebracht mit dieser ganzen EZB-Buyout und so weiter Sache. Und Macron hat nächstes Jahr Wahlkampf.
Ja, und wir haben ja das Interview im Salon gelesen von Macron, was der eigentlich außer Merkel ausgeklammert von der CDU so wohl halten wird.
Das ist nicht viel. In der Hinsicht Angela Merkel geht da. Also hier ist noch einiges in Bewegung.
Aber ich kann mir das auch gar nicht vorstellen, diese Situation. Macron, Draghi und Laschet müssen jetzt über irgendwas diskutieren. Also dieses intellektuelle Gefälle muss doch auch immens sein. Das ist ja auch so der Punkt, wo man nicht mehr mit so einer Bauernschleue da irgendwie durchkommt, mit dem man noch so ein paar Landräte auf seine Seite ziehen kann.
Also ich kann mir Draghi und Macron wunderbar vorstellen. Auch mit einer richtig guten Idee, bei der sie auch wirklich sagen, es ist uns jetzt egal, ob Deutschland hier mitmacht. Das Dreiergesparen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, mit Laschet.
Das ist ja im Übrigen etwas, was ist ja immer wieder diese, also es gibt ja so eine Diskussion darüber. Es gibt Europa, aber es gibt ja da drin auch nochmal vielleicht so das Kern Europa und das ist ja meines Wissens eine Idee von George O'Argambon gewesen, dass man sagte, eigentlich sind doch die natürlichen Partner nicht Deutschland und Frankreich, sondern Frankreich und Italien und das wird dann Philosophie, geschichtliche und Katholizismus und alles Mögliche. Und dann war dann jemand wie Alain Badiou, der gesagt hat, nee, wegen Hegel und so müssen wir ja Deutschland und Frankreich zusammen denken. Aber ich sag mal, das ist nicht abgemacht, dass das jetzt immer Deutschland Frankreich sein muss. Insofern ist das mit einem solchen Team natürlich etwas, was dann für die CDU heikel werden könnte.
Wir sind da mal gespannt. Also ich bin da sehr gespannt, was da kommt. Gut, als allerletztes Thema habe ich mir was Lustiges rausgesucht. Topic Influenzerei. Manchmal gucke ich auf YouTube-Quatsch. Zum Beispiel von Producer Michael. Producer Michael hat vor Jahren mal Musik gemacht. So Eminem in seinen Anfangsstadien und so weiter. Hat damit irgendwie so ein bisschen Geld verdient. Er rangiert so im 30-40 Millionen Privatvermögen Range, fragt sich also seit einer Weile, was mache ich so mit meinem Leben und denkt sich, YouTube-Videos, ich mache YouTube-Videos. Also hat er sich einen Kameramann gebucht, der sein bester Kumpel geworden ist und die beiden touren jetzt durch Los Angeles und laden pro Woche ein, zwei Videos hoch, in dem sie einfach nur durch Supervillas gehen und sagen, für 15 Millionen kannst du das kaufen, für 35 Millionen kannst du das kaufen. Und dann laufen die einfach nur durch wahnsinnig große Häuser, die wahnsinnig viel Geld kosten, aber in Los Angeles gibt es unglaublich viele von diesen Häusern und die laufen da durch. Und ich gucke mir das dann manchmal an, das geht immer so eine halbe Stunde, denken wir dann so, das ist zwar alles wahnsinnig cool, aber das ist auch alles wahnsinnig hässlich. Also da kann man sich, also da kommt kein Neid auf, sagen wir uns mal so.
Du hast mir da oben einen Clip geschickt und ich will ja jemand, der durchaus sagt, ja, das ist ja ganz schön, wenn man sich was ausbreiten kann, aber wenn man diese Häuser sieht, das ist ja grauenhaft.
Genau, und darauf kommen wir jetzt zu sprechen auf The One. Denn manchmal kosten die Häuser ein bisschen mehr und Producer Michael ist zu irgendeinem Typ gefahren, der hat sich ein Haus gebaut, das 500 Millionen Euro Dollar kostet. Also unten am Hang sind so die Häuser, die man da sonst besucht, zwischen 15 und 75 Millionen und dann gibt es halt auch oben auf dem Berg eins, das kostet 500 Millionen. Und nur kurz zur Dimension, ein Clip solo, ein Stieg in dieses Video.
Der eine und einzige, Nile, der die Visionen hinter diesem Haus hat. Er hat das gebaut und er ist einfach ein unglaublicher Typ. Er zeigt uns, dass in dieser Hausart keine Kameras in ihrer Entity gesehen haben. Eher, immer, immer, immer.
So, 105.000 square feet sind umgerechnet 10.000 Quadratmeter. Oben auf dem Berg. Nile ist irgendwie so ein Immobilientyp da in Los Angeles. Und hat sich gedacht, ich baue mal für mich selber. Also hat er sich dieses Haus gebaut. Und wir gucken es jetzt. Also wir beide gucken es, die anderen hören es. Liebe Hörer, ihr verpasst nicht viel. Man kann es aber einfach suchen. The One, das eine. Bei YouTube, da kann man sich mal kurz durchscrollen.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie so eine Mischung aus Parkhaus und Philharmonie in Luxemburg.
Das könnte eine Uni sein, ein Hotel, eine Kanzlerfabrik oder was auch immer. Und wir gucken jetzt mal, ich habe es mal zusammengeschnitten, der einstündige Spaziergang durch dieses Haus. Den gucken wir jetzt mal in fünf Minuten. Hören genau zu, was da so ist, was da so gibt und so weiter und so fort. Und dann überlegen wir die ganze Zeit, warum, wozu, was soll das? Und dann klären wir das mal auf. Denn es ist wirklich Wahnsinn, wofür die, ob er superreich ist, klären wir gleich, wofür mittlerweile Reichtümer geschaffen werden, Vermögen, also im Sinne von Vermögen, wofür das geschaffen wird. Also, let's go.
Es war sehr wichtig für mich, dass die Hausfeier komfortabel und warm sind, das ist warum ich die wirklich schön warmen, zauberhaften Schrauben verwendet habe.
Ist das nicht die Voraussetzung? Ich bin überwältigt, du hast mich nie in einer Haus-Verwaltung gesehen. Ich bin überwältigt.
Das ist eine Sache, die wir gefunden haben. Alle meine Schrauben sind artificiell.
Das ist das hässlichste Foyer aller Zeiten. Es ist kalt. Es sind weiße Blumen in weißen Gläsern unter weißen Ständern. Und die sind künstlich. Es ist einfach nur bescheuert, aber gut.
Und dann steht irgendeine unnützte Skulptur noch im Raum.
Genau, irgendwas verdrehtes und so.
Ich habe mir.
Das ist nur ein Zimmer hier. Das ist einer der vielen, vielen, vielen Kitchens, aber wir haben hier ein Hauptkitchen.
Ja, wir sind jetzt draußen und da sieht man jetzt eine riesen Rasenfläche und dann sieht man ganz viel Beton und lange Wege, die man dann nehmen muss, um zum Beispiel zu irgendeinem Infinity Pool zu gelangen und dann geht es aber auch schon wieder weiter. Also man muss dann wieder an irgendwelchen Mäuerchen vorbei, um dann um das Haus rumzukönnen. Man läuft sich zu Tode da.
Ja, die zählen auch zwischendurch ihre Schritte, sind dann irgendwie bei 8000 oder so. Also es ist völlig Banane eigentlich.
Jetzt sind wir in so einem Barbecue-Bereich, der vermutlich so groß ist wie so fünf Buffalo-Steakhouse-Küchen, so würde ich jetzt mal einschätzen.
Ja, das ist so ein Mensa-Betrieb für tausend Leute.
Holder, Eisholder, Eismaschine, Fridge, Warming-Drohr, Dishwasher, Refrigerator, Dishwarfer, Warming-Drohr, Warming-Drohr, Warming-Drohr. Das ist ein Topf mit einer Rotisserie. Wir haben dort einen heißen Wagen, das ist der Grill.
Nein, nur einen Extraktor. Das ist industriell.
Ich meine, die Küche da draußen ist so groß, dass sie eine Dunstabzugshaube Outdoor haben.
Wenn du die Kamera umdrehst, werde ich dir ein kleines Überrasch geben, dass du das in deinem Leben noch nie gesehen hast.
Also der Swimmingpool hängt am Masterbedroom und schwebt in der Luft mit diesem Infinity-Charakter, das ist halt eine Glaswand, bis zu der du dann schwimmen kannst.
Ich meine, das ist ein echter Nachtclub.
Das ist kein Nachtclub in einer Haus. Das ist ein echter Nachtclub.
Das ist größer als die meisten Nachtclubs. Also zwei dieser Pots haben Feuerpistole in ihnen und wir haben Wasser, das über all Seiten und von oben rüberklappt. Du weißt, die Grundlage, warum das Haus so groß ist, ist nicht, weil das unser Ziel war, aber wir haben 40 Meter von der Nase auf den Berg genommen, um die Lahn viel größer zu machen. Das ist in der Luft. Das ist wie eine Schwimmpumpe von Konkret, die sechs Monate lang zu bewerben hat. Ich habe viele Häuser gebaut, die viele Leute sagen, dass es nicht genug Garage gibt, dass es nicht genug Staff gibt. Wir haben hier ein 50-Mit-Garage-Garage. Aber mein Lieblings-Party...
50 Autos in der Garage und der Nachtclub, der da gezeigt wurde, ist halt wie so eine Großraumdisco...
Auf 900 Leute ausmacht.
Es hat alle Techno-Gym-Equipment und eine Juice-Bar. Also das ist die Pool-Lounge. Pool-Table-Lounge.
Das ist es. Das Faszinierende daran ist ja, dass es wirklich nur die Vorstellungen sind, die man in den Kopf bekommt, wenn man in Luxushotels durch die Gegend reist. Also das ist ja nichts anderes. Es wird einfach immer nur eine Hotelatmosphäre in die private Räumlichkeit übertragen und diese dann nochmal ausgebreitet und man geht eigentlich durch ein leeres Hotel. Also man kann was ähnliches jetzt auch gerade erleben, da ja fast keine Gäste in den Hotels sind. Ich war ja kürzlich in Hannover in einem Hotel und da ich war jetzt nicht im Spa-Bereich und habe mir das angeguckt. Aber so wird es da auch aussehen. Da ist dann halt jetzt alles verwaist. Da ist noch Wasser im Pool, aber du kannst eigentlich gar nichts mehr machen, weil du ja eh nur geschäftlich hier bist und hier sein darfst. Und jetzt haben die dann da eine Kegelbahn. Aber wer wird jemals kegeln?
Genau, behalt das mal im Hinterkopf. Das ist schon genau die richtige Idee.
Oh Gott!
Das ist es. Das ist die Bowling Alley, Vorleht und dann ist das ein Golf Simulator. Es hat ein volles Dolby Atmos System. Es hat ungefähr 20 Subwoofers. Das ist unser Kandy-Ruhm, das sieht toll aus, wenn es alle mit verschiedenen Farben gefüllt wird.
Ja, ich meine, das ist so groß wie ein paar dieser kleineren Räume.
Ich habe nie so etwas in einem Haus erwartet.
Nein.
Ich meine, wenn ich in ein Filmtheater in LA gehen würde, würde ich nicht erwarten, dass es so groß ist.
Nein, ich meine, und ich gehe nur auf die Eye-Pics, weißt du was ich meine? Aber das kostet zehnmal mehr.
Was war der Kosten dieses Theaters? Wie viele Millionen? Das muss der echten Haus-Tour in der Geschichte sein.
Dort wohnen oder sonst irgendwas. Und es ist so durchgeknallt, dass dieses 500 Millionen Dollar teure Haus nur aus einem Grund geschaffen wurde. Und zwar als Instagram-Kulisse. Und es ist so wahnsinnig, welche Ausmaße dieses Denken jetzt mittlerweile annimmt. Es ist so, deswegen hatte ich sie ja auch geschickt. Der Typ macht halt da diese Führung, es ist das allererste Mal, entscheidet sich ganz bewusst für diesen Producer Michael, weil er auf YouTube genug Reichweite hat und auch schon die richtigen Leute zuschauen. Und dann geht man auf die Webseite von The One und da wird man dann gebeten, Name und E-Mail-Adresse dazu lassen. Man kann dann auch gleich hochladen, dass man, also eine Bank muss irgendwie beglaubigen, dass du das Verbürgen auch hast, um da einen Termin herzukriegen, um das mal zu besprechen. Und als weitere vierte Info, die man da abgefragt wird, ist über welchen Influencer hast du von unserem The One erfahren? Als ob du als, ich habe 500 Millionen, möchte gerne ein Haus kaufen, dann gehe ich erstmal zu meinen Influencern und gucke mir, was die mir so empfehlen. Also auf der Ebene ist mittlerweile das Influencertum angekommen, das er wissen möchte, über welchen Influencer jetzt die Super- also Milliardäre dann mitbekommen haben, dass es dieses Haus gibt. So und jetzt gucken wir ein Gespräch von Producer Michael mit diesem Nile, der darüber spricht. Und dieses Influencertum hat ein Ausmaß angenommen. Also hier geht es wirklich nur darum, eine Kulisse zu schaffen für diesen ganzen Social-Media-Scheiß, den wir die ganze Zeit machen. Aber wie er darüber spricht, das ist so abgehoben, es ist selten so etwas erlebt.
Ich glaube, ich sollte immer diese Hauskette schaffen.
Also er ist auserwählt, dieses Haus gebaut zu haben, denn dann kam Covid. Wir wissen, wo die Oscar dies Jahr verliehen wurden, nicht im Kodaktheater, sondern irgendwo in der U-Bahn oder so. Und er möchte sich hier ins Spiel bringen. Könnte das nicht in meinem Haus machen. Ich habe hier einen großen Rasen, alles da, hier kann man geile Aftershow-Party führen, hier haben die Leute immer eine geile Kulisse für ihren Social Media Auftritt. In die Richtung geht es auch weiter.
Das. Hör mal, der Kampf zwischen Floyd Mayweather und Manny Pacquiao hat 700 Millionen Dollar auf Pay-Per-View gemacht. Und ich werde die größten Untertitel in der Geschichte singen, aber ich werde auch Leute wie Chimila Sahotun, meine currente Frau, die es nicht klappt, aber wir sind ein Verbrechen, eine unglaubliche Sängerin, die auf dem Stadion singen wird, neben den größten Sängern der Welt. Aber weißt du, wer sonst neben ihnen singen wird? Whitney Houston, Michael Jackson, Prince und Elvis Presley, weil jede eine dieser Sängerin Holograms werden. Ich werde dieses Schiff kaufen, das ich den God-Schiff nenne, und es ist gigantisch. Weil ich viele Freunde habe, die Billionäre sind. Und du verstehst, wenn du 1 Billion Dollar hast, wie viel Geld du im Jahr machst, wenn es bei 5% ist, was wenn du 2 Billionen hast? Was wenn du 3 Billionen hast? Du kannst das Geld nie spenden. Ich habe einen Freund, der 3 Billionen Dollar hat. Und als ich in meinem Haus war, in der Höhe, und gesagt habe, ich habe kein Geld, um einen Cheeseburger zu kaufen, hat er mir nicht geholfen. Und ich habe dann entschieden, dass das nie zu jemanden passieren wird, den ich sehe, den ich vertraue, der eine gute Person ist. Es ist ausgetauscht und es ist verrückt, aber weißt du was? Und ich werde durch ein Lotto-System oder durch mein eigenes Auge verschiedene Leute wählen, um auf diesem Flugzeug nur einen Weg zu kommen.
Ja, ganz bescheiden hier nochmal. Aber ich würde sagen, das ist so typisch, was du hier ausgewählt hast. Also wenn ich die Info in Zerkultur beschreiben müsste, es ist genau das. Es ist auch dieser Anspruch, dass man die Welt verbessert, dass man alles, was man tut, eigentlich Gutes tut. Man ist nachhaltig. Man denkt natürlich sozial, weil man ja in sein Privatstädt auch noch andere Leute einlädt. Und wer würde nicht an Ökologie denken, wenn er dieses Haus dort sieht? Und das ist so unglaublich. Aber es ist genau diese Attitüde, mit der die Influencer kommen, um die Welt zu verbessern. Und natürlich ist es ein Riesengeschäft immer nur für sie. Aber sie sind und da komme ich doch immer mehr zu dem Schluss und habe auch mit Ole immer wieder darüber gesprochen. Oder wir kommen immer mehr dazu dem Schluss. Zu einem großen Teil glauben die sich das selbst. Die sind derart verblendet, dass sie sich selbst glauben. Es gibt vielleicht noch so ein paar raffiniert Kalkulierende, die sagen, gut, ich spiele irgendwie das trollige Mädchen, bin aber eigentlich ganz raffiniert. Das mag es noch hin und wieder geben. Aber ich glaube, dass die Ideologie bei denen auch inzwischen so sehr internalisiert ist und diese Selbstübersteigerung, dass sie das sich tatsächlich hier abkaufen und dass selbst noch ein solch unsinniges Projekt wie ein Haus für eine halbe Milliarde auch noch dann ein Programm zur Weltverbesserung ist. Und die Toten werden lebendig. Das erinnert ja auch an Blade Runner 2049. Da dreht sich ja auch Elvis Presley in so einer Endlosschleife in einem Hologramm und kommt dann nicht mehr raus.
Und dann sage noch einer, durch Corona sind wir nicht alle wahnsinnig geworden. Ich meine, der Typ hat irgendwann keine Häuser mehr verkauft. Der ist halt wirklich, ging das Geld aus. Und jetzt versucht er eben dieses Haus als Kulisse für Pay-Per-View, also irgend so ein über Social Media vermarktetes, was weiß ich, auch immer dazu vermarkten und eine Firma zu schaffen, in die dann alle rein investieren, um beim nächsten tollen Event in der ersten Reihe zu sitzen. Also es ist völlig wahnsinnig, aber irgendwie auch sehr aussagekräftig für unsere Zeit, glaube ich.
Ja, und für den Reichtum und für den sozialen Wohnungsbau, der ein bisschen ins Hintertreffen geraten ist. Also jetzt noch mal um das Ganze, wenn ich aufs Land ziehe, so groß sollte es dann nicht sein. Aber ich wette, wenn ich so eine Fläche zur Verfügung hätte, ich würde es auf jeden Fall geschmackvoller einrichten.
Alles wäre geschmackvoller als das. Das ist einfach zu clean. Aber wie gesagt, es ist halt nur Kulisse. Der Protagonist ist immer derjenige, der vorne im Bild steht. Und dadurch brauchst du es im Hintergrund so, als wäre es gezeichnet. Es ist halt, es ist wie die Anforderungen halt heute so sind.
Ja, und es ist so schön, es ist ein Mensch ohne Fantasien. Also er quatscht zwar davon Visionen, aber du merkst, dass er nicht einen einzigen originellen Gedanken hat, weil das Haus nur eine Kopie ist aus anderen Hotels. Also das ist so bezeichnend, dass wirklich alles einfach nur seine Doselege-Touristen-Welt ist, die er dort in dieses Haus reingebracht hat.
Deswegen empfehle ich euch, man muss ja auch immer mal abschalten, geistig. Guckt euch diesen YouTube-Kanal von Producer Michael an. Das sind Leute, die haben einfach zu viel Geld und die haben keine Ahnung von nichts. Die äußern nie einen klugen Gedanken. Die machen keine Anlehnung an irgendwas. Die stehen auf irgendwelchen Balkonen und sagen, das ist aber eine schöne Farbe, die gefällt mir richtig gut. Dann gehen die in den nächsten Raum und sagen, das ist aber ein toller Schreibtisch, der gefällt mir richtig gut. Und er weihrt wirklich eine Scherze, die mit nichts in Zusammenhang stehen, die nichts anlehnen, nichts, einfach, das ist ein ganz großes Nichts, ein ästhetisches Nichts. Und in deren Sicht kann man sich das einfach so nebenherdudelnd anschauen. Ich guck's ganz gerne. Und wenn es mal nicht um Häuser geht, geht es um Uhren oder um Stifte.
Ja, und bald ist ja auch bestimmt wieder Art Base Miami. Da kann man dann auch noch ein bisschen Plunder kaufen, den man da unterbringt.
Es ist wirklich ganz grotesker Müll und in deren Sicht ganz unterhaltsam. Gut, in einer Woche gehen wir in den Salon und lesen dort.
Alec MacGillis, und zwar hat er ein Buch geschrieben über Amazon. Und jetzt denkt man, na ja, eine Amazon Biografie haben wir doch. Der Allesverkäufer über Jeff Bezos. Ja, die gibt es und will man jetzt mal wissen, wie das Unternehmen funktioniert. Nee, das interessiert Alec MacGillis gar nicht. Er sagt, ich will Amerika erzählen, wie Amerika sich in den vergangenen 20, 30 Jahren entwickelt hat und wie es sich entwickeln wird und wie es in der Gegenwart gerade aussieht. Und mache das durch Amazon. Ich sage, dieses ganze Land ist Amazons Land. Und da fängt er damit an, dass er erst mal in Seattle ist. Also dort, wo der Hauptsitz von Amazon ist und zeigt, wie es Seattle sich entwickelt hat. Und macht das anhand von Protagonisten. Aber er geht dann wirklich in das gesamte Land hinaus. Das ist also eine Langzeitreportage. Auch zehn Jahre hat er an dem Buch gearbeitet. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Blick. Die Amazonisierung ist ja da noch viel weiter als hier. Und auf diese Weise mal ein Land zu vermessen und eine Gesellschaft zu vermessen und das immer unter dieser Amazonbrille zu sehen. Konzentration von Kapital, Ungleichheit, all das. Das scheint doch sehr aufregend zu sein.
Sehr gut, genau. Das lesen wir zusammen. Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, aber ich freue mich drauf. Ich weiß noch nicht, welche. Es gibt ganz schön viele. Also die Textqualität nimmt irgendwie zu. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwie Frühling ist oder so. Also es ist eine große Auswahl. Ich werde mal noch entscheiden. Außerdem am 27. vor zwei Tagen ist, nachdem ich ja immer auch dachte, die Elizabeth Warren, die geht ja ganz schön ran, wenn es hier Silicon Valley und so weiter mit ihrem Spruch, lieber alles zerschlagen. Ich habe keine Lust, mich mit den Details zu befassen. Das ist natürlich ganz schön hart. Aber wie der Scott Galloway immer wieder darauf hinweist in seinem Podcast mit KSW-Scha, Amy Klobuchar ist eigentlich diejenige, die tatsächlich die juristischen Texte vorantreibt, also die Gesetzentwürfe und so weiter und vor der sie wirklich Angst haben, Silicon Valley. Und stellt sich heraus, es ist fertig geworden, ihr 600 Seiten Buch Anti-Trust. Und das ist natürlich nicht nur ein Buch, sondern das ist eine Waffe und ich würde sagen, wir können es dann auch mal, vielleicht im Mai oder so, dann mal richtig lesen, das muss man nicht überstürzen. Ich werde mir allerdings die ersten ad hoc Rezensionen, die jetzt bis nächste Woche rauskommen, schon mal nehmen, weil ich so gespannt bin, wieso das Fade jetzt so aufbereitet wird und was so gesagt wird, da möchte ich mal an dieser, auch wenn ich noch nichts weiß sonst zu dem Buch und können wir dann einfach mal einfach noch mal einladen.
Dann machen wir das vielleicht im Mai, dass wir das dann als gemeinsame Lektüre sehen. Ich habe ein hochinteressantes Buch gelesen von Johann Chapoteau, das ist ein Franzose, der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Gehorsam macht frei. Und zwar schaut er sich an, wie war dein Management im Dritten Reich und da stellt sich heraus, naja, da haben ja manche ihre Karriere fortgesetzt dann und haben Management gelehrt in der Bundesrepublik. Und wenn man jetzt an den Nationalsozialismus denkt, dann hat man sofort straffe Regeln, Hierarchie und all das vor Augen. Und das hat doch gar nichts mit so modernen Management zu tun, mit Flexibilität und jeder soll mal eigenverantwortlich arbeiten. Doch, auch das ist nationalsozialistische Herrschaft gewesen. Und das ist ein sehr provokantes, aber sehr gut aufbereitetes Buch, das ich sehr empfehlen kann. Und wirft doch noch mal einen Blick auf unsere aktuellen Management Theorien ganz gut. Naja, und dann gibt es eine große Studie über die Mediennutzung, wie sich das verändert hat. Und das hat sich verändert, nur mal so viel. Also es gibt nicht mehr diese übliche Entwicklung. Man ist halt in jungen Jahren vielleicht bei Social Media und so unterwegs, aber dann gibt es irgendwann den Weg hin zu den konservativeren, also den traditionelleren Medien, Fernsehen und so. Sondern da hat sich ja einiges verändert und ja, den Rest schauen wir mal.
Ja, interessant, weil die habe ich ja auch auf dem Schirm. Man dachte ja immer, dem Fernsehen geht es schlecht, weil Netflix aufblüht, aber nein, Netflix geht es auch schlecht, weil die Jungen dann gar nicht nachwachsen. Die wollen einfach dieses gar nicht mehr so haben, wie man immer dachte. Das ist einfach nur Internet und so. Ja, sehr gut. Ja, dann wird es ein toller Salon, gibt es dann nächste Woche. Und für heute haben wir den April hier besiegelt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, einen schönen Monat wünschen wir.
Yes, haut rein.
Bis bald.
Bis dann.